[Musique]
bonjour à tous il est 14h30 nous sommes
en direct sur l'antenne de public Sénart
vous savez la chaîne se mobilise pour
vous faire vivre autour d'un grand
direct l'examen de la réforme des
retraites au Sénat je vous signale
d'ailleurs que vous pouvez lire les
analyses des débats sur notre site c'est
public c'est un point FR pour
m'accompagner toute cette après-midi je
suis en compagnie de Mathias sarez notre
journée en tribune de presse bonjour à
vous Mathias bonjour Quentin il reste
environ 600 amendements examinés à
l'heure où l'entend un que la cloche
vient de retentir tout va donc se jouer
dans les prochaines heures et ce matin
encore on a vu des débats animés dans
l'hémicycle oui Quentin des débats
animés encore ce samedi matin vous
l'aurez compris la gauche déjà mal
l'utilisation par le gouvernement de
l'article 44 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
une gauche qui a décidé de le rappeler à
chacune de ces prises de parole depuis
ce matin
vous avez décidé de dévitaliser la
fonction parlementaire
par l'addition de toutes les procédures
que vous offre la constitution et le
règlement vous espériez sans doute que
nous laissions la retraite des Français
entre les mains des droites coalisées
nous sommes pas dupe et les Français
n'ont plus une lâcherons rien nous ne
lâcherons pas vous avez décidé de
dévitaliser la fonction parlementaire
par l'addition de toutes les procédures
que vous offre la constitution et le
règlement vous espériez que nous
laissions le sujet des retraites et les
retraites des Français entre les seuls
mains vont seulement des droits de
coalisées mais nous ne sommes pas dupes
et les Français non plus nous ne
lâcherons rien nous ne les lâcherons pas
alors oui cet article de la Constitution
est vécu comme un une clé de bras au
parlementarisme par la gauche mais sur
certains bancs de cette même gauche on y
voit aussi une stratégie du gouvernement
contre son allié dans cette affaire la
droite sénatoriale
et en fin de compte l'amendement visé
par l'article 44 3 de quel amendement le
gouvernement ne veut pas
c'est probablement celui de Monsieur
Retailleau nous verrons tout à l'heure
d'ailleurs s'il est maintenu pas
maintenu ce que le gouvernement fera et
en fin de compte ça vous arrange bien
qu'on soit là parce que ça vous permet
de faire croire aux Français que c'est
nous la gauche qui vous avons poussé aux
44 3 alors que ceci n'est qu'une affaire
entre le gouvernement et la droite la
plus dure à l'encontre des salariés
celles qui vont mettre fin aujourd'hui
au régime spéciaux c'est donc l'article
13 dans lequel la rappeler Laurence
Rossignol se trouve l'amendement du
patron des LR ici Bruno Retailleau donc
deux stratégies à présent s'offrent au
sénateur vendéen retirer son amendement
et faire tomber plus de 200 sous
amendements de la gauche ou le défendre
et tenir tête au gouvernement
les explications on suivra ce qui se
joue autour de l'amendement insignée en
premier signataire par Bruno Retailleau
sur l'accélération de la fin de la
clause du grand-père c'est de ça dont il
s'agit c'est donc après l'article 13
l'article qui est en train d'être
examiné dans l'hémicycle on va
d'ailleurs s'y rendre on parle donc
transition emploi retraite c'est à dire
cumulant retraite et retraite
progressive retournant les débats
pesticides le bénéfice pardon de la
retraite progressive il faudrait faire
du passage à temps partiel dans le cadre
de la retraite progressive un droit
opposable faute de quoi le dispositif ne
bénéficiera qu'à une poignée de salariés
au risque d'alimenter une logique
profondément inégalités avec la retraite
progressive il n'y a pas que la question
l'intensité du travail il y a aussi
celle de la liberté de choisir le moment
et la manière de partir en retraite au
regard des conséquences sur le montant
de la pension le recul de l'âge légal à
64 ans contraint vraiment les les
personnes à travailler donc comme on l'a
dit plus longtemps c'est
particulièrement injuste à enferme les
travailleurs et les travailleuses dans
un dans un carcan c'est à dire ils ont
le choix avec une retraite trop petite
et de devoir en plus s'user davantage à
travailler l'aménagement du temps de
travail en fin de carrière ne peut être
limitée un refus de l'employeur sans
explication aux salariés pour ces
raisons nous demandons à minima que ça
soit stipulé par écrit j'ai bien un
minima parce que vous l'aurez compris
toutes nos interventions visent à
demander le retrait de cette réforme et
nous sommes solidaires des
manifestations qui ont lieu partout dans
le pays aujourd'hui encore merci avis de
la commission
il est satisfait cet amendement madame
Cohen
voilà donc avis défavorable parce que
satisfait c'est le droit actuel
ce ministre merci quatre amendements de
discussion communes le 4021 qui
représente madame Cohen
on vient de enfin je viens de on peut
dire qu'il est qu'il est défendu et
j'adore quand même la logique qui
préside à anodas c'est-à-dire on est en
train de faire comme si de rien n'était
on commente des des amendements qui en
fait son virtuel puisqu'ils n'ont pas
été retenus et on arrive à nous dire que
ils sont satisfaits qu'il faut passer
assez moi je trouve que c'est lunaire
le 2171 rédactionnelle monsieur le
rapporteur
merci le 318 qui le défend
ait n'est pas là Monsieur Ferro oui
merci Monsieur le merci monsieur le
Président excusez-moi je ne pensais pas
que cet amendement présenté par David
hassouline arriverait si vite cet
amendement il vise à prévoir le la
consultation du comité national
consultatif des personnes handicapées
avant que le gouvernement ne prenne un
décret sur les conditions de cumul de la
pension d'invalidité avec une retraite
progressive nous avons présenté cet
amendement dans le but
d'enrichir et de préciser le texte mais
il ne pourra pas être soumis au vote
puisque comme vous le savez maintenant
par cœur je pense vous avez des idées de
dévitaliser la fonction parlementaire
par l'addition de toutes les procédures
que vous offre la constitution et le
règlement
d'ailleurs le journal Le Monde de cet
après-midi titre
les débats anesthésiés au Sénat
le 2920 madame Lubin merci monsieur le
Président c'est amendement porte sur la
formation professionnelle mais moi je
voudrais profiter de ce temps de parole
pour dire à Monsieur Savary un autre
rapporteur d'abord que le la retraite
progressive moi je trouve que c'est un
dispositif intéressant et il le sait à
la condition que ce soit encadrée que
l'on veille à ce que les salariés ne
perdent ne perdent rien s'il vous plaît
c'est compliqué ne perde rien en matière
de de revenus à côté c'est à dire que le
complément bon voilà par contre je suis
je ne suis pas du tout favorable au
cumul emploi retraite
parce que surtout lorsqu'il est présenté
surtout lorsqu'il est présenté comme une
alternative à l'emploi des seniors ou
comme une solution pour l'emploi des
seniors ce qui était le cas au début de
l'annonce de ce de ce projet de loi
pourquoi parce que le problème de
l'emploi des seniors c'est justement
qu'à partir de 55 ans ils n'ont pas
d'emploi donc ça n'est pas le fait
qu'ils cumule que ceux qui arrivent à la
retraite cumulent avec un emploi qui
apportera de l'emploi au seniors on est
bien d'accord donc je considère que pour
la plupart du temps la plupart du temps
ceux qui sont obligés de cumuler un
emploi avec une retraite sont ceux qui
ont des retraites extrêmement modestes
d'autres le font par passion de leur
métier je ne le dis pas mais ça n'est
quand même pas le le la majorité on va
dire des salariés qui cumulent retraite
et
retraite et emploi voilà ce que je
voulais dire et vous et vous dire
Monsieur le Rapporteur que je sais que
vous êtes passionné par votre par le
sujet mais je trouve que ce n'est pas
tout à fait loyal de nous asséner tout
ce que vous nous asseinez parce que nous
ne pouvons pas répondre or nous avons
des arguments
à vous opposer voilà la passion je crois
que nous sommes quelques-uns à la voir
et nous avons des arguments à vous
opposer voilà merci merci Madame Lubin
je vais donner la parole aux rapporteur
alors pour aller non pas dans le sens de
Madame Lubin mais monsieur le rapporteur
merci de ne pas poser de questions
puisque par définition les élus ne
peuvent pas vous répondre
j'ai effectivement un sens du débat qui
est bien différent vous dire quand même
que
merci monsieur le Président le
Gouvernement est favorable de 1171 du
rapporteur et défavorable 3 autres
amendements pour les mêmes raisons
merci
monsieur le rapporteur 2572
rédactionnelle
coordination c'est le Ministre merci
amendement du Gouvernement monsieur le
ministre le rédactionnel
merci
Madame ponts et mange le 31 39
merci monsieur le Président alors
effectivement nous nous soutenons
beaucoup le dispositif de transition
emploi retraite quelle est la retraite
progressive à la différence du cumul en
poireaux traite c'est nous pensons une
transition vertueuse la retraite
progressive est un dispositif essentiel
pour le maintien en emploi des seniors
et la prise en compte de l'accroissement
de leur vulnérabilité face aux risques
dont les risques psychosociaux de fait
selon les chercheurs servent volcov
c'est Corinne Godard beaucoup de seniors
se maintiennent en activité
professionnelle à condition de disposer
d'aménagement du temps qui leur
conviennent la sortie d'un système
contraignant d'horaires ou Dory mais
alors pour ces personnes une condition
pour ne pas sortir de la vie active donc
afin de prévenir l'augmentation des
risques et de permettre un maximum de
personnes de profiter de la retraite
progressive il est important en
conséquence que l'âge d'accès au
dispositif soit maintenu
[Musique]
vous espériez sans doute que nous
laissions la retraite des Français entre
vous-même nous ne sommes pas du les
Français non plus ils sont dans la rue
aujourd'hui nous ne lâcherons rien nous
les lâcherons pas j'espère pas ou look
ma tradition de son peuple est exacte
c'est terminé madame
et merci de faire en sorte que
finalement les SMS ça fonctionne bien
allez
avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur sur le 3139 la solution qu'à
retenue la commission puisque nous
proposons de faire un dispositif qui
serait commun à tout public mais on
avait envisagé cette solution avec une
différence c'est le droit actuel en fait
par rapport aux droits prochains que
propose le gouvernement donc la vie
défavorable
le 2173 rédactionnaires
le 2174 coordination
le 2175 coordination le 2176
coordination le 2177 rédactionnelle cinq
amendements identiques
le Gouvernement est favorable surtout ça
ben oui
allez
cinq amendements identiques maintenant
le 40 rectifié monsieur Cabanel merci
monsieur le Président
chers collègues monsieur le ministre la
retraite progressive est un dispositif
qui permet une bonne transition entre
emploi et retraite il est pourtant très
peu utilisé aussi l'article 13 visa
faciliter les conditions d'accès à ce
dispositif notamment en encadrant plus
strictement le refus de l'employeur dans
le cadre de demande de salariés qui
souhaitent en bénéficier ainsi celui-ci
ne pourra intervenir que lorsque la
quantité de travail souhaitée était
incompatible avec l'activité économique
de l'entreprise l'employeur devra
adresser son refus aux salariés dans les
deux mois en revanche le texte ne
précise pas que l'employeur doit motiver
son refus aux salariés l'employeur
pourrait en conséquence adresser un
refus salarié sans justifier de
l'incompatibilité du temps partiel avec
l'activité économique de l'entreprise
voire sans même donner de justification
aussi afin de s'assurer de la
réalification
du dispositif l'amendement précise que
l'employeur doit motiver son reçu son
refus pardon aux salariés par écrit
c'est le centre de qui le défend madame
madame la Présidente merci monsieur le
Président donc c'est un amendement
identique déposé par notre collègue de
midi donc il est défendu par notre
collègue Cabanel merci c'est
le suivant le 2360 madame vermeiller
pardon oui monsieur le Président
amendement identique de Michel Calvet il
est défendu merci
ensuite madame Lubin le 2642 ah pardon
pardon pardon monsieur Tissot je vous en
prie monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues à mon tour
de m'adresser à vous et de vous dire que
vous avez décidé de dévitaliser la
fonction parlementaire par l'addition de
toutes les procédures que vous offre la
constitution et le règlement vous
espériez sans doute on vous l'a dit
plein de fois que nous laissions la
retraite des Français entre les mains
des droites locaux alizés nous ne sommes
pas dupe les Français n'ont plus nous
lâcherons rien nous ne lâcherons pas et
c'est donc pour ça que je vais vous
présenter cet amendement le projet de
loi encadre la possibilité de refus du
temps partiel de l'employeur dans le
cadre de demande de salariés souhaitant
bénéficier de la regrette progressive en
vertu des règles introduites l'employeur
ne pourra refuser le temps partiel que
lorsque la quantité de travail souhaitée
est incompatible avec l'activité
économique de l'entreprise et devra
adresser son refus aux salariés dans les
deux mois or le projet de loi ne précise
pas que l'employeur doit motiver son
refus aux salariés l'employeur pourrait
en conséquence adresser un ressources
salarié sans justifier de
l'incompatibilité du temps partiel avec
l'activité économique de l'entreprise
voir sans même donner de justification
or pour que la mesure introduite par le
projet de loi est une réelle efficacité
en pratique l'amendement précise que
l'employeur doit motiver son refus aux
salariés par écrit Merci monsieur merci
chers collègues le
3441 madame ponce
merci monsieur le Président ce projet de
loi donc en cas de les possibilités de
refus de temps partiel en permettant à
l'employeur de le refuser ce temps
partiel lorsque ce serait incompatible
avec l'activité économique de
l'entreprise sans aucune justification
pour que cela ne soit pas totalement
discriminé discrétionnel je vous propose
par cet amendement d'imposer que
l'employeur motive son refus aux
salariés par écrit il y aura donc un
écrit c'est un amendement que nous avons
reçu de la part des organisations
syndicales pas très respectée de nos
jours il est vrai mais nous tenons à
déposer parce que nous respectons leurs
paroles et surtout leur revendications
cependant j'avais un autre amendement il
a été déclaré ircevable comme beaucoup
vous allez me dire qui allait encore
plus loin et qui proposait de supprimer
la possibilité pour l'employeur de ne
pas donner suite à cette demande parce
que c'est souvent la condition de
maintien en emploi du travailleur senior
ou tout simplement la sauvegarde quand
même de sa santé selon l'adresse en 2020
le dispositif de retraite progressif
concernait 24000 personnes ce qui est
vraiment une honte il est selon les
termes de la dresse très marginale
voulons-nous vraiment que plus de
personnes puissent disposer de la
retraite progressive à temps partiel qui
est un dispositif vertueux de transition
entrant l'emploi il a retraite voilà une
solution simple supprimer la possibilité
pour l'employeur il a ce salarié de ne
pas donner suite à sa demande de rester
dans l'entreprise de maintenir son
emploi
en passant à temps partiel c'est ne pas
c'est ne pas lui permettre de se reposer
enfin se reposer parallèlement au
travail après une vie entière de labeur
donc voilà nous aurions aimé discuter de
cette mesure mais nous ne le pourrons
pas par ailleurs Paulus sans tout Paris
me dit que j'ai très bien traduit
qui voulait vous dire
alors c'est quand même l'essentiel
monsieur le rapporteur c'est 5
amendements identiques
oui effectivement la commission
également c'est penché sur cette affaire
là parce que dans le les propositions
gouvernementales la réponse le refus en
tout cas de l'employeur doit être motivé
voilà alors là vous pré vous vouliez
préciser une réponse écrite et motivée
où on avait pas retenu mais bon ça peut
ça peut être effectivement une précision
pourquoi pas écouter moi je vais
demander la vie au gouvernement pour
avoir sa position par là mais dans la
première réflexion de la commission des
affaires sociales c'était une réponse
défavorable mais
ça ne peut pas être oral non plus alors
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre merci à Monsieur le Président
le gouvernement considère que la
précision est utile c'est un avis
favorable et nous avons intégré ces
amendements dans le texte qui sera
soumis au vote unique de votre assemblée
très bien allez allez allez
le 430 qui représente monsieur Fabien
gay monsieur gay vous avez la parole
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous ne
sommes pas d'accord monsieur le
Président et il y a un affrontement de
classe aigu ici qui joue dans
l'hémicycle comme dehors mais peut-être
qu'on pourra se mettre d'accord tous
ensemble sur une chose le Sénat n'est
pas un îlot complètement sorti de la
société et moi je veux saluer les
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
se mobilisent pour la 7e journée
consécutive qu'on ne se réforme unique
des retraites et il faut leur dire une
chose vous pouvez vous moquer de nous
nous méprisez nous maltraités tentez de
nous bâillonner de nous piétiner mais je
vous le dis une chose
si si on le vit comme ça écoutez on peut
entendre ce que nous avons à dire vous
pouvez faire tout cela mais nous
resterons dignes et debout jusqu'au bout
pas pour nous pas pour nos petites
personnes mais pour les centaines de
milliers de personnes qui sont en train
aujourd'hui même de se battre partout
dans la rue à Paris comme dans vos
villes et villages et nous continuerons
jusqu'au bout il reste 641 à maman
jusqu'au bout a donné nos arguments
jusqu'au 20e article parce que nous
faisons nous pas pour nous-mêmes mais
pour toutes celles et ceux qui se
mobilisent et qui sont majoritaires
alors que vous êtes une poignée
aujourd'hui à vouloir cette loi et je
dis et je finis une question à monsieur
le rapporteur il pourra pas me répondre
et m'interpeller mais je lui pose
comment va jouer la CMP à 14 dans une
salle mercredi prochain il va falloir
nous dire et l'expliquer non pas à nous
mais aux françaises et aux Français qui
se Mobil parce que si vous pensez que
vous allez régler cette question
politique à 14 minoritaires dans une
salle et que tout le monde va avaler ça
vous vous trompez et nous resterons
mobilisés jusqu'au retrait de cette
réforme je vous remercie monsieur le
président
[Applaudissements]
bon allez on va pas créer de problèmes
vous connaîtrez monsieur Fabien je suis
pas sûr vous ayez vraiment défendu
l'amendement mais bon on va considérer
que oui et que la vie du rapporteur
négatif
allez-y monsieur le rapporteur
je donnerai la vie du rapporteur quand
même sur un objet important puisque là
c'est l'inverse dans les dispositions
c'est une suppression des dispositions
qui prévoit que le refus par l'employeur
de la demande de retraite progressive du
salarié doit être soit justifiée tout à
l'heure on dit que elle doit être
justifiée motivée et par écrit et là non
ça doit pas être c'est l'inverse
voyez-vous alors la gauche unie se
désunit me semble-t-il à travers cet
amendement et simplement sans répondre
sans répondre
à mon collègue je rappellerai simplement
que les conclusions de CMP sont ensuite
présentés à chacune des assemblées quant
à l'Assemblée nationale qu'au Sénat
[Musique]
tu avais du gouvernement sur
l'amendement
merci
et je l'entends même pas la vie et et oh
je n'entends même pas la vie du
gouvernement ou du rapporteur si tout le
monde parle en même temps alors reste
merci Monsieur gay de rester calme ça va
avancer deux amendements discussion
commune le 400039
le 400039 je vous en prie oui monsieur
le président
six manifestations historiques
90% des actifs opposés à la retraite à
64 ans et votre seule réponse est le
mépris mépris envers l'opposition
sénatoriale et surtout mépris du
président de la République envers les
syndicats qu'il refuse de recevoir
mépris envers les salariés envers les
Français votre votre projet n'est pas
légitime retirez-le notre amendement
celui que nous allons présenter
maintenant visa supprimé l'alinéa 161 de
l'article 13 je suis étonnée que la
commission des affaires sociales du
Sénat ne propose pas de supprimer cette
disposition alors même que les rapports
prévoient je cite la commission regrette
toutefois que l'âge d'éligibilité au
dispositif soit porté de 60 à 62 ans
considérant que la retraite progressive
doit constituer un outil de prise en
compte des carrières terrible en
permettant la légende de la charge de
travail de l'assuré en fin de carrière
elle a adopté un amendement 2168 du
rapporteur prévoyant le maintien de
l'âge d'éligibilité à 60 ans pour les
bénéficiaires actuels de ce dispositif
comme pour les nouveaux donc si la
majorité sénatoriale est favorable au
dispositifs de regret progressive il
faut créer les conditions pour permettre
son application effective dans le sens
de cette c'est le sens de notre
amendement qui supprime la possibilité
pour l'employeur de refuser la retraite
progressive à temps partiel en raison de
l'incompatibilité de la durée souhaitée
par le salarié avec l'activité
économique de l'entreprise quelles sont
les raisons de cet amendement merci en
discussion commune le 4041 qui le
présente oui pardon
merci monsieur le Président six
manifestations historiques 90% des
actifs opposés à la retraite à 64 ans et
votre seule réponse c'est le mépris
mépris envers l'opposition sénatoriale
et pire mépris du président de la
République envers les syndicats qu'il
refuse de recevoir mépris envers les
salariés et les Français votre projet
n'est pas légitime retirez-le car si
nous souscrivons à l'idée d'élargir le
bénéfice de la retraite progressive à
l'ensemble des assurés le dispositif est
vidé de sa substance par la possibilité
laissée à l'employeur de refuser aux
salariés le bénéfice de la retraite
progressive s'il juge que le temps
partiel demandé est incompatible avec
l'activité de l'entreprise autant dire
que ça va fermer pas mal de portes il
faudrait au contraire faire du passage à
temps partiel dans le cadre de la
retraite progressive un droit opposable
faute de quoi ce dispositif ce
dispositif pardon ne bénéficiera qu'à
une poignée de salariés et je pense
notamment aux cadres qui sont par
exemple souvent au forfait pour les
métiers à forte pénibilité cette
aspiration à la réduction du temps de
travail avant d'arriver en retraite est
plus que justifiée la pratique des
entreprises consistant à licencier les
seniors peut être contrecarré par le
bénéfice de la retraite progressive
encore faut-il garantir aux salariés qui
en font la demande leur garantir qu'il
puisse avoir une possibilité de
contester devant les conseils de
prud'hommes le refus éventuel de leur
employeur je vous remercie merci avis du
rapporteur sur ces deux amendements
discussion communes
4039 à la retour en salle des
conférences nous sommes en direct pour
suivre l'examen de la réforme des
retraites au Sénat on va rejoindre
mathiasarez mathiasarez pour les
téléspectateurs qui nous rejoignent il y
a quelque chose de très important qui va
s'ouvrir dans l'hémicycle dans quelques
minutes n'est ce pas absolument c'est le
fameux amendement Retailleau qui a t'en
fait parler et bien il pourrait être
débattu d'ici quelques alors c'est un
amendement vous le savez pour accélérer
la convergence des régimes spéciaux vers
le régime général en clair supprimer la
clause du grand-père cher au
gouvernement et bien cet amendement qui
n'avait pas été débattu lors des
discussions sur les régimes spéciaux
mais qui avait été placé après l'article
7 dans une dans une dans un objectif de
de stratégie et bien il avait été
replacé de nouveau après l'article 13 et
de fait cet amendement et bien il s'est
fait prendre au piège du vote bloqué
voulu par le gouvernement l'exécutif ne
l'ayant pas retenu non plus pour le vote
final reste à savoir si la droite
sénatoriale ici prétend le retirer pour
accélérer les débats en faisant tomber
plus de 200 sous amendements ou bien le
défendre pour tenir tête à l'exécutif
voilà on le voit c'est un amendement
très important va-t-il être soutenu
alors en l'occurrence Bruno retail au
chef de fil la destinataire elle n'est
pas présent aujourd'hui au Sénat ce sera
donc un autre LR qui est le défendra
s'il est donc défendu ou s'il est retiré
on va voir on va suivre ça
oui merci merci monsieur le Président
déjà apporté ma totale solidarité avec
l'ensemble des Françaises et des
Français qui défilent partout en France
aujourd'hui six manifestations
historiques 90% des actifs opposés à la
retraite à 64 ans et votre seule réponse
votre seule réponse c'est le mépris le
mépris envers l'opposition sénatoriale
et surtout le mépris du président de la
République envers les syndicats qui
refusent de recevoir mes prix envers les
salariés et les Français votre projet
n'est pas légitime retirez-le
l'amendement que je m'apprête maintenant
à défendre et qui a été déposé par le
groupe écologiste vise à demander au
gouvernement un rapport je sais ce que
vous pensez des rapports mais ça me
paraît important suivant la promulgation
de cette un rapport excusez-moi qui
présente les différentes options
législatives ou réglementaires
permettant la diminution de la durée
maximum de suspension entre la demande
de liquidation de la mise en place d'un
cumul emploi retraite si l'article 13 de
ce projet de réforme des retraites vise
à rendre le dispositif de cumul emploi
retraite créateur de droit il faudrait
également faire en sorte de réduire le
délai de carence avant la mise en place
d'accumul emploi retraite comment donc
au Parlement de remettre un rapport pour
étudier les options qui permettraient de
diminuer le temps d'attente entre la
demande de liquidation et la mise en
place de ce dispositif de cumul emploi
retraite nous souhaitons tout de même
réitérer notre avis sur ce dispositif de
cumulant par tête qui n'est pas une
solution puisqu'il est très inégalitaire
et en effet nous l'avons déjà dit à de
multiples reprises ce dispositif ne
bénéficie majoritairement qu'aux
personnes qui ont occupé un emploi de
cadre sont en bonne santé et ont une
pension de retraite correcte ce
dispositif va précariser encore un peu
plus les retraités qui ont de petites
pensions et pousser les plus pauvres à
travailler au-delà de 64 ans encore une
fois la priorité du gouvernement et de
la majorité des satoriales ne devrait
être plutôt de corriger les inégalités
de carrière qui concernent
majoritairement les femmes et
d'augmenter les pensions de retraite qui
sont largement insuffisantes cet
articlement campus de forcer les
Françaises et les Français à travailler
deux ans de plus le gouvernement refuse
d'augmenter les pensions et pousser les
Français les plus précaires à travailler
au delà de 64 ans merci monsieur le
Président avis de la commission
la Commission a gardé ce délai de six
mois pour que le dispositif de surcotte
soit plus insubitatif que le dispositif
de cumul emploi retraite donc à vider
favorable
merci avis du gouvernement mais ma vie
l'amendement
2057 rectifié bis présenté par Bruno
retailleux plusieurs de ses collègues a
été retiré
je
[Musique]
voilà je je pressentais je pressentais
un mouvement de joie
je remercie une partie voilà très bien
allez
c'est comme ça donc l'amendement 2057 a
été retiré non mais monsieur gay
chacun fait oui dans mes bons allez
bravo vous vous en rêviez il l'a fait
voilà allez
[Musique]
et nous passons et nous passons en
conséquence allez allez on se calme à la
discussion de l'amendement 1369
de madame la Présidente billon
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la loi du 9
novembre 2010 portant sur la réforme des
retraites a créé un dispositif
d'informations à destination des assurés
l'entretien information retraite ces
modalités ont été précisées par le
décret du 31 décembre 2011 relative à la
mise en oeuvre des prestations du droit
à l'information des assurés sur la
retraite ce dispositif permet aux
assurés de plus de 45 ans d'obtenir à
leur demande
vous venez de le vivre en direct cet
amendement de Bruno retaillod dont on
parlait depuis mardi sur la fin de la
clause du grand-père cet amendement et
vu qu'il avait fait débat déjà il y a
quelques jours il a été retiré par les
LR et en conséquence plus de 160 sous
amendements de la gauche viennent des
facto et automatiquement de tomber cela
signifie 5 heures de débats en moins
pour la gauche qui voulait monter au
créneau pour dénoncer cette mesure de la
droite des républicains mais donc on a
entendu que cela avait ému dans
l'hémicycle les cas la gauche vient de
subir et bien une forme de contrecoup
stratégique puisqu'elle perd 5 heures de
temps de débat pour s'opposer à la
réforme des retraites retour dans
l'émission dont la durée d'assurance est
inférieure à 10 années et de leur
proposer un entretien d'informations
adaptée à leur situation je vous
remercie monsieur le Président Madame la
Présidente vous avez le 1400 qui est en
discussion commune
c'est un amendement de repli monsieur le
Président je le considère comme défendu
merci c'est avis de la commission sur
ces deux amendements écoutez nous avons
pensé que les dispositions actuelles en
ce qui concerne l'information suffisait
suffisait c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons donné un avis défavorable
merci avis du gouvernement merci
monsieur le Président sur le 1401 la vie
défavorable mais sur le 1369 qui prévoit
un entretien pour les assurer qui ont
moins de 10 ans de cotisations à 45 ans
la vie est favorable
merci donc avis favorable du
Gouvernement je passe aux 400054 qui le
défend
je pense que au-delà du fait que
l'objectif étant de faire tomber 200 ans
sous amendements je pense que la réalité
c'est aussi qu'il craint d'être
minoritaire dans cette émission croyez
le bien croyez le bien monsieur
rotaillon nous allons continuer en tout
cas à vous mettre en difficulté en
minorité dans tout le pays
allez au l'amendement maintenant
qui est en dit
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui si
manifestations historiques 90% des
actifs opposés à la retraite à 64 ans et
votre seule réponse c'est le mépris
mépris envers l'opposition sénatoriale
et surtout mépris du président de la
République envers les syndicats qu'il
refuse de recevoir mais pris envers les
salariés et les Français votre projet
n'est pas légitime vous devez le retirer
nous par cet amendement nous nous
attirons l'attention sur la situation
des plus anciens qui n'ont pas toujours
accès à Internet et même s'il existe
aujourd'hui une possibilité de prendre
rendez-vous faut-il encore avoir
l'information et le numéro de téléphone
uniquement disponible sur le site
Internet vous comprenez chers collègues
monsieur le ministre la difficulté de
nos concitoyens n'ayant jamais utilisé
un ordinateur de leur vie afin d'accéder
simplement des informations sur leurs
droits notre groupe est persuadé que
cette situation n'est autre qu'un choix
politique destiné à faire des économies
sur l'ensemble du territoire de la
France
oui sur l'ensemble du territoire de la
France nous donne la possibilité à
chaque Français chaque Français de
pouvoir accéder à ses droits à qui par
des années de travail car oui chers
collègues ces deux-là dont nous parlons
ici avec cet amendement nous voulons
permettre à chacun d'entre nous de
pouvoir demander de l'aide à la Carsat
dans leur démarche et de connaître
l'ensemble de leurs droits car
aujourd'hui encore trop de nos
concitoyens ne touchent pas l'ensemble
de leurs droits qu'ils ont pourtant
cotisé et ce par manque d'informations
sur ce sujet merci
avis de la commission oui nous
partageons effectivement cette
préoccupation d'information au plus près
de nos concitoyens mais il appartiendra
au CARSAT de s'organiser le voir si
elles mettent ou pas sur pied des
permanences ou bien sur rendez-vous
comme ça se fait dans nombre de CARSAT
donc avis défavorable pour que ce soit
inscrit dans la loi
merci
le 784 je vous empêche la collègue
Nassim ce prix dans le chemise mes chers
collègues aujourd'hui le cumulant Planet
est autorisé sans aucune restriction
lorsque l'assuré a atteint une retraite
de base du régime général à taux plein
si un assuré n'a pas le nombre de
trimestres validés suffisant le cumulant
peut retraite est dit plafonné
c'est-à-dire que le cumul des revenus
d'activité et des pensions est autorisé
dans une certaine limite cela pénalise
donc les assuréticulaires d'une retraite
anticipée au titre du handicap d'une
retraite au titre de l'inaptitude au
travail qui bénéficie légitimement d'un
régime de faveur et d'une réduction de
la durée d'assurance exigée pour tenir
compte de la réalité du marché du
travail de leur fatigue habilité et de
leurs conditions de travail aussi c'est
amendement vise à permettre aux
titulaire d'une pension liquidée au
titre du inaptitude et au titulaire
d'une retraite anticipée de bénéficier
du cumul emploi retraite intégral je
vous remercie
si avis de la commission sur le
rapporteur
c'est un avis défavorable monsieur
président avis du gouvernement
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
simplement préciser que c'est un avis
défavorable mais pour les personnes dont
la situation vous évoquez ce cumul des
plafonnés est possible à partir de l'âge
légal n'est pas dans la partie entre
l'âge anticipée de départ et l'âge légal
c'est une pression que je voulais vous
apporter
merci
le 2183 monsieur le rapporteur
un amendement tout à fait important me
semble-t-il mais comme comme bien
d'autres bien entendu la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2021 a permis le recours aux données
biométriques pour vérifier chaque année
que les personnes résidant à l'étranger
et bénéficiant d'une pension servie par
un régime de retraite obligatoire
français sont toujours en vie toutefois
la mise en oeuvre de cette mesure qui
doit permettre de renforcer les moyens
de la lutte contre la fraude aux
prestation sociale a été plusieurs fois
repoussé ces deux dernières années à ce
jour le décret d'application n'a
toujours pas été pris par le
gouvernement monsieur le ministre cet
amendement vise donc à assurer que le
gouvernement permette l'application des
dispositions de la loi de finance de
sécurité sociale de 2021 au plus tard le
1er septembre 2023 je rajouterais que
cette biométrie permettrait également
aux Français qui sont à l'étranger de
pouvoir plus facilement avoir là aussi
accès par ce dispositif à l'heure
document et derrière leur prestations de
retraite
donc merci avis du gouvernement merci
monsieur le Président de la vie
favorable et monsieur le rapporteur l'a
dit c'est un outil de lutte contre la
fraude avec la mise en oeuvre
biométrique nous voulons le faire mon
collègue Gabriel l'a déjà dit et par
ailleurs au-delà de la lutte contre la
chrotte c'est un élément d'Accès au
Droit et de simplification de l'accès
aux prestations pour les Français
établis à l'étranger donc c'est aussi
une première brique pour le chantier que
nous aurons amener sur les différentes
conventions merci monsieur le ministre
je passe au 2022 madame Goulet oui
monsieur
rapport que j'ai commis avec Carole
Grandjean
s'agissant de l'élaboration d'un
domicile social comme on a un domicile
fiscal de façon à éviter la fraude à la
résidence et au domicile alors plusieurs
fois cet amendement a été déposé il ne
tournait pas on la rectifié plusieurs
fois la semaine dernière en réunion sur
ce sujet chez Gabriel Attal nous avons
de nouveau évoqué ce sujet avec
évidemment les problèmes que ça pouvait
poser notamment pour les étudiants qui
étaient rattachés fiscalement au foyer
de leurs parents mais qui par ailleurs
avaient leurs propres domicile donc
c'était un petit rappel de cette
disposition qui serait extrêmement
utile pour lutter contre la fraude
avis de la commission
c'est un problème effectivement
de conditionnalités du versement de
diverses prestations sociales à la
transmission d'une adresse unique de
contact effectivement
sujet intéressant et la Commission a
préféré demander la vie du gouvernement
avant de se prononcer du gouvernement
au risque de se voir Madame
et ne nous paraît pas très utile de
conditionner l'accès à l'adresse unique
il y a d'autres mesures du plan lutte
contre la fraude y compris celle
prescrite ou proposée par le rapport
vous avez évoqué le vôtre en
l'occurrence qui nous paraissent plus
prioritaire
voilà bien je passe à deux amendements
identiques d'abord le 2990 monsieur
Chantrel
merci monsieur le Président nous sommes
en direct sur Public Sénat si vous nous
rejoignez il vient de se passer un
moment important dans cette dixième
journée de l'examen de la réforme des
retraites au Sénat on va rejoindre
mathiasaray pour en parler en tribune de
presse de l'hémicycle Mathias tous ces
jouets autour de l'amendement de Bruno
Retailleau déposé depuis le début de
l'examen et qui donc n'a pas été examiné
il a été retiré avant la séance que
s'est-il passé exactement et de quoi
s'agit-il c'était l'un des temps forts
qu'on attendait cet après-midi et ce que
cet amendement qui allait être défendu
en tout cas qui était défendu depuis le
début de ce texte sur la réforme des
retraites par Bruno retaillod allait-il
être examiné ou non cet amendement vous
le savez pour une accélération de la
convergence des régimes spéciaux vers le
régime général et bien la nouvelle est
tombée de la bouche du président de
séance Roger Carotti que je vous propose
d'écouter
l'amendement 2057 rectifié bis présenté
par Bruno retailleux de ses collègues a
été retiré
je
voilà je je pressentais je pressentais
un mouvement de joie
je remercie une partie voilà très bien
allez
c'est comme ça donc l'amendement 2057 a
été retiré non mais monsieur gay
chacun fait oui mais bon allez bravo
vous vous en rêviez il l'a fait tout
porter à croire que cet amendement
n'allait pas être défendu puisque un il
n'avait pas été retenu par le
gouvernement dans la procédure du vote
bloqué deux il n'était pas non plus
soutenu par une partie de la majorité
sanatoriale à savoir les centrist ce qui
est certain c'est que ce retrait est un
véritable coup dur à gauche vous l'avez
vu sur ces images car en retirant cet
amendement et bien c'est environ 200
sous amendements de la gauche qui
tombent avec lui plus de 5 heures de
débat auquel tenait la gauche pour durer
pour faire durer en longueur ces
discussions ici dans l'hémicycle et donc
une gauche à qui il reste un peu moins
de 400 amendements maintenant à examiner
avant le vote final sur ce texte de la
réforme des retraites merci Mathias pour
toutes ces explications de ce qui vient
de se jouer dans l'hémicycle nous on
retourne écouter les débats en direct
qui en plus monsieur le ministre en
d'autres temps avaient massivement voté
pour le président que vous représentez
je crois que ça incarne toute
l'illustration de l'aberration de ce que
nous vivons cet après-midi tout le
mépris qui est fait à l'opposition
sénatoriale et au fonctionnement du
Sénat je crois que le mépris est
effectivement au cœur aujourd'hui de ce
que nous vivons des millions de Français
sont encore aujourd'hui dans dans la rue
90% des Français sont contre cette
réforme et on leur répond par le mépris
mépris qui va jusque jusqu'au fait de
refuser de recevoir aujourd'hui les les
syndicats je crois que nous vivons donc
un moment douloureux pour notre société
et qu'il en restera évidemment beaucoup
beaucoup de traces ce matin ma collègue
communiste a assisté
a donc cité évidemment Albert Camus qui
a écrit
après le mythe de saisie l'homme révolté
l'homme révolté c'est très récent parce
que le révolté dit que la révolte tire
l'homme de sa solitude elle montre
l'importance de l'individu à un
collectif à un groupe qui partage des
valeurs communes je crois que la gauche
depuis le début de ce finalement de de
ce débat aura donné raison à Camus aura
illustré les propos de Camus et surtout
et ça sera ma conclusion Camus dit mais
Sisyphe a toujours de l'enthousiasme a
toujours l'idée qu'il gagnera un jour et
il remontera toujours le rocher et je ne
peux donc conclure avec vous il faut
toujours imaginer Sisyphe
c'était très beau même si si ce n'y est
jamais arrivé mais bon
[Rires]
moi je dis rien allez avide la
commission avis de la commission allez
chat monsieur Dante monsieur le
rapporteur
suite à l'expliquer création très claire
de cet amendement je voudrais rappeler
quand même qu'il s'agit de d'un problème
de délivrance des certificats
d'existence voilà c'est pas la solution
qu'à retenue la Commission en
conséquence à vie défavorable non mais
ma vie
le 2556 monsieur le Président Gontard
oui merci merci monsieur le Président
encore une mobilisation record encore
des chiffres record par tout en France
six manifestations historiques 90% des
actifs opposés à la retraite à 64 ans et
votre seule réponse c'est le mépris
mépris envers l'opposition sénatoriale
et surtout le mépris du président de la
République envers les syndicats qu'il
refuse de recevoir mépris envers les
salariés et les Français votre projet
n'est pas légitime retirez-le et comme
le chante en ce moment une partie de nos
collègues qui sont partis en
bénéfestation pour exiger le retrait de
cette réforme scélérate pour l'honneur
des travailleurs et pour un monde
meilleur nous on est là on est là même
si Macron ne veut pas nous on est là
et puis
cet amendement qui est un rapport
analysant les impacts de cette réforme
de retraite sur les obstacles à l'accès
des Français des Françaises réduisant
étrangers au versement de leur pension
de retraite qui a été
défendu et qui est à peu près identique
à l'amendement à l'amendement précédent
qui serait d'ailleurs tombé s'il avait
pu être voté puisque c'était un
excellent un excellent amendement dire
quand même nous nous avons le courage de
défendre nos amendements parce que
derrière nous avons du fond nous avons
des propositions et le retrait de
l'amendement de Monsieur Retailleau qui
d'ailleurs était encore affiché sur
l'article 7 qui pendant toutes ces débat
c'est rétrograder comme ça petit à petit
peut-être pourquoi peut-être par manque
de courage je ne sais pas peut-être
aussi parce que face à une majorité qui
se divise on n'a pas osé mettre cet
amendement au débat parce que vous
saviez que vous n'auriez pas de majorité
comme vous avez utilisé le 44 3 l'arme
des faibles parce que votre majorité
s'effrite
avis de la commission sur le 2556
défavorable c'est un rapport du
gouvernement
le
3376 je vous en prie Monsieur salmon
merci monsieur le Président avant de
prévenir l'augmentation des risques et
de permettre à un maximum de personnes
de profiter de la retraite progressive
il est important que l'âge d'accès au
dispositif correspondent à un âge
cohérent avec l'accroissement de la
vulnérabilité c'est l'objet de cette
amendement que de proposer de maintenir
l'accès aux dispositif de retraite
anticipée à 60 ans et maintenant un peu
de contexte
la France affronte des circonstances
exceptionnelles après deux ans de
pandémie le retour de la guerre en
Europe l'inflation liée au choc
énergétique l'accélération des impacts
du changement climatique et notamment
des canicules qui ont fait plus de 3000
morts en 2022 alors que tous s'effondre
le bon sens voudrait que le gouvernement
donne la priorité aux urgences
écologiques et sociales résultant de ses
bouleversements et anticipent sur les
chocs à venir à l'inverse cette réforme
des retraites proposées illustrent
l'impensée sociale et climatique du
gouvernement elle est une nouvelle
illustration de l'obsession
productiviste pour la croissance du PIB
qui mène au chaos en ignorant les
limites planétaires la souffrance
sociale et la perte de sens au travail
elle est fondée sur l'idéologie de la
croissance infinie travailler plus pour
produire plus pour consommer plus à
contre-courant des besoins de sobriété
décroissance que nécessite l'urgence
climatique la planète brûle et les
droites juges urgent de reculer le
départ à la retraite et ne souhaite
qu'une chose aggraver encore et encore
les injustices sociales c'est unique et
absurde si manifestations historiques
90% des actifs opposés à la retraite à
64 ans et votre seule réponse c'est le
mépris mépris en verre l'opposition de
sénatoriale et surtout le mépris du
président de la République envers les
syndicats qu'il refuse de recevoir
mépris envers les salariés et les
Français votre projet n'est pas légitime
retirez
merci avis de la commission sur le 3376
négatif monsieur le Président parce que
c'est une demande de rapport sur
l'impact du décalage de l'âge
d'ouverture des droits dans l'accès au
dispositif de retraite en sicipé et
l'opportunité maintenir l'âge d'accès au
dispositif de retraite anticipées de 60
ans on n'a pas encore pris les mesures
elles sont applica qu'à partir le
premier du premier septembre 2023 et il
appartiendra à la commission des
affaires sociales de suivre l'évolution
du dispositif en conséquence ce rapport
me paraît
inutile c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous donnerons un avis défavorable sur
le fond et sur la forme merci monsieur
le ministre mais ma vie
et je passe au
2065 qui le défend monsieur Kerrouche
merci monsieur le président
si manifestations historiques 90% des
actifs opposés à cette retraite à 64 ans
et une réponse ici ailleurs le mépris le
mépris envers l'opposition qui se
confirme encore aujourd'hui surtout
celui du président de la République
envers les syndicats qu'il refuse
toujours de recevoir mes prix envers les
salariés et les français pour un projet
qui n'est pas légitime et que nous vous
demandons de retirer et d'ailleurs ce
projet justement mérite toujours d'être
transformé dans l'état actuel des choses
et mon collègue Pierre Julien le sait
l'ensemble des enseignants chercheurs
des professeurs des maîtres de
conférence des chercheurs s'accordent
pour remarquer que notre université
notre système de recherche et est en
train progressivement de de s'effondrer
il faut des incitations pour celui-ci
d'où celle proposée par cet article qui
vous propose à travers cet amendement
pardon le rachat de trimestre de stage
ou d'Ét qui permettrait aux assurés qui
ne disposeraient pas du nombre de
trimestres requis pour liquider leurs
droits à taux plein de réduire la décote
qui est applicable à leur pension afin
de garantir les activités de ce
dispositif cet amendement propose
d'assigner aux établissements
d'enseignants un rôle d'enseignement
pardon un rôle d'information auprès des
élèves et des étudiants sur le droit qui
leur sont ouverts dernier réflexion
enfin suite à la réaction que mes
collègues de droite ont eu par rapport
aux propos de Monsieur chanterelle je ne
comprends pas que vous vous étonniez
vous confirmez à vrai dire ce que fait
la droite depuis longtemps vous n'êtes
pas la droite du travail vous êtes la
droite de la rente et qui défend les
plus et qui défend les plus aisés et
nous nous sommes ceux qui défendons les
travailleurs et donc nous sommes contre
cette réforme c'est aussi simple que ça
avile non non avis de la commission non
non non
on reste calme
on a dit qu'on rentrait pas dans les
polémiques on rentre pas dans les
polémiques laissés écouter et puis c'est
tout merci merci
la parole est au rapporteur et à lui
seul merci c'est dommage que le ton n'y
soit pas car effectivement c'est un
sujet intéressant que d'informer les
élèves ou les étudiants sur la
possibilité de pouvoir racheter les
trimestres d'études qui sont en train de
faire je pense qu'il y a des
corporations étudiantes qui peuvent
faire comme elles le font pour la
protection sociale l'information
nécessaire ça ne me paraît pas utile de
marquer d'inscrire ça dans la loi nous
savons que le dispositif de rachat de
trimestre a été reculé à l'âge de 30 ans
ce qui laisse le temps nécessaire de la
réflexion faut pas que ce soit trop long
non plus parce que plus ça t'a plu c'est
cher la raison pour laquelle ne se
dispositif n'ayant pas été retenu par la
commission la vie est défavorable
même avis je passe au titre 4 avec un
amendement 3399 madame ponce
merci monsieur le Président alors nous
entamons une série d'articles sur les
trajectoires de financement des branches
de la sécurité sociale que nous jugeons
insincer les budgets prévisionnels de la
branche maladie ne tiennent pas compte
des dépenses induites par l'inflation la
FHF vous l'a dit c'est la rectification
aurait dû porter à hauteur de 1,2
milliards 2 les finances de la TNT
tiennent compte d'une diminution des
cotisations au profit de la broche
vieillesse alors que le travail
s'intensifie et que les accidents du
travail augmentent selon le chercheur du
four le taux d'incidence des accidents
mortels et non mortels a augmenté de 47%
en France le faisant la faisant la plus
mauvais élève de l'Union européenne
concernant les accidents du travail
cette branche ne devrait pas être
excédentaire en regard de cela la
branche autonomie est augmentée de
seulement 100 millions alors qu'elle
assume un coup supérieur du fait de
cette réforme enfin la bronche
vieillesse n'en parlons pas
je garde quelques secondes pour vous
dire que je viens de recevoir de nouveau
un message de mon collègue Corse paoulou
sans tout parisien
j'espère effectivement que la traduction
sera fidèle donc
Paulo parisienne me dit que
malheureusement à cause de la tempête
l'écorce n'ont pas pu le manifester
mec il rappelle quand même qu'ils ont
fait partie des six manifestations
historiques précédentes et qu'ils
étaient 9000 encore il me il vous
rappelle aussi
90% des actifs sont opposés à la
retraite à 64 ans et que la seule
réponse ne peut être le mépris mépris
envers l'opposition sénatoriale mépris
du président de la République envers les
syndicats qu'il refuse de recevoir mes
prix envers les salariés mais pris
envers les Français mépris envers les
actifs
Paolo Parisi aussi vous demande de
retirer ce projet parce qu'il le juge
pas légitime merci merci et nous
espérons tous que Monsieur parisien un
forfait sms parce que
[Applaudissements]
avis de la commission madame la
rapporteur général merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues en réalité si on en reste à
l'intitulé en tout cas l'objet de votre
amendement il s'agit de supprimer la
division et l'attitude de ce titre or ça
apporte beaucoup de lisibilité à la
compréhension de la loi c'est donc un
avis défavorable
l'article 14 deux amendements identiques
le
2563 Monsieur Mohamed
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues selon les
chiffres de l'ARS environ 389
professionnels de santé libéraux exercés
à Mayotte en 2021 peu nombreux et
majoritairement situé dans ou autour de
Mamoudzou chez
d'importantes zone de Lille notamment le
Nord et le Sud demeure très largement
sous doté aussi 45% des habitants de
plus de 15 ans déclare avoir dû renoncé
à des soins en 2019 ce qui est largement
supérieur à l'Hexagone et aux autres
départements d'outre-mer 47% des plus de
65 ans estiment que leur état de santé
est mauvais ou très mauvais enfin
l'espérance de vie y est de 75 ans
inférieur de 8 ans à celle de l'Hexagone
l'amélioration de l'accès aux soins sur
le territoire doit donc représenter une
priorité celle-ci passe par le
développement de l'attractivité du
territoire pour les professionnels de
santé cet amendement vise donc à
affilier les médecins
dentiste sage-femme et auxiliaire
médicaux et les directeurs de
laboratoire privé d'analyses médicales
nos médecins conventionné avec
l'assurance maladie qui réside exerce
leur activité à Mayotte au régime de
prestations complémentaires de
vieillesse dont bénéficie déjà ses
professionnels à métropole en
contrepartie l'assurance maladie prendra
en charge une partie de cotisation des
professionnels affiliés le bénéfice de
ces régimes permettra ainsi aux
professionnels de santé exécent à
Mayotte d'améliorer significativement
leur pension de retraite monsieur le
ministre les Maoré vous savent gré
d'accéder à cette demande importante de
profession libérales locales cette
mesure va contribuer à lutter contre la
désertification médicale et à
sensiblement améliorer l'accès aux soins
merci chers collègues amendement
identique du gouvernement le 2570 merci
monsieur le Président effectivement
monsieur le sénateur soli a attiré
appelé l'attention du Gouvernement sur
cette nécessité d'affiler les
professionnels libéraux de la médecine
au régime complémentaire de pension de
vieillesse pour donner de l'attractivité
et corriger une inégalité le
gouvernement a déposé un amendement
strictement identique pour lever le gage
de l'amendement de monsieur le sénateur
donc c'est évidemment favorable à
l'adoption des deux
merci David la commission puisque par
définition le Gouvernement est favorable
favorable merci beaucoup
je passe à l'article 14 avec
orateur Madame Raymonde ponce d'abord
le président
premier
d'articles sur les trajectoires
financières des branches de la sécurité
sociale nous l'avons dit il nous semble
très difficile d'établir la sincérité de
ces multiples trajectoires tant les
externalités négatives notamment sur les
autres branches mais pas seulement
Macron économique sont importantes sans
être prises en compte dans les calculs
du gouvernement les effets de la réforme
effectivement sur le système de santé
par exemple
entraînera forcément et ça a été chiffré
une augmentation des arrêts maladie dans
ces arrêts maladie je prends un exemple
simplement l'augmentation de deux ans
c'est l'augmentation de deux ans de la
durée de l'exposition aux agents
chimiques pour les personnes concernées
qui provoquent vous le savez des
maladies
ultérieures après la session l'arrêt du
travail je vous rappelle aussi que comme
l'amiante effectivement cet effet
différé créé un préjudice d'anxiété je
crois que la science quand même devrait
éclairer nos débats par exemple
Clémentine garous en 2019 et en évidence
un effet négatif de la réforme de 1993
en France sur la santé perçue aussi bien
un mental que physique une autre étude
menée par l'Université de Jérusalem en
2018 examine l'effet d'une réforme un
peu comparable adopté en Israël en 2014
et montre que cette fille a été
préjudiciable à la santé
j'en ai voterai d'autres mais on a peu
de cas de temps de parole mais la
conclusion est toujours la même les
réformes des retraites notamment des
paramètres que vous privilégiez
notamment celui de l'âge dégrade la
santé car elles obligent à travailler
plus longtemps alors que l'on observe
une intensification du travail que tous
les facteurs de pénibilité explosent et
que le management néolibéral a des
effets délétères voire toxiques je vous
envoie à France Télécom merci Madame
Poumirol
oui merci monsieur le Président à mon
tour je voudrais relever le fait que
malgré les six manifestations
historiques et l'opposition de 90% des
actifs à ce recul à 180 dollars votre
seul réponse c'est le mépris mes prix
envers l'opposition et la toriage c'est
pas très grave mais surtout le mépris du
président de la République envers les
syndicats qui refusent de recevoir mes
prix envers les salariés et les Français
votre projet est-il légitime et nous
vous demandons de le retirer en ce qui
concerne l'article 14 il a pour objet de
réviser les objectifs de dépenses de la
branche maternité maladie émaillité
d'essai à 238,4 milliards pour rappel la
loi de finances de 2023 avait fixé ses
objectifs à
238,3 milliards cette très légère
augmentation 100 millions d'euros à
peine c'est vraiment dérisoire et elle
est due à la création de ce fond de
prévention de l'usure professionnelle
dans le coup est estimé à 30 millions
d'euros pour cette année en cours je ne
peux que regretter que nous n'ayons pu
discuter de ce fond lors de l'article 9
par la négation de notre rôle par le
gouvernement avec l'utilisation de
l'article 44 3 de la Constitution nous
n'avons pas pu défendre ces travailleurs
de la fonction publique hospitalière
dans le métier très exigeant
usant pénible mérité plus de
reconnaissance partout en France des
maternités aux urgences en passant par
les ehpads beaucoup de soignants tirent
encore et toujours la semaine d'alarme
en effet ces travailleurs dont la charge
de travail ne cesse de s'accroître face
aux pénuries de personnel dans les
hôpitaux subiront de plein fouet le
recul de l'âge de la retraite pour ces
métiers la prévention l'aménagement de
la fin de carrière recuré à minima un
plan de soutien d'envergure mais ceci
est ce plan lui est dérisoire il est
grand temps de prendre la mesure des
difficultés de notre système hospitalier
et de la souffrance de ces personnels et
d'y apporter une réponse ambitieuse il
en va de la santé de nos concitoyens
madame gréaume
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre nous présentera tout à l'heure
son amendement s'il en prend le temps
tout doit aller très vite apparemment il
nous faudrait alors nous réjouir des 750
millions d'euros de rallonges budgétaire
il demande il manque bien plus que 750
millions d'euros pour notre système de
santé hôpitaux comme médecine de ville
et nous il faut redonner aux agents de
l'hôpital les capacités de faire leur
métier la vérité financière de la
branche maladie c'est que les
cotisations sociales salariales et non
salariales ne représente plus que 36%
des financements il suffit de lire la
page 36 de l'annexe 3 du plfs 2023 pour
s'en convaincre s'agissant
particulièrement des cotisations
sociales
elle serait encore freinée par le
dynamisme attendu des allège manger des
rôles mais aussi par la baisse des
cotisations maladie des travailleurs non
salariés prévus dans la loi en faveur du
pouvoir d'achat je le dis aux salariés
financ la branche maladie de plus en
plus par les impôts c'est les empêcher
de participer aux décisions ils perdent
la main sur leur système de protection
sociale pire la branche maladie peut
leur apparaître comme injuste car
financer davantage par de la TVA et de
la CSG pour 129 milliards 3 d'euros avec
ce type de recettes et mini sur Oléron
pour dire que ce n'est pas possible ou
comme aujourd'hui pour venir présenter
les miettes consenties au monde de la
santé rien qu'en ce début d'après-midi
257 amendements tombés en une seconde SI
manifestations historiques 90% des
actifs opposés à la retraite à 64 ans et
votre seule réponse c'est le mépris
mépris envers l'opposition sénatoriale
et surtout mépris du président de la
République envers les syndicats qu'il
refuse de recevoir mépris envers les
salariés le peuple français votre projet
n'est pas légitime retirer le
merci Madame Guillaume
allez une série voilà on avance dans
l'examen du projet de Gold de réforme
des retraites Mathias ares dites-nous
tout on vient de tourner une nouvelle
page on ouvre un nouveau chapitre
n'est-ce pas ça y est Quentin on rentre
dans le dernier chapitre de ce projet de
loi après les recettes les dépenses la
solidarité on arrive à présent dans un
chapitre très technique celui des
dotations et des objectifs de dépenses
des branches de la retraite ou encore de
la sécurité sociale des articles 14
jusqu'à 20 c'est donc la dernière ligne
droite qui vont aller très très vite
quand il reste un peu moins de 400
amendements à présent sur ce texte soit
l'équivalent de 12 à 13 heures de débat
donc la fin est proche certains ici
parlent déjà éventuellement d'un vote
demain avant midi c'est un véritable
coup dur qui a été vécu vous le savez en
début d'après-midi par la gauche avec le
retrait de cet amendement Retailleau
puisque environ 170 sous amendements
sont tombés avec lui une accélération
donc progressive et des amendements qui
sont de plus en plus techniques car
comme je vous l'explique on est à
présent dans les dotations et objectives
merci Mathias merci pour cette analyse
alors sachant que le décompte des temps
de parole n'est pas une chance exacte
mais effectivement c'est et bien la
théorie qui tient la corde un examen
final un vote finale sur le texte demain
peut-être en fin de matinée ou en début
d'après-midi c'est en tout cas les
dernières rumeurs qui brillent
effectivement au Palais du Luxembourg
retour au direct sont toujours
instructives et je pense que vous
devriez relire aujourd'hui une qui est
très connue le chêne et le roseau je
vais vous en dire quelques verres
l'arbre tient bon le roseau pli le vent
redouble ses efforts et fait si bien
qu'il déracine celui de qui la tête au
ciel était voisine et dont les pieds
touchaient à l'Empire des Morts je veux
saluer les Français qui travaillent qui
font tourner le pays qui aujourd'hui
manifeste qui ont voté contre l'extrême
droite et qui vous permettent monsieur
le ministre d'être aujourd'hui au bord
du gouvernement alors que vous n'avez
pas de vrais majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale je veux saluer les Français
qui se battent pour défendre leurs
droits et dire que nous ne les lâcherons
pas c'est Monsieur Ferro là n'est pas là
madame Ferrer le 388
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
si manifestation historique des
rassemblements encore extrêmement
nombreux aujourd'hui
90% des actifs qui sont opposés à la
retraite à 64 ans et la seule réponse du
gouvernement c'est le mépris le mépris
envers l'opposition sénatoriale mais
surtout bien plus grave le mépris le
mépris du président de la République
envers les syndicats qu'il refuse de
recevoir et le mépris envers les
salariés et les Français votre projet
n'est pas légitime retirez-le avec cet
amendement qui vise à supprimer cet
article 14 et bien c'est une proposition
de ou une rectification proposée qui que
nous refusons car nous constatons non
seulement l'insuffisance des moyens
donnés à l'hôpital public qu'il soit
pour les patients que nous sommes ou que
nous pourrions être pour les personnels
soignants que nous avons applaudis que
nous avons applaudis chaque soir en 2020
et à qui vous dites ce soir aujourd'hui
à qui vous dites depuis des semaines et
bien pour vous remercier vous devrez
travailler plus longtemps vous devrez
travailler deux ans de plus à qui vous
dites aussi et bien non les critères de
pénibilité qu'on avertirait en 2017 et
bien nous nous l'ouvrir ils ne seront
pas réintégrés voilà le mépris que vous
exercez à l'égard de toutes celles et
tous ceux qui sont en difficulté mais
aussi et surtout qui depuis des semaines
des jours vous disent que cette réforme
ils n'en veulent pas est-ce qu'un jour
vous allez finir par les entendre
au-delà de ce que nous vous répétons
chaque jour ici dans cette émission je
vous demande monsieur le ministre
entendez les dites au président de la
République de les entendre et retirer
votre réforme
merci le 549 Madame Van a
Madame Van eye le 549 oui merci monsieur
le Président c'est amendement vise à
rejeter la rectification de l'objectif
de dépenses de
merci le 658 monsieur chanterelle
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président comme
l'Allemagne est souvent cité dans nos
débats et on est sur le volet budgétaire
j'ai voulu justement vous faire le
tableau de ce qui se passe justement en
Allemagne puisque le gouvernement dit
qu'en 2030 on n'est pas assuré que cette
réforme sera suffisante donc c'est le
modèle vers lequel le gouvernement
souhaite aller donc je voulais vraiment
vous donner des précisions par rapport à
ça une élue qui vit depuis très
longtemps en Allemagne m'a envoyé toutes
ces informations donc tout d'abord
sachez que 10 à 12% des retraités
allemands bénéficient d'un régime
spécial et oui vous qui vous inspirez du
modèle allemand prenez-en de la graine
un régime spécial là-bas l'âge moyen de
départ n'est pas de 67 ans contrairement
à tout ce qui est dit sur les bandes
c'était mystiques mais de 62,4 ans c'est
plutôt qu'en France où il est de 62 ans
et 6 mois en 2021 36% des retraités
Allemands sont partis avec une décote ce
qui fait beaucoup de retraités pauvres
le 22 % des retraités hommes 42% des
femmes sont sous les 600 euros alors que
le montant de la pension moyenne à
pleine cotisation est censée être de
1600 euros sur un mois de départ en 2021
12% des cotes pour incapacité de travail
et 24,5 % en décote alors que le montant
théorique de pension complète de
cotisation et de 1600 euros le montant
réel moyen de la pension de départ en
retraite et de 1000 euros d'après un
rapport de l'Assurance retraite
allemande datant de 2022 le taux de
pauvreté monétaire en Allemagne et le
triple de celui de la France d'après les
chiffres de l'OCDE en 2019
7,85% des femmes allemandes sont en
dessous de 1200 euros et 60% sous les
900 euros le système allemand est
particulièrement brutal pour les femmes
donc voici le modèle qui vous inspire
pour votre réforme c'est profondément
injuste et brutal et c'est pour ça comme
les milliers et milliers de personnes
qui sont dans la rue aujourd'hui que
nous vous demandons à nouveau de retirer
cette réforme profondément injuste et
brutale merci
le 688 madame Le Houérou
merci monsieur le Président alors cet
article 14 vient corriger le plafond des
dépenses de l'assurance maladie pour
l'année 2023 mais il n'est pas à la
hauteur et ne permet pas d'en Disc et ne
nous permet pas d'en discuter donc nous
demande nous en demandons la suppression
le plafond proposé certes en
augmentation 3,6 pour cent par rapport à
2022 mais à un niveau inférieur
largement inférieur à l'inflation prévue
à 4,3% cela représente ni plus ni moins
une baisse de dépense qui couvre les
risques maladies maternité et invalidité
et invalidité sans grande surprise aucun
de nos objectifs n'est à la hauteur des
besoins alors les Français vous le
disent 6 manifestations historiques 90%
des actifs opposés à la retraite à 64
ans et la seule réponse c'est le mépris
mépris envers l'opposition sénatoriale
et surtout le mépris du président de la
République envers les syndicats qu'il
refuse de recevoir mes prix envers les
salariés et les Français
votre projet n'est pas légitime
retirez-le tout au long du débat notre
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicains avec les autres groupes de
gauche c'est attaché à le dire l'urgence
n'est pas la réforme des retraites mais
un financement massif de notre système
de soins et d'accompagnement fermeture
de lit fermeture de maternité en
Côtes-d'Armor à Guingamp aujourd'hui
nombreux étaient les manifestants pour
contre cette fermeture de maternité
difficulté d'accès aux soins pénuries de
soignants plus de 6 millions de Français
dont 600 000 atteints d'une infection de
longue durée non pas de médecins
traitant des chiffres très très
inquiétants la désignation d'un médecin
traitant est souvent difficile voire
impossible pour les personnes habitant
dans des zones soudances les
établissements pour la quasi-totalité
hôpitaux et hépates connaissent la
difficulté pour recruter des
paramédicaux force de constater que le
compte n'y est pas la branche maladie
mérite mieux compte tenu des coups de
d'énergie etc donc retraite 117 madame
blatrix compta
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues c'est un
amendement visa rejeter la rectification
de l'objectif de dépenses de cet article
14 dont l'évolution d'objectif de
dépenses s'explique exclusivement par la
création d'un fond de prévention l'usure
professionnelle prévue à l'article 9 du
présent au projet de loi se font aura
vocation à déployer une politique de
prévention de l'usure professionnelle et
d'aménagement des fins de carrière dans
la fonction publique hospitalière plus
particulièrement pour les professionnels
de santé employés dans des structures
publiques sanitaires et médico-sociales
son coût est estimés pour 2023 à 30
millions d'euros le secteur sanitaire et
médico-social fait face aujourd'hui à
une pénurie de bras les métiers
sanitaires sociaux médico-sociaux sont
en grande difficulté ces professions se
sentent méprisées alors que la
pénibilité au travail aurait dû être un
sujet central de ce projet de loi votre
gouvernement ni à consacrer qu'un seul
art règles se font évoque l'usure
professionnelle vous refusez toujours de
parler de pénibilité ce choix sémantique
souligne à mes connaissances du labeur
enduré par des millions de salariés mais
vous avez beau bannir de votre
vocabulaire le terme pénibilité vous
n'effacerez pas ces conséquences pour
les salariés le président de la
République et la droite sénatoriale
veulent que les fonds français
travaillent plus longtemps mais pour
travailler plus longtemps il faut déjà
pouvoir travailler ce fond est très
insuffisant son montant relève du mépris
mais il est vrai que les salariés du
secteur sanitaire et médico-social sont
habitués aux mépris du gouvernement
merci le 798 madame de La Gontrie
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement de suppression a été
parfaitement
expliqué par mes collègues qui m'ont
précédé et donc nous refusons la
rectification de l'objectif de dépenses
de la branche maladie maternité
invalidité telle que cela a été proposé
mais comme vous avez décidé de
dévitaliser la fonction parlementaire
par l'addition et le recours à toutes
les procédures que vous offre la
Constitution le règlement comme le
président de la République vient
désormais de nier le concept même de
démocratie sociale vous espériez sans
doute que nous laissions la retraite des
Français entre le main des droites
coalisées dont vous faites partie
évidemment nous ne sommes pas dupe les
Français non plus nous ne les lâcherons
pas et nous ne lâcherons rien mais comme
je sens que vous n'êtes pas convaincu
par mes propos je souhaite non pas citer
la fontaine mais cité l'une de vos
collègues LR qui a voté contre l'article
il y a quelques jours elle a publié un
texte pourquoi j'ai dit non elle précise
qu'elle est membre du groupe les
républicains au Sénat et elle indique à
l'heure où près des deux tiers des
Français s'opposent à cette réforme
l'adoption par la droite sénatoriale
elle parle donc le de vous de cette
mesure est une erreur que nos
concitoyens ne nous pardonnerons pas
c'est une profonde injustice c'est une
insulte faite à tous ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler tôt à tous ceux
qui ont des métiers éreintants et
surtout une insulte à toutes les femmes
qui seront les grandes perdantes de
cette réforme arrivée en fin de droit au
chômage à 60 et 61 ans les Français qui
ont économisé doivent leur permettre de
bénéficier de leur vie mais à cet âge là
44% des Français n'ont pas de travail et
se retrouvent dans une grande précarité
voilà pourquoi j'ai voté contre le
report de l'âge légal oui je suis de
droite vous êtes également mais cette
réforme n'est pas la mienne que Monsieur
Macron et son gouvernement l'assume seul
vous devriez méditer ses propos merci
madame de La Gontrie
le 883 monsieur Durand
merci monsieur le Président cela a été
dit avant moi par de nombreux orateurs
nous rejetons par cet article de
suppression la rectification de
l'objectif de dépenses de la branche
maladie maternité invalidité et des sets
tels que proposée par le gouvernement
dans cet article il faut de pouvoir
créer de nouvelles charges pour porter
ses budgets à la hauteur nécessaire la
suppression et la seule voie Camus Hugo
ont déjà été invités dans ce débat je
convoquerait pour ma part Paul Valéry on
le paraphrasant le vent se lève il est
temps de vivre il est surtout temps il
est surtout urgent d'écouter avec cette
réforme le président de la République
joue les apprentis sorciers alors nous
ne sommes pas surpris
revoilà Jupiter le théoricien de la
verticalité Jupiter au grand pas qui
enjambe les corps intermédiaires et veut
concentrer tous les pouvoirs mais à
force de surdité Merlin risque de casser
sa baguette et Jupiter de voir la foudre
se retourner contre lui et faute
d'écouter le peuple qui gronde nous
invitons ceux qui sont dans cette
hémicycle à eux entendre la colère
puissante la colère sourde qui s'exprime
chez les français si manifestations
historiques 90% des actifs opposés à la
retraite à 64 ans et votre seule réponse
c'est le mépris mépris envers
l'opposition sénatoriale et surtout le
mépris du président de la République
envers les syndicats qu'il refuse de
recevoir mes prix envers les salariés et
les Français votre projet n'est pas
légitime retirez-le après le refus de
concertation et le refus de considérer
la démocratisation sociale après le
dévoiement de la procédure parlementaire
voilà désormais le passage en force tout
azimut dans les deux chambres du
Parlement il n'est pas trop tard retirer
ce projet
merci le 1161 madame Lubin
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues nous demandons bien évidemment
le retrait et de cet article et de ce
projet de loi les seuls arguments que
vous asseinez en tout cas les plus
nombreux que vous assainez afin de
justifier votre réforme des retraites
sont l'âge qui serait bien plus
avantageux en France qu'en Europe sauf
que vous ne comparez pas des choses
comparables puisqu'en France nous avons
deux âges 62 ans là je légale et 67 ans
qui est l'âge auquel on peut percevoir
une retraite à taux plein et que cette
barrière des deux âges n'existe pas dans
les autres pays européens donc vous
comparez des choses qui ne sont pas
comparables et vous ne cessez aussi de
d'affirmer que dans ce pays nous avons
un niveau de protection sociale tel que
ça ne pourrait plus durer et que nous
devrions veiller à baisser à l'avenir
notre niveau de dépenses pour dépenses
de protection mais mes chers collègues
je vous pose une question devons-nous
nous excuser d'être d'habiter dans un
pays d'être les citoyens d'un pays qui a
été capable de mettre en place un niveau
de protection sociale aussi élevé est-ce
que notre projet de société à l'avenir
doit être au prétexte que nous serions
meilleurs que d'autres en matière de
protection sociale est-ce que notre
projet doit être d'abaisser cette
protection sociale et de traiter moins
bien les Français que nous ne les
traitons aujourd'hui une chose est
certaine c'est que sur ce côté de
l'hémicycle ça n'est pas notre projet de
société c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui je
réaffirme qu'après 6 manifestations
historiques
90% des actifs opposés à la retraite à
64 ans votre seule réforme c'est le
mépris mépris envers l'opposition
sénatoriale mépris du président de la
République envers les syndicats mépris
envers les salariés et les Français
retirez votre projet merci Monsieur
merryou pour le 1227
pour le 1295 merci monsieur le Président
chers collègues monsieur le ministre je
veux saluer à mon tour ici les nombreux
Français qui sont aujourd'hui encore
dans les rues du pays
pour nous dire vous dire leur opposition
ferme et résolue à ce texte je veux
qu'il sache qu'il donne aussi de la
force à la démarche dans cette émission
des groupes de gauche Unis malgré le
fait que qu'ici monsieur le ministre
vous ayez décidé de dévitaliser la
fonction parlementaire par l'addition de
toutes les procédures que vous offre la
constitution et le règlement vous
espériez sans doute que nous laisserions
la retraite des Français entre les mains
des droites coalisées mais nous ne
sommes pas dupe les Français non plus
nous ne les lâcherons pas et nous ne
lâcherons rien quant à la mandement 1295
nous avons rejeté en décembre dernier le
PLFSS 2023 qui est plus nous casse de
Bercy qu'un texte de progrès social
répondant aux défaillances et
déficiences de notre système de santé en
cohérence nous rejetons rejetons la
rectification de la de l'objectif de la
branche maladie maternité et décès qui
est proposé par le gouvernement dans cet
article
merci
ensuite
monsieur Kerrouche le 1456
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
moment de suppression juge bien entendu
insuffisant les 100 millions qui sont
proposés que nous correspondent en rien
au nécessité de
ce qui serait
envisageable si le problème est très
traité vraiment concrètement mais plus
largement
cette réforme est une réforme qui
fonctionne à l'envers
comment peut-on expliquer aux Français
que on baisse les impôts on baisse la
contribution des plus riches et que
comme on baisse tout simplement les
ressources fiscales de notre pays à un
moment donné il convient d'éponger ses
baisses de ressources par d'autres
ressources que l'on pourrait trouver sur
les plus faibles
l'ensemble de notre hexagone et c'est
exactement ce qui se produit avec cette
recherche avec cette avec cette réforme
pardon et les Français le comprennent
très bien et d'une certaine façon
la justice sociale ne peut jamais
fonctionner à l'envers et là ce que
comprenne nos concitoyens c'est que on
leur fait payer un impôt sur leur vie on
les décale dans le temps et on leur
prend des années qui ne leur reviendront
jamais c'est pas très compliqué à
comprendre la justice c'est pas très
compliqué à percevoir l'injustice je me
souviens de mon grand-père qui a pu
bénéficier de la retraite à 60 ans et de
sa joie de simplement pouvoir le faire
pas parce qu'il était affinéant mais
parce qu'il en avait assez de son
travail d'ouvrier et c'est ce que vous
allez empêcher alors
un humoriste a dit qu'il y a trois
grandes époques de l'humanité il y a
l'âge de pierre il y a l'âge de bronze
et à l'âge de la retraite et bien nous
nous voulons l'âge de la retraite et pas
l'âge de pierre merci le
1470 monsieur Stanzione
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
petit message attention de Monsieur le
Ministre et de certaines de nos
collègues qui sont renouvelables
d'ailleurs au mois de septembre
et
écoutez bien il y a eu six
manifestations historiques
90% des actifs dont certains sont dans
vos départements sont opposés à la
retraite à 64 ans et votre seul réponse
c'est le mépris
mépris envers l'opposition sénatoriale
car par un courage extraordinaire vous
venez de faire tomber 257 amendements
que nous aurions pu étudier ensemble
et surtout le mépris du président envers
les syndicats qu'il refuse obstinément
de recevoir mes prix envers les salariés
et les Français tout court votre projet
n'est pas légitime retirez-le il ne vous
reste que ça à faire
quant à l'article 14
inscrit qui est inscrit les objectifs de
dépenses de la branche maladie et
maternité invalidité d'essai en effet le
plafond est en baisse réelle de 1%
tenant compte de l'inflation et du la
croissance démographique c'est une
nouvelle cure d'austérité imposée au
régime sociaux au mépris de la centrée
des Français pourtant notre système de
santé déjà en souffrance alors que la
pandémie du covid a mis un exergue
extrême fragilité du système sanitaire
et social notre pays la menace de
fermeture de maternité dans mon
département de Vaucluse et symptomatique
d'une volonté gouvernement ale de
poursuivre la case du service public
mais c'est le cas entre autres à
Cavaillon à Carpentras avec la fermeture
des urgences et bien sûr l'hôpital
public est en train de disparaître merci
merci Madame Conway Mouret le 1487
vous avez présenté un texte qui de toute
évidence n'a pas été pensée jusqu'au
bout alors que finalement vous aviez le
temps pour la concertation et surtout
vous inspirez des recommandations du
corps puisque
finalement cette réforme était
nécessaire d'après vous pour des raisons
budgétaires rien de cela des annonces
sûrement préparées par un des cabinets
de communication auxquels vous avez pris
l'habitude de faire appel grave erreur
car cette réforme est hautement
politique et méritée que vous batissiez
sur les acquis sociaux auxquels nos
compatriotes sont très attachés et ils
vous le disent encore aujourd'hui en
manifestant massivement contre vos
réformes et nous vous le disons en
continuons notre travail de
parlementaire alors que celui-ci est
méprisé tout autant que les syndicats
qui ne sont pas reçus à l'Elysée alors
que nous savons tous que la décision du
retrait de cette réforme sera prise au
château 90% des actifs vous le demandent
et nous vous le demandons en nous basant
sur une pédagogie qui est basée sur la
répétition
le 1560 madame meunier
merci monsieur le Président alors je
voulais dire à Madame pansement je
commence à Monsieur Paris qui m'a écrit
mais c'est un de mes anciens élèves qui
suit qui entraîne manifester et il me
dit que cette sixième manifestation
comme les 5 précédentes et tout à fait
historiques ce qui n'a rien de
surprenant quand on sait que 90 % des
actifs sont opposés à la retraite et que
la seule réponse que l'on a pour le
moment à cette mobilisation historique
c'est le mépris d'abord mépris envers
nous l'opposition sénatoriale puisque
nous pouvons ni voter nos amendements ni
faire des explications de vote et pire
le mépris du président de la République
envers les syndicats qu'il refuse de
recevoir mes prix au fond envers les
salariés et l'ensemble des Françaises et
des Français ce projet n'est pas
légitime la seule solution c'est le
retirer l'amendement qui est là est un
amendement de suppression c'est vrai
qu'il y a une dépense supplémentaire qui
a été intégrée au titre du nouveau fond
de prévention de l'usure professionnelle
pour les établissements publics de santé
et médico-sociaux mais c'est très très
maigre c'est au lieu de 238 33 milliards
c'est 238,4 pourquoi c'est très maigre
et pour 5 convaincre il faut regarder
une étude publiée en février 2023 par le
conserve Conservatoire national des arts
et métiers qui se fondent sur l'impact
de la réforme des retraites 2010 dont la
mécanique de recul de 2 ans de l'âge
légal du départ et tout à fait similaire
à celle dont nous discutons actuellement
et les conclusions de cette étude sont
formelles plus on travaille longtemps
plus les recours aux arrêts maladie sont
fréquents il est ainsi constaté que le
recours aux arrêts maladie après la
réforme de 2010 augmenterait en moyenne
de 1,7% pour mémoire 6 ans après la
réforme des retraites de 2010 le coût
total des arrêts maladie est passé de
6,3 à 7,1 milliard d'euros donc le
manque de prise en compte de cette
problématique dans les trajectoires
prévues par le gouvernement interroge et
remet en cause la sincérité d'une
démarche qui repose pourtant avant tout
sur un souci d'économie budgétaire une
seule solution retirez votre réforme
merci le 1642 madame pomirol
oui merci monsieur le Président comme je
l'évoquais tout à l'heure voilà il est à
16h04 nous sommes toujours en direct
comme depuis 10 jours maintenant pour
suivre l'examen de la réforme des
retraites en direct sur notre antenne on
va retrouver mathiasarez qui se trouve
en tribune de presse de l'hémicycle
Mathias si les décomptes de publicité
sont bons il reste 324 amendements à
examiner pour finir l'examen de cette
réforme et vous nous le dites les débats
sont en train de s'accélérer en fait oui
les débats vont continuer de s'accélérer
même quand un car depuis l'article 14
est jusqu'à la fin de l'examen du texte
sur l'intégralité des six articles
restants et bien les amendements sont
quasiment tous des amendements de
suppression des articles c'est la seule
arme qu'il reste à la gauche car étant
dans le volet dotation et objectif je
vous le rappelle Quentin il n'y a pas de
possibilité de créer de nouvelles
dépenses article 40 de la Constitution
problème ses amendements de suppression
ils sont nombreux mais ils ne sont
signés qu'individuellement donc si le
sénateur ou la sénatrice signataire est
absent et bien il ne peut être soutenu
cet amendement et Quentin et bien cet
après-midi les bandes de la gauche sont
bien dégarnés et oui c'est pour cela que
l'on a vu et bien des amendements qui
avaient été déposé des amendements donc
dessus pression comme vous le disiez et
qui sont marqués non soutenus dans les
bases de données qui nous permettent de
suivre l'examen des amendements minute
par minute et c'est ce qui fait que le
décompte va pouvoir peut-être retomber
encore plus vite mais pour l'instant il
reste 324 amendements examinés est-ce
que les sénateurs vont aller au bout de
la réforme d'ici ce soir à minuit et
demi ou demain c'est tout le suspense
maintenant retour dans l'hémicycle le
mépris envers l'opposition sénatoriale
mais surtout le mépris du président de
la République envers les syndicats
qu'ils ne daignent pas recevoir mes
priant vers l'ensemble des salariés et
l'ensemble des Français votre projet
n'est pas légitime retirez-le
merci le 1769 madame meunier oui que le
président comme mes collègues je dépose
cet amendement de suppression de
l'article 14 je ne reviendrai pas sur
les conclusions du corps qui battent en
brèche votre discours alarmiste sur
l'impérieuse nécessité de la mise en
œuvre de cette réforme ni sur les
efforts que votre gouvernement attend
des Français les plus modestes pour
réaliser des économies tandis que les
aides et les cadeaux fiscaux aux
entreprises ne cessent de croître malgré
la charge que vous faites peser sur la
classe sociale inférieure sur le dos des
salariés les plus modestes encore une
fois auxquelles vous demandez de
travailler toujours plus et toujours
plus longtemps alors cette amendement de
suppression vous ne la laissez pas le
choix puisque quand on vous demande des
rapports ils sont refusés et quand on
vous propose des solutions de recettes
supplémentaires
sont
irrecevables comme mes collègues après 6
manifestations historiques après le
constat de la population qui adhère à
plus de 90% à l'opposition de ce texte
de report de l'âge de départ à la
retraite quel est votre réponse monsieur
le ministre et bien votre réponse c'est
le mépris mépris envers l'opposition
sénatoriale et surtout le mépris du
président de la République envers les
syndicats quand ils refusent de les
recevoir mépris enfin envers les
salariés et les Français votre projet
n'est pas légitime retirez-le
merci monsieur le Président Kanner le 18
centime
mes chers collègues ces articles au 14
dont nous voulons la suppression par nos
différents amendements que nous vous
présentons successivement prévoit de
relever pour 2023 les objectifs
dépensent de la branche maladie
maternité invalidité et décès de 100
millions supplémentaires chacun sait ici
que cette branche maladie assure la
prise en charge des dépenses de santé et
des assurés et garantit l'accès aux
soins c'est une branche très importante
bien évidemment et cette couverture
maladie est fait partie de notre
patrimoine commun et notamment depuis
les jours heureux du Conseil national de
de la résine de la résistance et vous
n'ont pas jaillir de la refondation non
faut pas faut pas confondre c'est ce
serait comme une erreur dramatique donc
le principe est simple toute personne
qui travaille aux résidents France de
manière stable et régulière a le droit à
être prise en charge de ces frais de
santé de manière continue tout au long
de sa vie et on l'a amélioré d'année en
année de réforme en réforme une réforme
progressiste et donc je me demande sur
quoi se font le gouvernement pour
prévoir une augmentation de dépenses à
hauteur de 100 millions d'euros mais
néanmoins ces moments de suppression je
passe un moment particulier de notre
histoire sociale cela a été dit et redit
et je vais vous le redire il y a eu 6
manifestations historiques dans dans ce
pays 90% des actifs sont opposés à la
retraite à 64 ans plus de la moitié des
Français sont en soutien de ce mouvement
y compris des grèves quand vous regardez
les chaînes d'infos permanentes et bien
même
ceux qui subissent les grèves des
éboueurs disent mais oui bon c'est quand
même un mouvement légitime et bien votre
seule réponse mes chers collègues c'est
le mépris mépris envers nos amendements
mépris aussi surtout d'Emmanuel Macron
moi j'ai lu la lettre d'Emmanuel Macron
en réponse au syndicat d'abord c'était
pas une réponse puisqu'il y avait une
demande on veut vous voir Monsieur le
Président et il dit mais passé sur le
trottoir d'à côté ça nous rappelle
quelque chose et bien cette attitude
n'est pas responsable nous vous
demandons de retirer votre réforme merci
Monsieur Assouline le 1861
il nous reste encore du temps pour
essayer de vous convaincre parce que
cette réforme vraiment
elle est injuste et vous n'avez pas
compris à quel point elle est vécue
comme une
comme une flèche
portée
contre ceux qui donnent tout déjà
n'attendez pas grand chose mais au moins
qu'on les respecte et qu'on soit dans
l'accompagnement dans les réponses à des
difficultés qui sont déjà
incroyables vous voyez bien dans votre
quotidien vous-même quand vous allez
acheter même des produits de première
nécessité que ça a doublé mais pour ceux
qui sont à l'euro près ce n'est plus
vivable
et au mieux au 15 du mois pour certains
ce n'est plus possible
de l'endettement
des crises des malheurs y compris
familiaux d'attention là où nous devons
être allé giféré pour voir comment
dans ce moment d'inflation particulière
qui touche beaucoup de pays nous
fassions bouclier social pour traverser
cette période c'est pour cela que c'est
particulièrement inconscient de ne pas
avoir compris que toucher les mêmes on
les imposant sur deux ans de leur vie en
bonne santé possible
en tous les cas les meilleures années de
retraite là où pour certains c'est une
attente qui dure depuis des années ce
moment-là parce que c'est le moment où
ils vont pouvoir enfin s'occuper des
petits-enfants où ils vont pouvoir faire
œuvre utile pour toute la société
parce que vous savez le nombre de
bénévoles qui s'occupe entre
62 et 64 ans de tout ce qui fut
associatifs
je profiterai ma volonté de conviction
dans mon prochain amendement allez le
1927 monsieur Joly en salle des
conférences pour quelques instants
LRD de Charente-Maritime et
effectivement on a vu on voit ces débats
qui se qui se prolonge il y a
théoriquement jusqu'à 10 heures de débat
encore avec le nombre de personnes
est-ce que vous pensez que le vote de la
réforme des retraites va intervenir ce
soir ou demain quel est votre votre avis
sur la question honnêtement je sais pas
je pense que ça pourrait peut-être
intervenir dans la nuit peut-être je dis
bien mais si c'est pas le cas on finira
de 20 minutes je pense je pense que au
rythme où on va ça peut c'est peut-être
que le vote interviendra ce soir à 7h
peut-être que dire de ce qui se joue en
ce moment avec ses prises de parole de
signataires d'amendements de suppression
comme ça on a une forme de une nouvelle
litanie de de prise de parole de la
gauche avec cette fois-ci assez peu
d'arguments sur le fond ce sont des
amendements de suppression qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez ce sont des amendements
individuels de suppression d'un article
c'est c'est ce qu'on a vu précédemment
sur d'autres articles bien évidemment
comme tous les sénateurs ne sont pas
présents cet après-midi il y a des
moments qui ne sont pas défendus mais
vous l'avez dit c'est une Italie un peu
récurrente on entend depuis depuis deux
jours et voilà les règles du jeu font
ils peuvent être tous présentés ils le
sentent que tous les auteurs amendements
peuvent présenter
ça traduit cette volonté d'obstruction
que nous avons dénoncé et qui a conduit
le gouvernement à appliquer un article
de la Constitution et donc
44 3 qui aboutiraient à votre bloqué sur
l'ensemble du texte et justement
qu'est-ce que ça donne quand même images
de l'examen du texte puisque cette
examen touche maintenant à sa fin on
rentre dans les peut-être dans les 10
dernières heures d'examens au Sénat
qu'est-ce que vous retiendrez vous du
niveau des échanges aussi voilà de de
ces stratégies qui sont mises en place
cette guérilla parlementaire parfois
qu'on a vécu ça nous a privé de débat
sur le fond qui notamment sur la après
l'article 7 je pense à l'article sur les
aidants je pense à l'article sur le
cumul emploi retraite je pense qu'on
aurait pu avoir de belles discussions et
que cette façon d'aborder le texte avec
une volonté d'obstruction
au titre du droit d'amendement qui est
tout à fait évidemment que je défends
qui respectable mais a donné une
caricature de ce que pouvait être un
travail parlementaire et ça nous a privé
de débat sur le fond et je le regrette
est-ce que vous dites qu'il y aura en
avant après réformes des retraites au
Sénat notamment dans le niveau
d'énervement séance entre la droite et
la gauche sanatoriale j'espère longtemps
notamment dans les dans les propos de
Patrick Kanner qui qui dit que oui
j'espère que non j'espère que les choses
ont s'apaisés on l'a vu avec voilà il y
a notamment après la conférence des
présidents d'hier les choses se sont
apaisées et j'espère que voilà on
retrouvera une ambiance de respect de
calme dans cette à la Haute Assemblée
parce que ça serait dommage que ça
laisse trop de traces un dernier mot sur
cette question
si le Sénat adopte ce soir le texte
qu'est-ce que ça donne comme image une
chambre parlementaire qui adopte un
texte au moment où des milliers
centaines de milliers de Français
manifestent contre ce contre cette
réforme alors je pense que d'abord la
mobilisation a l'air d'être un petit peu
moins un truc que mardi dernier je pense
que vous avez dans votre département
alors j'ai pas les honnêtement j'ai pas
les chiffres en Charente-Maritime et
c'est ce que j'ai j'ai pu voir à travers
certaines parutions
dans des journaux sur le net mais je
pense que ça sera plus ni moins que le
vote de l'article 7 dans la nuit de
mardi à mercredi
le vote de cette loi c'est aussi de
préserver le système de répartition et
préserver l'équilibre financier du
système de retraite et de la branche ISS
je crois que c'est ça qui est important
pour les retraités à venir des futurs
générations donc voilà il y a pas de
souci là-dessus j'ai posé une dernière
question si vous me le permettez sur
l'amendement Retailleau on a vu que il
n'avait pas été finalement soutenu dans
l'hémicycle puisque vous l'avez retiré
avant la séance c'était un amendement
qui visait à sortir de la clause du
grand-père plus rapidement que ce qui
n'est prévu dans le projet du
gouvernement pourquoi l'avoir retiré
tout d'abord je pense que vous aurez
noté en tant qu'observateur averti que
nous avons retiré tous les amendements
et enfin notre groupe LR a retirer tous
les amendements qui n'avaient pas reçu
qui ne serait pas retenu au final par le
gouvernement
donc nous avons retiré tous les
amendements il n'était pas non plus
tout à fait n'était pas et en plus avant
la séance on a vu tout un tas de sous
amendements de dernière minute déposer
pour allonger les débats voilà par la
gauche de la même façon qu'on a vu tous
les sous amendements ou amendement
copier-coller et on était encore là sur
l'obstruction donc je pense que on a
appliqué à ce cet abonnement comme on
l'a fait pour tous les autres
amendements hors hormis un amendement
outre-mer qui nous paraissait important
et donc et qui a obtenu un avis
favorable donc voilà ni plus ni moins
que les autres amendements défendus par
notre groupe merci merci pour cette
période en direct sur le micro depuis au
public de publicain on va retourner dans
l'hémicycle puisqu'on suit tous ces
échanges en direct le gouvernement nous
propose un chiffre qui ne tient pas
compte d'un certain nombre de réalité
l'inflation en premier bien sûr mais
aussi la croissance démographique ou
encore la progression des maladies
chroniques cet objectif de dépenses et
donc largement insuffisant pour répondre
aux grands défis qui sont devant nous
l'inquiétant détérioration de l'hôpital
public qui s'accélère désormais trois
mois ne sera pas contenu encore moins
réparé cette crise de l'hôpital est
devenue une crise de vocation désormais
des lits ferme sans plus vite que le
gouvernement ne le voudrait lui-même
faute de soignants dans les services nos
soignants sont à bout ils sont épuisés
essorés et vous exigez deux comme de
l'ensemble de la population de tirer
deux ans plus peut-être pensez-vous que
les applaudissements leur suffirait et
ce n'est pas cela qui va motiver les
futurs générations déjà 10% des
étudiants en médecine abandonnent en
cours d'études et 20% des places en
deuxième année de formation sage-femme
ne sont pas remplies j'avais d'ailleurs
proposé un amendement visant à ce qu'on
examine la possibilité de prendre en
compte les stages obligatoires à
réaliser dans le cadre de la formation
de sage-femme dans le calcul de leur
retraite comme piste pour revaloriser
cette filière mais de cela comme de
bien-être nous ne pouvons pas en
débattre d'une part parce que mon
amendement comme bien d'autres a été
retoqué sur un motif bien fumeux mais
finalement cette attitude finalement
illustre parfaitement votre mépris
envers le Parlement votre mépris envers
l'opposition sénatoriale mais surtout le
mépris du président de la République
envers les syndicats qu'il refuse
recevoir méprisent vers les salariés et
les Français
le 3192 madame ponce
merci monsieur le Président alors je
vais compléter ce que vient de dire mon
collègue Jean-Claude Tissot sur cette
branche maladie qui ne tient pas compte
aussi tout simplement de votre réforme
je dirais et qui est pas révisé à cet
égard suffisamment en effet selon une
étude du Centre d'étude de l'emploi et
du travail en 2023 la réforme de 2010 à
augmenter drastiquement le nombre
d'arrêt maladie notamment de longue
durée chez les seniors et prévu pour un
surcoût désormais estimé par la Cour des
comptes à 970 millions les résultats de
cette étude
dise bien que c'est très forme sera
dramatique quant à son cou sur la santé
d'ailleurs nous avons de nouvelles de
nombreuses études qui concluent un effet
négatif de l'allongement de la vie
active sur la santé j'en ai déjà parlé
et assis par exemple une étude de 2020
montre que la réforme adoptée au
Royaume-Uni en 2010 tiens 2010 à
entraîné une augmentation du nombre de
dépressions médicalement diagnostiquées
devant votre cécité votre aveuglement un
bon médecin vous conseillerez de
visionner les films de Ken LOA par
exemple moi Daniel Blake qui mieux que
tout autre illustre le sas de
pré-calédité où vous allez plonger
200000 français chaque année 200000
seniors cette réforme est effectivement
d'inspiration thatcherienne et nous vous
disons avec beaucoup moins de talons
nous vous disons les conséquences
sociales et qu'elles louches vous aurait
dit en anglais cette fois-ci six
manifestations historiques en France 90%
des actifs opposés à la retraite à 64
ans et votre seule réponse c'est la
mépris le mépris envers l'opposition
sénatoriale notre position et surtout le
mépris du président surtout du président
de la République envers syndicales qu'il
refuse de recevoir
ce mépris envers les salariés et les
Français est inadmissible votre projet
n'est pas légitime merci pour le retirer
merci allez
qui présente je vous en prie
merci monsieur le Président je pourrais
vous le dire en Cauchois mais je vais
préférer le lire en français si
manifestations historiques 90% des
actifs opposés à la retraite à 64 ans et
votre seule réponse c'est le mépris
mépris envers l'opposition sénatoriale
et pire mépris du président de la
République envers les syndicats qu'il
refuse de recevoir mais pris envers les
salariés et les Français votre projet
n'est pas légitime retirez-le votre
projet fait en quelque sorte un peu de
saupoudrage pensant que quelques petites
très petites mesures positives feront
passer la pilule de l'allongement de la
retraite à 64 ans pas du tout
là nous abordons la l'article 14 qui
entérine les objectifs de dépenses de la
branche maladie maternité invalidité et
décès pour 2023 et qui malgré les 750
millions d'euros ne vont absolument pas
répondre à l'état d'indigence dans
lequel est notre système de santé nos
hôpitaux du service des urgences à la
psychiatrie je pense par exemple aux
urgences de Lillebonne qui sont
contraintes de fermer régulièrement ce
qui mène nos concitoyens dans une colère
noire
je pense à la psychiatrie nous allons
avoir des accidents si nous ne prenons
pas la mesure de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans le pays et je crois que
la colère noire que les Français
ressentent à l'égard de cette se refus
d'investir véritablement dans le système
de santé va se traduire par une couche
supplémentaire de colère face à votre
refus de retirer ce projet d'allongement
de la réforme des retraites il y a
évidemment un lien on le sait entre
l'allongement de la durée de travail et
la santé des Français ne rajoutez pas de
couches à la colère nous allons tous le
regretter
c'est Madame la rapporteur général
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre chers collègues avec cet
article en fait nous entamons la série
d'articles qui donnent l'ensemble des
objectifs de dépenses des différentes
branches de la sécurité sociale là on
est sur la branche maladie maternité
invalidité et décès et donc ce qui est
prévu c'est une dépense qui s'établira à
230 8,4 milliards d'euros alors c'est -
évidemment que ce que nous avons voté
l'année dernière parce que comme vous le
savez nous avons été traversés par une
crise sanitaire et que là il était prévu
justement au PLFSS 2023 un milliard
d'euros de dépenses donc effectivement
ce niveau baisse mais en l'occurrence il
reste tout de même suffisant pour les
dépenses je voudrais simplement préciser
que là si on en parle c'est parce que il
y a une incidence par rapport à ce que
nous avons voté dans les articles
précédents puisque est inclus la dépense
pour le fond d'investissement de l'usure
professionnelle nous avons eu l'occasion
avec René Paul Savary de rencontrer les
deux personnes qui s'occupent de la mise
en place de ce fond et très simplement
vous dire que nous avons eu un échange
tout à fait constructif c'est deux
personnes sont en train d'établir
finalement quel sera leur feuille de
route entre
essayer de d'investir auprès des
hôpitaux des services des établissements
médico-sociaux tous ces professionnels
dont on a parlé qui vivent une vraie
usure professionnelle et donc ils
prennent lien aujourd'hui avec les ARS
avec les départements parce que les
départements ont pu investir aussi déjà
dans ces établissements et puis il
regarde aussi comment investir sur la
fin de carrière des personnes les plus
en difficulté donc c'est une dépense qui
est intégrée simplement si vous me le
permettez j'ai entendu effectivement que
chacun pouvait se servir de cet article
pour en faire une tribune vous le savez
c'est sur la branche maladie que nous
avons le plus haut des déficits donc on
voit bien et les deux années de Christ
inter je dirais même trois on laissait
des traces en termes de déficit on
laisse la facture de nos consultations à
nos enfants faut-il leur laisser en plus
l'idée qu'il ne pourront pas payer la
retraite que le retraite ne sera pas
payé par les générations qui seront les
générations d'actifs en même temps que
eux ils seront retraités donc c'est
vraiment cette prise de conscience qui
fait que aujourd'hui nous avons en tout
cas au niveau de la majorité sénatoriale
suivi cette réforme des retraites donc
en clair avis négatif allez monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le Président c'est
évidemment un avis défavorable puisque
les amendements de suppression privé le
bel effet 16 d'un tableau qui fait
article et que cet article d'un article
obligatoire pour que le PDFs soit
recevable par ailleurs beaucoup des
intervenants souligné la le fait que
l'objectif d'un Damme était à leurs yeux
trop bas nous le son de 750 millions
d'euros pour tenir les engagements pris
par le Président de la République leur
de ses vœux aux acteurs de la santé et
mettons en oeuvre dans le cas de cet
article 14 les premiers crédits qui
permettront de financer les premières
actions du fond d'investissement dans la
prévention de l'usure donc défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre vous pouvez
quasiment rester debout pour le 47 23 je
peux monsieur le Président d'autant plus
que je l'ai finalement défendu en
m'opposant aux amendements de
suppression puisque c'est cet amendement
tire les conséquences des annonces que
j'ai évoquées dès l'article 14 même si
le principal des conséquences vient à
l'article 15 donc vous pouvez considérer
qu'il est défendu merci avis de la
commission sur le 4723
merci je passe à l'article 15 madame
ponce dans les orateurs
alors à tous les
nous revenons sur la question de l'ONDAM
et à tous c'est projet de loi de
financement nous aboutissons au même
constats il est insuffisant lors du
dernier PLFSS nous demandions une
rallonge pour faire face à l'inflation
le gouvernement nous la refusé puis
finalement a ouvert une ligne de 600
millions nous disions qu'elle était
insuffisante pour finalement en ajouter
une autre lors d'un amendement Assemblée
nationale de 700 millions qui est
malheureusement toujours insuffisante il
suffit d'écouter quand même la
Fédération hospitalière de France c'est
simple voilà puisque les besoins pour la
Fédération s'élève à 1,2 milliards bien
sûr on peut saluer les rallonges mais il
faut tout de même quand même préciser
que les hôpitaux ne peuvent pas tenir
sur des rallonges octroyés comme ça de
façon discrétionnaire et sans vision
pluriannuelle avec les organisations
hospitalières et syndicales nous ne
cessons de demander un nom d'âme pluriel
détaché des budgétaires et austéritaires
pour finir pour fournir enfin une vision
à moyen terme aux établissements
hospitaliers et ce que nous demandons
n'est rien de plus que ce qui a été
promis par Ségur nous avions aussi pu
exprimer le besoin que la programmation
plus réelle de la dame intègre les
missions d'intérêt général financé par
le fondateurs
au Parlement et à nous une visibilité
dans le domaine sanitaire et
médico-social l'enjeu d'un Honda mal à
la hauteur c'est le maintien comme un de
notre système de santé on ne sait plus
comment dire qu'il est au bord de
l'effondrement j'aimerais ne pas avoir à
dire qu'il était fondé nous ne cessons
d'alerter au Parlement sur l'extension
continue des déserts médicaux sur la
crise d'évocation dans le métier du soin
sur les démissions en cascades sur la
crise que vivent les soignants les
rallonges ne pourront jamais se
substituer à une réelle vision de la
politique de la santé qu'il nous faut un
engagement de l'État sur la durée en
faveur de notre système de soins et des
soignants qui tiennent notre pays merci
Madame ponce madame Poumirol
oui merci monsieur le Président
par cet article le gouvernement
entendirait les conséquences des
différentes annonces faites par le
Président de la République notamment
lors de ses vœux aux acteurs de la santé
en janvier dernier pourtant cet article
maintient la baisse des dépenses de
santé pour l'année 2023 était prévu à
l'automne 2022 ainsi nous présente un
nombre rectifié et revalorisé de 750
millions d'euros vous venez de le redire
monsieur le ministre 600 millions
concernent les établissements de santé
notamment pour financer la prolongation
des mesures d'urgence concernant la
rémunération et du travail de nuit et du
travail en urgence dans les
établissements de santé et 150 millions
d'euros pour les soins de ville mais de
toute évidence le gouvernement n'a pas
pris la mesure de l'ampleur des besoins
de notre système de santé notre hôpital
se meurt nous le disons le répétons
partout des services d'urgence des
maternités fermes pas moins de 51 en
Occitanie et les personnels de santé
sont à bout nous vous avons interpellés
de nombreuses fois sur ces sujets sur
tous les bancs de notre assemblée tout
ce conscients des difficultés d'accès
d'accès aux soins des Français de la
souffrance des personnels et des besoins
de renforcer notre soutien à l'hôpital
pourtant et malgré votre communication
Londres est toujours très inférieure à
l'inflation et la revalorisation que
vous présentez là n'y changera rien on
est bien loin des milliards d'euros
nécessaires pour devenir nos hôpitaux et
notamment embaucher les infirmières
nécessaires à la mise en place du ratio
patients soignants que nous avons
présenté nous avons interrogé le
ministre de la Santé il y a quelques
mois sur sa volonté de proposer une
réponse pérenne et d'envergure pour
l'hôpital public voici aujourd'hui la
réponse d'un acte aucune ambition pour
notre hôpital public je le répète il
nous faut un plan Marshall pour
l'hôpital à moins que votre véritable
ambition ne soit d'abandonner le service
public de la santé et de laisser les
fonds de pension privée prendre la main
sur la santé comme elles font déjà merci
beaucoup d'endroits monsieur gay
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre et chers collègues 244
milliards voici l'objectif de dépenses à
ne pas dépasser pour les soins nos
hôpitaux publics ou privés au centre de
médecine bref
la santé de nos compatriotes et cela
fait 30 ans chez le ministre que
l'hôpital public va mal et manque de
moyens et on ne vous alerté sur tous ces
bancs à gauche depuis de nombreux temps
y compris le groupe communiste avait
fait un tour de France des hôpitaux
avant la crise du covid et on avait vu
la détresse de celles et ceux qui
tiennent l'hôpital à abra
et on vous avait alerté vous n'avez pas
écouté et puis après il y a eu la crise
du covid et on l'a vu l'hôpital a été
submergé il n'a tenu une nouvelle fois
que parlez-vousment de celles et ceux
qui travaillent mais maintenant ça ne
suffit plus il suffira plus de les
applaudir un soir à 20h à la fenêtre il
demande des moyens alors certes tout le
monde vient de le dire 600 millions mais
ce n'est pas suffisant et chacun dans
nos territoires on rencontre des oubliés
du Ségur qui viennent nous dire on n'est
pas rentré dans la case et pourtant nous
on était là aussi et on est toujours là
chaque fois qu'on va dans un hôpital on
nous dit regardez il y a des désertions
les gens ne veulent plus parce qu'il
n'arrive plus
il se sentent humilié
entendons ça et donc il nous faudra un
moment donné pas là puisqu'on n'a pas de
débat mais y revenir sincèrement et
mettre des moyens dans l'hôpital public
nous ne pourrons pas faire autrement et
puis dernière chose j'ai un petit
message officiel qui vient de mettre en
voilier sur le Président si vous me
permettez je pense que ça va intéresser
tout le monde il y a six manifestations
historiques dans le pays
90% des actifs opposés à la retraite à
64 ans et votre seul réponse est le
mépris mépris envers l'opposition
sénatoriale mépris du président de la
République envers les syndicats qui
refuseront recevoir mes prix envers les
salariés et les Français votre projet
n'est pas légitime retirez-le je vous
remercie monsieur c'est pas c'est pas
monsieur parisji qui vous a envoyé un
SMS à vous donc c'est pas en salle des
conférences la salle qui jouxte
l'hémicycle ou se tiennent ces débats
que vous suivez en direction de notre
antenne je suis avec Hélène canon Mouret
bonjour madame comment Mouret vous êtes
sénatrice PS des Français établit hors
de France un mot sur ce qui se joue dans
l'hémicycle le décompte de Public Sénat
qui est autour de 300 amendements un des
comptes un nombre d'amendements qui qui
font un peu comme neige au soleil
notamment parce qu'il manque des
collègues à vous qui sont pas là pour
défendre des amendements de suppression
et ils sont les seuls signatures de les
seuls signataires des amendements donc
les amendements tombent c'est un peu ce
qui est en train de se jouer là et on
rentre dans la dernière ligne droite des
débats c'est bien ça et certainement et
heureusement puisque de toute façon nous
arrêtons demain
absolument donc en effet nous
aboutissons nous allons jusqu'au bout de
ce débat qui n'en est pas un puisque la
moitié de l'hémicycle ne débat pas ne
contribue pas donc il y a pas d'échanges
et nous sommes là et je viens de le dire
en présentant un amendement finalement
dans une sorte de pédagogie pour dire et
répéter au gouvernement qu'il fait une
erreur en présentant ce projet de loi
qui fait une erreur politique en santé
temps on ne voulait pas écouter ni ce
qui se passe ou ce qui aurait pu se
passer parce que nous étions prêts nous
étions prêts à débattre nous étions
prêts nous avons travaillé pendant des
mois pour améliorer le texte il y avait
beaucoup de choses et on l'a vu à
l'Assemblée nationale dans un premier
temps qu'en effet il y avait des manques
il y a des annonces qui ont été faites
et en fait le résultat était tout autre
sur les 1200 euros sur les femmes enfin
les carrières assez ainsi de suite et
donc nous étions prêts à rectifier tout
cela et nous avions notamment mais il
n'y a pas de débat nous en sommes privés
on nous demande d'accélérer parce que et
bien la majorité sénatoriale veut que
son texte passe et ce qui est déroutant
c'est que en fait l'ensemble du texte se
repose sur le totem des 64 ans comme si
c'était la mesure seule et unique qu'il
est bon de défendre et d'imposer aux
Français qui n'en veulent pas et qui
manifeste encore aujourd'hui contre
cette réforme justement qu'est-ce que
vous dites à ces manifestants et qui
sont en train de défiler et qui
peut-être regarde l'émission sur leur
téléphone dans les cortèges ils sont ils
vont peut-être être déçus de voir que le
texte va être voté peut-être ce soir ou
demain matin est-ce qu'il faut les
remobiliser ou est-ce que ça va pas les
démobiliser mécaniquement il y a pas
simplement une mobilisation
enfin pour bien sûr que la mobilisation
est là pour faire changer le
gouvernement d'avis mais si nous restons
mobilisés alors que de toute évidence
nous avons quand même un certain mépris
de notre travail puisque nous sommes
limités à un débat qui n'en est pas un
nous sommes limités à présenter des
amendements avec un avis de la
commission et un avis du gouvernement en
sachant très bien que de toute façon ils
ne seront pas retenus donc infinés nous
continuons à batailler pour simplement
dire au gouvernement que aujourd'hui il
est en train de faire éclater la
cohésion sociale il est en train de
commettre une erreur politique majeure
et qu'il est temps de s'arrêter on
arrive dans les 10 dernières heures de
débat c'est à peu près le calcul si on
multiplie le nombre d'amendements par le
les deux minutes par reprise de parole
vous pas toujours tiendrez de ces 10
jours alors qu'on arrive dans la
dernière ligne droite
une fraction parce que je crois que nous
sommes tous arrivés
et bien travaillé à un projet de loi qui
est très important puisque
sur les Français de l'étranger en
particulier nous étions avec mes
collègues nous avons travaillé pendant
des mois proposer avoir des propositions
concrètes d'amélioration
de de faire en sorte que les Français de
l'étranger qui sont les premiers
pénalisés puisqu'il se retrouvent dans
la catégorie des femmes c'est-à-dire des
carrières hachées ce sont des gens qui
ont choisi la mobilité qui partent à
l'étranger après avoir cotisé en France
cotise à l'étranger reviennent parfois
en France et donc ce sont des carrières
hachées qui n'est pas linéaires avec un
emploi salarié de 20 ans à la retraite
43 annuités qu'on leur demande il aurait
pu combler ces éléments dans dans les
carrières HD des des Français
nous avions des propositions pour
améliorer le texte et surtout répondre à
un certain nombre de problématiques et
de problèmes qu'ils rencontrent à
l'étranger et nous avions enfin le le
support législatif pour rectifier tout
cela et nous en avons été privés donc
aujourd'hui je prends la parole en effet
sur une base de pédagogie qui est basée
sur la répétition que nous avons un vrai
problème et qu'il faut arrêter tout cela
j'ai une dernière question vous avez été
membre du gouvernement avec Marisol
Touraine qui a porté la précédente
réforme on entend la droite qui vous
renvoie à cette accélération des 43
annuités puisque c'est la réforme
Touraine qui avait mis cette ce nombre
d'annuité comment est-ce que vous
expliquez le fait que vous êtes concept
très fort à la droite qui qui vous
renvoie cette réforme Touraine mais
enfin d'abord c'est pas la même chose on
pourrait la proposition et totalement
différente puisque là on propose avec ce
nouveau projet de loi de rallonger de
deux ans le nombre d'années travaillées
sous prétexte que on a besoin d'aller à
l'équilibre en 2030 alors qu'on sait
très bien que ça ne sera pas le cas donc
c'est une finalement une décision
budgétaire qui a été qui a motivé on va
dire le lancement de cette réforme et en
fait elle a été pour moi mal pensée mal
bouclée je pense qu'on avait la
possibilité de faire en sorte que nous
avions peut-être un nouvel acquis social
que aurait pu s'ajouter à ce que les
Français ont bénéficié depuis 1936
finalement avec à chaque étape
finalement des des droits sociaux qui
font que nous avons du temps libre que
aujourd'hui les billes actifs sont en
capacité et bien de trouver un équilibre
entre leur vie professionnelle et leur
vie active et que l'on pouvait ajouter à
cela au lieu de cela en positif était
possible vous le dites avec des gens on
se rend bien compte que on est en train
de rétropédaler de revenir en arrière et
c'est pour ça que les Français
manifestent parce qu'il ne veut ils ne
veulent pas perdre ils auraient aimé
qu'on avance et non pas qu'on recule
merci merci pour cette réaction au micro
de public c'est même madame Conway Morel
alors que dans l'hémicycle on est en
train de passer sous la barre des 300
amendements qu'il reste à examiner
autour de la réforme de retraite au
Sénat
élu les républicains à l'Assemblée
nationale oui un compteur qui fond comme
neige au soleil Quentin puisque depuis
l'article 14 est jusqu'à la fin des 5
articles restants et bien les
amendements sont des amendements de
suppression des articles c'est la seule
arme qui leur reste à la gauche car
étant dans le volet dotation et
objectifs je vous rappelle Quentin il
n'est pas possible de créer de nouvelles
dépenses ça c'est l'article 40 de la
Constitution problème ses amendements de
suppression bien qu'il soit nombreux ne
sont signés qu'individuellement par les
sénateur et donc si le ou la sénatrice
le sénateur ou la sénatrice signataire
est absent et bien il ne peut pas être
soutenu et Quentin et bien cet
après-midi les bancs de la gauche sont
bien dégarnies tout à l'heure à la
louche en 20 minutes on a perdu à peu
près 20 amendements oui voilà c'est ça
il y a une vingtaine de sénateurs PS qui
ne défendent pas leurs amendements qui
sont absents de l'hémicycle et donc les
amendements sont considérés comme non
soutenus ce qui fait donc effectivement
baisser le compteur des amendements
qu'il reste à examiner merci Mathias
pour ces explications de dépenses
d'assurance maladie objectifs et nous en
demandons la suppression il confirme la
baisse de la dépense de santé imposée
par le gouvernement à l'automne dernier
c'est ton dame est largement
sous-évalué en effet lors de l'adoption
du budget de la Sécurité sociale pour
2023 nous avons déjà fortement critiqué
cette baisse de 1,2 % des dépenses de
santé par rapport à 2022 tandis que
l'inflation est à 4,3 l'hôpital public
craque de tous les côtés ça a déjà été
dit le manque de personnel à entraîné la
fermeture de près de 20% des liés
hospitaliers des menaces sur les
maternités en particulier les petites
maternités de nos départements que des
hommes médecins parisiens veulent rendre
rayer de la carte de France je fais
référence au rapport ville cette année
c'est une véritable cure d'austérité au
mépris de la santé des forcée des
Français des millions de des millions
des milliers de
costaméricains c'est déjà beaucoup
manifesté aujourd'hui pour dire non à
ses menaces de fermeture je suis
solidaire de cette mobilisation pour
dire NON NON fermeture de lit non à la
réforme des retraites qui rallonge de
deux ans le travail obligatoire alors
dans tous les coins de France 6
manifestation historique 90% des actifs
opposés à la retraite à 64 ans et la
seule réponse est le mépris mépris
envers l'opposition et sénatoriale et
surtout le mépris du président de la
République envers les syndicats il
refuse de recevoir mépris envers les
salariés et les Français votre projet
n'est pas légitime retirez-le
mal cuite en breton
bon
allez tout à l'heure c'est un anglais
maintenant c'est en breton madame latrix
comptas vous voulez bien le faire en
français dans l'hémicycle merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues comme l'a dit mon
collègue Rémi fero nous en sommes nous
sommes amenés à proposer des amendements
de suppression pour en réalité demander
plus nous l'avions déjà fait lors de
l'étude du plfs et là encore le compte
n'y est pas tant les enjeux sont
colossaux vous connaissez bien entendu
la situation de notre hôpital public
proche de l'effondrement nous avons
d'ailleurs dans le cadre d'une
proposition de loi adoptée dans cette
hémicycle prenez un ratio minimal de
soignants parler ouvert ou par nombre de
passages pour chaque spécialité ou type
d'activité et bien entendu cela
nécessite des moyens c'est parce que
nous avons fait le constat que l'hôpital
public manquait de moyens
soignant que nous avons fait cette
proposition donc le relèvement des
dépenses de santé consacrées à l'hôpital
et à la médecine publique est absolument
indispensable le gouvernement évoque
souvent la prévention comment faire de
la prévention sans soignant comment
attirer les soignants les médecins sans
augmenter leur rémunération donc sans
augmenter ses dépenses de sécurité
sociale je vis dans un département
l'infortement touché par les questions
des certifications médicales avec 15%
quand même des habitants qui n'ont pas
de médecin traitant des difficultés
d'accès aux soins souvent à renoncement
d'accès aux soins d'aider l'aide rendez
vous de plus en plus long et la
lourdement l'alourdissement comme dans
beaucoup d'endroits des de la
fréquentation des services d'urgence
donc le budget n'apporte pas de réponse
suffisante n'est pas à la hauteur et la
réforme des retraites qui figurent aussi
dans ce projet de loi
aggravera encore la situation avec des
personnes
usées qui devront travailler plus
longtemps qui seront encore davantage
malades il faut retirer ce projet dans
son ensemble merci madame de La Gontrie
le 799
merci monsieur le Président je crois
qu'il est utile pour soutenir la
l'amendement de suppression que nous
sommes plusieurs à présenter de rappeler
les informations très pertinentes et
très utiles contenu dans le rapport de
la commission qui rappelait que le Sénat
n'avait pas adopté l'article du PLFSS
pour 2023 qui fixait le montant de
l'ondondam et que les critiques qui
étaient faites à l'époque par notre
collègue Corinne Imbert et qui avait
motivé ce refus étaient des hypothèses
trop optimistes en matière de
conséquences de l'inflation sur les
coups du système de santé et l'absence
de traduction dans l'onde 2023 des
annonces au fil de l'eau a été annoncé
une augmentation du niveau de
l'ondamment nous estimons qui n'est pas
qui n'est pas suffisant par rapport aux
besoins et enfin je dirais pour vous
convaincre encore une fois
j'essaye
en pensant que ce sera plus efficace de
faire appel aux paroles de vos collègues
de votre propre groupe LR un autre de
vos collègues qui a également voté
contre l'article 7 a publié le texte
suivant après le 49,3 le 44 3 permet au
gouvernement certes en toute légalité de
piétiner les débats parlementaires
voici comment dégoutter les Français de
la politique et alimenter le tout pourri
voilà pourquoi lorsque l'heure du vote
finale arrivera il faut vraiment que
vous réfléchissiez avant de vous lier
définitivement à cette réforme funeste
merci Monsieur Durin le 884
merci monsieur le Président c'est
amendement des sénateurs écologistes
socialistes écologistes et républicain
visa rejeter la confirmation de
l'objectif national de dépenses
d'assurance maladie telle qu'elle est
proposée par le gouvernement dans cet
article alors évidemment nous sommes
très attachés au compte public mais nous
ne sommes pas des comptables
nous ne sommes pas des comptables ou
plus exactement nous ne comptons pas
comme vous et dans ce texte vous avez
choisi de compter avec la vie des gens
plutôt avec d'autres moyens de financer
cette réforme des retraites et d'autres
moyens de financer nos services publics
mon collègue Patrice Joly indiquait tout
à l'heure que aujourd'hui même dans
notre département de Saône-et-Loire
avait lieu à autant une une
manifestation contre la fermeture de la
maternité c'est un territoire en colère
ce sont des des élus désespérés des
citoyens qui se sentent désarmés et dans
ce texte sur cet article nous parlons de
la vie des gens de leur santé leur
souffrance au travail nous parlons de
chiffres évidemment mais nous parlons
surtout de réalité très concrète dans la
vie de chacun dans la période je puisque
nous ne sommes pas des comptables mais
nous sommes assis au chiffre il y a bien
un ruissellement sur ruissellement c'est
celui de l'indignation de l'exaspération
la colère sur les territoires chez les
élus chez les habitants et finalement
les seuls bons comptes les seuls bons
comptes dans la période ce sont ceux que
font certains élus extrémistes qui
voient leurs capitales prospérer et sur
ces élus là la République elle elle ne
peut pas compter merci Monsieur Cardon
le 964
merci monsieur le Président
effectivement
un article de suppression fait preuve de
pédagogie de répétition
j'ai effectivement fait un petit passage
j'ai pris l'air dehors il y a une
manifestation qui a pris une certaine
ampleur je vois que ça vous intéresse
pas forcément mais c'est pas grave vous
serez vous serez rappelé par vos
électeurs prochainement quand vous allez
faire un retour dans vos
circonscriptions ah vous êtes vivant
tiens vous êtes vivant je pensais que il
y avait personne en face d'accord bon
sur monsieur Cardon
monsieur Cardon vous pouvez mettre le
cas mais si vous voulez ne jouez pas
faites votre amendement merci merci
de ne pas répondre on continue monsieur
Cardon merci
donc bon on va si on fait les comptes en
réalité puisque c'est votre objectif
c'est de faire peser cette réforme sur
les millions de Français qui travaillent
et d'ailleurs c'est là où c'est un
maquette parce qu'en réalité la droite
sanatoriale est quand même fan de la
valeur travail et qui prend en compte
bah oui non mais c'est quand même vous
êtes vous êtes quand même obsédé par ça
donc si vous voulez ça fait quand même
ça me fait quand même doucement rigoler
en réalité ah mais quand même
le cardon défendez votre amendement
allez bah écoutez
c'est impressionnant que de
pardon enfin voilà je viens de me faire
traiter de apparemment
[Musique]
après alors après après
s'attaquer au justement aux personnes au
Seigneur vous vous attaquez aux jeunes
maintenant
passez quand même dingue
parce que je suis coupé ça s'appelle de
l'obstruction parlementaire monsieur le
Président merci franchement elle est
après c'est qui Lubin madame Lubin pour
le 1162 madame Lubin
le 1162 pardon madame
Lubin madame Lubin seul le 1162
[Musique]
millions d'euros London c'est quand même
extraordinaire parce que lors du PLFSS
vous vous étiez particulièrement
satisfait de l'augmentation de longue
dame que vous nous proposiez et nous
vous répétitions sans cesse que c'était
loin d'être suffisant puisque avec une
inflation à 6% de toute façon les
retards ne seraient pas comblés et les
attentes notamment de l'hôpital public
ne serait pas non plus comblé il se
trouve que dans une loi de finances de
la sécurité sociale rectificative c'est
ces tableaux et ses articles sont
obligatoires et vous en avez profité
pour mettre un cataplasme sur une jambe
de bois c'est mieux que rien mais c'est
bien loin bien loin de ce qu'attendre de
les soignants de ce pays et j'avoue que
lorsque nous entendons les témoignages
partout dans n'importe quelle région de
France dans laquelle nous vivons lorsque
quelquefois nous sommes nous-mêmes
côté pour nous ou nos familles à des
situations à des besoins notamment de de
suivi de traitement dans un hôpital
public
j'avoue que le paysage est de plus en
plus noir je ne pensais pas moi que
j'aurais à entendre un jour en
commission des affaires sociales des
collègues spécialisés me dire que selon
l'endroit dans lequel on vit en France
on peut être victime de ce qu'on appelle
une perte de chance
une perte de chance et oui mais il y a
10 ans on entendait pas à parler de ça
après avoir eu une vision parfaitement
comptable de l'hôpital public on en est
arrivé à laisser de côté l'intérêt des
patients alors je vous je sais derrière
les choses ont fait que personne n'a
rectifié le tir mais aujourd'hui la
situation est très grave merci le 1296
monsieur Montauger merci monsieur le
Président chers collègues monsieur le
ministre nous avons souvent dit au cours
de ce débat qui a tourné parce que vous
l'avez voulu comme ça au dialogue de
sourd qu'avant de discuter de ce texte
consacré aux retraites vous auriez dû
monsieur le ministre le président de la
République aurait dû engager le
Parlement sur un texte qui traite du
travail et de la place du travail dans
la société française au 21ème siècle et
dans ce sujet de London il y a la
question centrale des données des moyens
donnés aux acteurs de la santé et donc
dans notre pays quel est le projet de
santé français pour le 21ème siècle pour
l'hôpital pour la médecine de ville et
de campagne pour nos territoires en
grande difficulté d'accès aux soins de
premier recours et également aux
spécialités de base il faudra beaucoup
plus que le cosmétique CNR santé j'ouvre
une parenthèse pour dire que avoir
utilisé la chronique CNR est un
véritable scandale pour moi eu égard à
ce que la notion représente dans
l'histoire de notre pays donc il faudra
plus que ce CNR à santé et mis la main
cosmétique pour répondre à ces questions
nous avons ici dans mon groupe rejeté un
décembre dernier London il n'y a
absolument aucune raison même avec la
révision qui est qui est proposée de
l'approuver aujourd'hui c'est la raison
pour laquelle dans cet amendement 1296
nous nous rejetons la proposition du
gouvernement
merci Monsieur Kerrouche le 1457 sur
votre série d'amendements au terme de la
série d'abondance je donnerai la parole
à Monsieur Ferro je donnerai la parole à
Monsieur Ferro au terme madame de La
Gontrie c'est encore moi qui précise
madame de La Gontrie la Conférence des
Présidents a dit clairement les choses
je donnerai la parole pour le rappel le
règlement au terme ce sont vos
amendements
identiques laissez finir la série enfin
c'est absurde monsieur Kerrouche
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre c'est le combat des Voraces
contre les coriaces mais les vorace ont
complètement mangé et dévorer les
coriaces c'est une citation de bureau
d'Alfred Jarry
et je dois vous dire Monsieur le
Ministre que vous êtes passé du camp des
coriace dans celui dévorace et c'est
exactement ce que traduit cet article 15
que nous voulons supprimer comme le 14
tout à l'heure comme le sceptre est bien
d'autres articles de cette de cette loi
parce que au final quand on regarde ce
texte comme cet article
on constate qu'une chose en fait le
macronisme c'est la langue et la
grammaire du mépris social
c'est exactement cela c'est accepter les
hiérarchies sociales donner sa place à
chacun mais sûrement pas au plus faible
c'est faire comprendre à certains
qu'ils sont en quelque sorte des
citoyens jetables et on leur explique
que comme ils sont faibles ils ne
peuvent pas comprendre et on prend les
bonnes décisions à leur place et on leur
explique qu'il faut qu'il fasse des
sacrifices mais de l'extérieur c'est
aussi le fait que nous avons un problème
de représentation démocratique parce que
en fait toutes ces voies ne sont pas
assez représentées ici et la conséquence
qui a été montrée dans de nombreuses
analyses de sciences politiques c'est
que bien entendu comme ces voix sont peu
représenter la plupart des politiques
publiques néolibérales se font à leur
rencontre
alors
monsieur le ministre beaucoup a été dit
sur cette réforme et quand on regarde
les chiffres parce que parfois les
sondages sont trompeurs on peut en
revanche en tirer quelque chose de fort
c'est le taux de rejet de cette réforme
entendez le redevenez un commerce merci
Monsieur Stanzione 1531
pardon madame Conon et Mouret pardon le
le 1188 madame Conway
le président monsieur le ministre
mon pas votre entêtement a passé en
forme on force pardon quoi qu'il en
coûte à notre pays en matière de
cohésion sociale que vous faites éclater
avec le non-respect des causes
intermédiaires et le mépris du Parlement
que vous considérez comme une chambre
d'enregistrement ce que nous n'avons
jamais été et enfin le pari que vous
faites de passer en force et que nous
enverrai embrayerons sur le prochain
texte en oubliant ce qui s'est passé
cette semaine et bien non je crois que
quelque chose a été cassé cette semaine
ici dans la chambre haute et laissera
des traces et pour longtemps car ce
n'est pas le style de la maison de ne
pas écouter de ne pas rechercher le
consensus de ne pas rechercher à
améliorer les textes au plus proche de
la réalité de terrain et surtout nous
n'avons jamais reculé devant l'exercice
du contrôle de l'action du gouvernement
avec de nombreuses missions d'enquête et
d'informations alors aujourd'hui
nous continuons à dire avec ses
amendements que nous continuerons le
combat pour notre hôpital public et pour
les femmes les femmes et les hommes qui
les font vivre
et c'est tout ce que j'ai à dire
merci le 1531 monsieur stand-yonne
il est toujours pas la pardon alors
madame Monnier le 1561 merci monsieur le
Président donc cette amendement et cet
article traite de London qui est
l'objectif national de dépenses
d'assurance maladie comme l'a dit mon
collègue Montaugé déjà quand on a
examiné le projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale pour de vie de
trois il n'était pas à la hauteur et ce
projet de leur rectificativement ce qui
ne l'est pas non plus aujourd'hui à
l'époque nous avions souligné dans un
contexte où notre système de soins et
ses personnels sont exangs qu'il est
plus que temps de sortir de la logique
délétère de rationalisation budgétaire
pour repartir enfin de l'essentiel à
savoir les besoins de santé du pays la
pénurie de soignante et de soignants à
laquelle notre pays est confronté doit
nous interpeller sur la nécessité de
rendre plus active leur rémunération
plus attractive pardon leur rémunération
mais aussi leurs conditions de travail
ce qui nécessite d'alouer des moyens à
la hauteur de notre offre de santé selon
la revue de l'an 7 tout des exercices
confondus l'Hexagone comptabilise en
moyenne
336,5 soignants pour 10000 habitants à
titre de comparaison la moyenne de
l'Europe de l'Ouest est de 407 soignants
pour 10000 habitants nous faisons figure
de mauvais élèves quant à la densité
d'infirmiers 87,7 pour 10000 et de
médecins 24,8 pour des milles à titre
d'exemple la Norvège et l'Allemagne
affiche par exemple respectivement 211
et 176 infirmiers pour 10000 habitants 7
désertification nous la payons d'ores et
déjà très durement dans nos territoires
ruraux où il est déjà selon la MRF 6
fois plus difficile de consulter un
médecin améliorural qu'en ville un
phénomène qui va en s'accélérant avec le
vieillissement du personnel médical et
le rapport sénasterial sur femme et
rivalité a pointé le manque criant de
gynécologue en milieu rural nous aurions
préféré que ce projet de loi de finance
rectificative la sécurité sociale soit
l'occasion et c'était tout rêvé pour que
le pour que le gouvernement nous
présente un homme plus ambitieux
malheureusement ce n'est pas du tout le
cas il n'y a donc qu'une solution votre
énergie pomirol le 1643
voilà si vous n'engeniez nous sommes en
direct sur public Senna il est très
précisément 17h01 et 30 secondes on va
rejoindre Mathias sarez pour un point
sur la séance Mathias vous venez de me
le confier il reste 274 amendements à
examiner ça fout un peu comme neige au
soleil n'est-ce pas il en reste même
maintenant 269 Quentin je me suis
retourné à l'instant c'était 271 ça fond
effectivement comme neige au soleil
pourquoi et bien tout simplement parce
que nous nous trouvons dans le volet
dotation et objectif donc un volet où
les seuls amendements possibles la seule
arme que peuvent utiliser les
parlementaires de gauche et bien ce sont
des amendements de suppression des
amendements de suppression qu'il signe
de manière individuelle et donc s'il le
sénateur ou la sénatrice est absent et
bien il ne peut pas défendre cette
amendement donc depuis tout à l'heure et
bien on voit les amendements tombés les
uns après les autres un rythmes des
débats qui s'accélèrent donc Quentin est
donc la possibilité qui grandit de voir
un vote sur l'intégralité de ce texte
peut être ce soir on va voir quelle va
être la stratégie de la gauche
sénatoriale dispose-t-elle encore
d'armes du règlement ou de la
Constitution pour rallonger
éventuellement ses débats puisque elle
espère qu'il n'y ait pas de vote sur
l'intégralité du texte d'ici demain
minuit ou bien la droite sanatoriale
va-t-elle parvenir à voter un texte tard
dans la soirée ou demain assez tôt c'est
l'enjeu maintenant des prochaines heures
retour dans l'hémicycle alors que cette
réforme repousse le départ à la retraite
de deux ans c'est un sincère les
personnes de 62 64 ans au chômage ou en
emploi ont des risques accrus de fatigue
on a parlé hier de pénibilité d'usure
professionnelle de santé au travail et
ces épuisement c'est fatigue ne seront
pas traités par la branche accident du
travail et maladie professionnelle dans
un premier temps elles seront prises il
y aura des arrêts maladie des indemnités
journalière et donc automatiquement des
incidences sur la branche maladie donc
tout ça sera des répercussions et malgré
tout face à cela face aux manifestations
historiques qui se produisent ici en
France depuis deux mois face au 90% des
actifs opposés à la retraite à 64 ans
votre seule réponse monsieur le ministre
c'est le mépris le mépris envers
l'opposition sénatoriale et surtout le
mépris du président de la République qui
refuse de rencontrer les syndicats
mépris envers les salariés mépris envers
les Français votre projet n'est pas
légitime retrait
merci Monsieur président de canner le
1840 oui merci Monsieur prudent monsieur
ministre mais chers collègues
nous tenons nous résistons d'amendements
d'amendement d'articles en articles je
salue la résilience de nos collègues qui
nous écoutent
voilà donc ça bouge un peu encore
en face
ça me fait penser à un film de ma
jeunesse mais que vous avez sûrement vu
parce que nous avons la même jeunesse
c'est fort à la mot
fort à la main vous savez c'était le 6
mars 1836
c'est le 10e jour où nous travaillons
ensemble et
ça a duré aussi 10 jours et c'est vrai
que le 6 mars 1936
le trappeur David Crockett et d'autres
ils étaient 187 et bien sont tombés face
à 5000 soldats mexicains alors qu'il
défendaient l'autonomie et
l'indépendance du du Texas alors je vous
rassure vous allez pas nous faire tomber
physiquement vous allez sûrement nous
faire tomber politiquement je n'en doute
pas un seul instant et pourtant mes
chers collègues et pourtant si vous avez
une victoire dans les heures qui
viennent qui est fort probable une
victoire à la Pyrrhus ou je ne sais pas
à quoi en tout cas sachez que si nous
avons résisté si nous résistons nous
continuerons à résister contre cette
réforme dont les Français ne veulent pas
ils l'ont encore exprimé tout à l'heure
une réforme qui est marquée par le
mépris le mépris du président de la
République vis-à-vis notamment du monde
syndical finalement ça n'est que la
réplique de son quinquennat précédent
vous n'avez pas respecté les corps
intermédiaires et bien donc malgré votre
fatigue malgré aussi notre fatigue parce
qu'on parle un peu plus que vous vous
l'avez compris nous continuerons à être
présent nous continuerons à être présent
dans cette émission pour dire non à
cette réforme il faut la retirer
merci monsieur le Président Cannet de
mémoire monsieur le Président kaner
c'était pas 5000 mexicains mais 7000
sous les ordres du général Santana en
allez le 1862 de Monsieur Assouline
oui donc on va continuer à essayer de
vous sensibiliser à l'injustice de cette
réforme vous vous le savez que selon une
étude de l'INSEE de 2018 dans la
catégorie des 5% les plus pauvres il
ressort que 25% sont effectivement déjà
morts à l'autre extrémité de l'échelle
sociale chez les 5% les plus fortunés
avec 5600 euros par mois c'est à peu
près ce qui est pris comme niveau
95% des hommes sont encore en vie à 62
ans seul 5% sont déjà décédés
ces chiffres doivent vous montrer
pourquoi pour certaines catégories de la
population qui sont majoritaires qui ont
déjà dans les plus grandes souffrances
de la vie pendant la durée de leur
travail la question de la retraite est
si sensible j'ai entendu des discours
hors-sol mais que je peux entendre si on
reste dans son milieu social
que mais bon 64 ans avec l'espérance de
vie
c'est pas terrible quand on a bossé
peut-être dans un bureau mais dans une
relative
sérénité mais il faut comprendre que
pour certains c'est une course pour la
vie et que ils savent
que déjà dans la fin de leur vie
professionnelle ils sont diminués
physiquement
moralement et que peut-être ils vont
mourir avant les autres ils ont besoin
de ce moment-là il est beaucoup plus
recherché que dans des catégories aisées
voilà pourquoi vous devez comprendre ce
que disent encore dans la rue des
centaines de milliers de Français de nos
concitoyens et pourquoi cette réforme
dans ce moment de grande difficulté
économique il faut vraiment la retirer
si on ne veut pas fracturer le pays
merci Monsieur Assouline le 1928
monsieur Joly
monsieur le Président féministe mes
chers collègues cet abonnement est un
abonnement vous l'avez compris de rejet
de cette de l'objectif national des
dépenses d'assurance maladie parce que
le montant qui est fixé présente enfin
en tout cas conduit à ce qu'il y ait une
baisse légère une baisse plutôt des
valeurs réelles des dépenses de
l'assurance maladie alors que les
besoins sont immenses il s'agit là d'une
des raisons supplémentaires
effectivement de rejeter ce texte dont
on voit bien qu'il n'est pas bouclé de
manière satisfaisante en prenant en
compte les besoins des Français c'est
d'ailleurs ce que comprenne des milliers
de Français mobilisés au cours de ces
derniers jours avec ces six
manifestations historiques avec
90% des actifs qui sont opposés à ces
reports de la Juventus à 64 ans et avec
une réponse la vôtre la seule d'ailleurs
qui est le mépris mépris envers notre
opposition c'est Royal qui est bâillonné
et surtout mépris du président de la
République qui s'étaient prononcé en
tout cas dont on sait très bien qu'il
s'agit là de sa réforme premier prix
envers les syndicats qu'il refuse de
recevoir mes pris en vert en définitive
les salariés et l'ensemble des Français
c'est un projet qui n'est pas légitime
le peuple le montre on vous demande de
le retirer les besoins sont réels je le
disais parce que il y a à travailler sur
les différences d'espérance de vie en
France je le disais il y a quelques
jours de deux ans d'espérance de vie
selon le territoire où on habite avec
notamment une espérance plus faible sur
les territoires ruraux sur les
territoires métropolitain mais je sais
aussi que sur les territoires militants
des parties des quartiers ne sont pas
dotés de manière satisfaisante et
suffisante deux ans d'écart de vie 50
dans certains cas si on y ajoute les
écarts de vie selon les catégories
sociales on voit l'ampleur de
l'injustice qu'il y a lieu de corriger
et à travers également ça a été dit
avant moi l'augmentation entre la
prolongation de la durée au travail on
voit que c'est injustice va être
renforcée mais au regard des
conséquences qu'elle a mais ceux qui
travaillent dans les plus difficiles
merci le 2008 madame la présidentielle
merci monsieur le Président vous nous
avez invité tout à l'heure à évoquer les
amendements lors de nos présentations
d'amendement et franchement mes chers
collègues vous seriez surprises nous
n'avions pas des amendements de
suppression de l'article 15 nous avions
des amendements de suppression de
l'article luminaire c'est l'article 15
et le pendant et Madame la rapporteur
Elisabeth Doisneau hoche la tête de haut
en bas ce qui signifie qui est à qui
est-ce à mon propos et je sais que si
nous n'avions pas fait elle n'aurait pas
manqué de pointer cette incohérence ceci
pour vous montrer que nous ne sommes pas
là pour faire autre chose que d'évoquer
la cohérence de nos amendements ceci
étant dit je pense que nous n'avons pas
suffisamment évoqué du fait de se
débattromper la question des femmes et
de la retraite
le gouvernement nous a présenté son
projet de voyage pas 6 semaines 8
semaines c'est tout juste c'était pas un
projet de loi concocté dans les réunions
du MLF à les entendre ou de nous tous ou
je ne sais quelle organisation féministe
contemporaine c'était un projet pour les
femmes en marquez bien maintenant que
j'ai vu que monsieur Ciotti nous
expliquer avec le féminisme était une
valeur de droite que votre effort est de
gauche je fais je prends avec beaucoup
de prudence ce que disent les uns et les
autres pour autant il me reste 47
secondes pour vous dire que ce projet
n'est pas féministe parce qu'il ne prend
pas en compte la particularité que
connaissent les femmes dans leur
activité professionnelle et ensuite dans
la retraite et puisqu'on parle de la
dame particulièrement des soignante et
des critères de pénibilité qui excluent
les charges lourdes des critères de
pénibilité depuis 2017 or les
infirmières c'est désolant à dire on
s'étend d'espérance de vie en moi que la
moyenne des femmes parce que leurs
critères de pénibilité ne sont pas
retenues depuis que vous les en avez
privés en 2017 une véritable réforme
féministe monsieur le ministre au cas où
vous auriez vraiment songé à le faire
elle aurait pris en compte les
spécificités à la fois de la charge
physique et de la charge mentale qui
pèse sur les femmes et avec ces critères
là vous auriez pu vous présenter devant
les femmes en disant nous avons fait
quelque chose pour vous merci madame la
Présidente le 2289 monsieur Tissot
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues comme
l'article précédent cet article 15 nous
est imposé dans le cadre d'un texte de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale il s'agit maintenant de nous
prononcer sur un objectif national de
dépense d'assurance maladie où l'on dame
a changé par rapport à celui adopté dans
le PLFSS pour 2023 même si cet article
tient en une seule phrase il y aura
beaucoup à dire tout d'abord parce que
l'objectif de défense de dépenses fixé
par le gouvernement est insuffisant il
est suffisant aujourd'hui comme il
l'était à l'automne il tape en effet sur
des dépenses d'assurance maladie en
baisse alors même qu'elle s'inscrit dans
un contexte d'inflation de plus de 4%,
ne pouvant corriger ce chiffre sous
peine de tomber sur le coup de l'article
40 qui nous interdit toute création
dépenses supplémentaires nous proposons
donc la suppression de cet article avec
cet amendement sinon il faudra que
quelqu'un nous explique par quel miracle
les dépenses d'assurance maladie
seraient suspendues hors du temps et
échapperait un inflation mais c'est vrai
j'oubliais personne nous expliquera rien
puisque le recours à l'article 44-3 par
le gouvernement interdit tout débat sur
nos amendements nous voici
constitutionnellement réduit à nous
exprimer dans
pas grand chose par rapport au premier
jour des débats pour nos collègues de
droite qui s'étaient déjà appliqués
d'eux-mêmes par anticipation cet article
40-44-3 en restant volontairement muet
on peut désormais dire que la droite
sénatoriale aura littéralement devancé
les désirs du gouvernement mais pour
l'intérêt des débats cela va quand même
poser problème que nos questions ou
propositions nous souhaitent annoncés
par avance comme ne méritant aucune
réponse au point où nous en sommes
rendus la question qui se pose à votre
gouvernement monsieur le ministre c'est
pourquoi ne pas avoir fait simplement
c'est très forme des retraites par
ordonnance vous auriez fait gagner du
temps à nos collègues de droite qui
avait visiblement mieux à faire que
prendre 12 journées pour décider en
pleine connaissance de cause que nos
concitoyens devront travailler deux ans
plus certains d'entre vous ont eu
l'indécence de traiter de feignasse et
travailleurs attachés à prendre leur
retraite à 62 ans que pensez-vous qu'ils
vont penser de ces sénateurs nos
concitoyens prêts à tous les sacrifices
pour pouvoir partir en week-end en gros
à vous les art ifices à eux les
sacrifices merci il ne faut pas venir
1895 madame ponce
madame ah pardon monsieur salmon alors
ma chère collègues est un peu multiforme
au loyer merci monsieur le Président
avec cette amendement de suppression
nous vous demandons de reconsidérer en
profondeur les logiques austéritaires
qui ont présidé à l'établissement de la
dame jusqu'à présent nous vous demandons
de financer les établissements de santé
à la hauteur des besoins à virgule deux
milliards supplémentaires dès à présent
en suivant une logique des besoins des
territoires de santé et non de logique
austéritaires à peine atténuer par des
rallonges ponctuelles et insuffisantes
ainsi la rectification partielle de la
dame 2022 ne suffit pas à masquer un nom
d'âme 2023 qui nous rattrape pas le
retard des budgets précédents d'autant
que l'inflation persiste et pèse sur les
investissements
mais au-delà de cet de cet amendement
cette réforme des retraites pose un
débat de fond quel monde voulons-nous
voulons-nous de ce monde qui glorifie la
valeur travail mais qui crée du chômage
et de l'exclusion qui détruit la planète
qui fait pression sur la puissance
publique pour la pauvrir organise la
concurrence et la justice fiscale plutôt
qu'un monde de régression sociale et de
désolation environnementale allons vers
plus de communs et de solidarité et
construisons un autre héritage où le
travail aurait plus de sens serait moins
pénible et remis à sa juste place
c'est pour inventer cet autre monde et
défendre leur retraite que les Français
ont participé en masse à six
manifestations historiques que 90% des
actifs sont opposés à la retraite à 64
ans et votre seule réponse c'est le
mépris mépris envers l'opposition
sénatoriale et surtout le mépris du
président de la République envers les
syndicats qu'il refuse de recevoir
mépris envers les salariés et les
Français votre projet n'est pas légitime
retirez-le demande tous ceux qui
travaillent à l'hôpital et qui
travaillent pour nous merci merci
le 41 59 monsieur le Président Laurent
oui merci monsieur le Président nous
proposons de supprimer cet article pour
vous redire une fois de plus que nous ne
pouvons accepter la limitation des des
dépenses qu'il contient et surtout que
d'autres solutions étaient possibles
monsieur le ministre vous avez
de manière assez
irrespectueuse utilisée dans le débat
national le nom de notre ami Yolanda
Dias la ministre du Travail espagnol
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que il y a
eu une négociation sous pression de la
Commission européenne avec le
gouvernement espagnol sur le calcul de
du mode des pensions des retraites or il
se trouve que le gouvernement espagnol a
lui décider de mettre davantage à
contribution les revenus les plus élevés
le mécanisme finalement retenu a prévu
d'accroître l'assiette de cotisations
c'est à dire la part du salaire sur
laquelle les employés cotisent pour
dégager des recettes supplémentaires et
il a entériné un doublement d'ici 2029
du taux de contribution
au mécanisme d'équité
intergénérationnels qui alimente le fond
de réserve tout cela fait partie de
propositions que nous avons faites
pendant le débat mais qu'évidemment vous
avez toutes écarté et je crois que les
Français ne sont pas dupes des arguments
que vous avez tentés d'employer pour
justifier votre réforme c'est exactement
pour ça que nous en sommes aujourd'hui à
la 6e manifestation historique c'est
pour cela que 90% des actifs reste
opposés à la retraite à 64 ans c'est
pour cela qu'ils ne comprennent pas que
votre seule réponse soit le mépris
mépris envers l'opposition sénatoriale
mépris du président de la République
envers les syndicats qu'il refuse de
recevoir mes prix envers les Français
les salariés qui manifestent aujourd'hui
votre projet n'avait pas de légitimité
en entrant dans cette hémicycle il en
aura encore moins on en sortant après
l'utilisation du 49-3 sénatorial vous
n'avez qu'une seule solution monsieur le
ministre retirez votre propre projet
merci monsieur le président Laurent je
vais donner s'il le permet s'il le
permet de se faire après juste la vie de
la Commission du gouvernement et je vous
donne tout de suite la parole pour un
rappel le règlement avis de la
commission avis de la commission sur ses
amendements madame la rapporteur général
pardon monsieur le Président oui nous
sommes là sur l'objectif national des
dépenses d'assurance maladie et avec ma
collègue Corinne Imbert qui est en
charge de cette branche au moment du
PLFSS nous avions eu quelques doutes
monsieur le ministre sur effectivement
le montant de dépenses qui était en tout
cas le vôtre et nous avions demandé à ce
qu'il soit recalibré c'est d'ailleurs ce
que j'ai demandé dans la discussion
générale c'est que vous puissiez nous
donner les éléments
de réflexion par rapport à cet objectif
national parce qu'il nous semblait pas
assez
calibré en quelque sorte pour l'ensemble
des dépenses qui avaient été
identifiés par notre collègue donc ça
c'est notre première question je voulais
aussi indiquer à ma collègue Laurence
Rossignol que évidemment on connaît la
constance et et comment la la comment
les questions qui sont posées à travers
vos comme en prise de parole et bien
elles sont tout à fait légitimes tout à
fait légitime et on en débat
suffisamment en commission des affaires
sociales pour ne pas être surpris on est
sur des questions budgétaires ici et
donc il est bien normal que vous ayez
aussi l'envie de connaître les réponses
donc monsieur Mehdi si vous pouvez nous
donner les éléments par rapport à ce
montant de long terme et puis merci à
Monsieur Kerrouche pour avoir appelé
le roi Ubu dans cette enceinte parce que
Alfred Jarry est né à Laval donc en
Mayenne et je dois dire que je suis
toujours sensible lorsque l'on nomme des
auteurs de mon département il se trouve
que
uburois et bien c'est l'absurde
c'est-à-dire que en quelque sorte cette
pièce montre qu'un personnage
est implique plutôt de passion que de
raison mais il me semble qu'il faut
avoir les deux pas seulement la passion
parce que si on est entrain îné dans la
passion et bien on oublie qu'il faut
raisonnablement se donner les moyens de
la passion et les comptes publics c'est
aussi la raison de mon engagement
politique et pour toute protection
sociale il faut mettre en face les
moyens financiers qui sont nécessaires
et se permettre de les réaliser dans la
durée et donc d'être raisonnable et de
permettre leur pérennité merci
le ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président la vidéo du
gouvernement est évidemment défavorable
pour deux raisons au moins le premier la
première raison c'est que nous sommes
sur un article obligatoire donc
supprimer cet article 15 m en cause la
validité intégrale du PLFSS et par
ailleurs je présenterai si l'autorisait
dans un instant un amendement pour
rehausser le niveau de lambda ma hauteur
très-150 millions d'euros 600 millions
d'euros au profit des établissements de
santé ce qui permettra de financer la
prolongation des mesures d'urgence sur
la rémunération du temps de travail de
nuit dans les établissements de santé
puisque cette surémération dépend de fin
le 31 mars 2023 et nous la financerons
le temps que le travail se poursuivre
sur la valorisation des suggestions à
l'hôpital et les permanence de soins et
cela permettra de financer hauteur de
150 millions d'euros le sous objectif
soigneville afin de tenir compte des
prévisions de dépenses supplémentaires
en 2023 et donc nous serons sur un nom
d'âme en croissance de 3,5% hors
dépenses de crise pour faire suite à des
annonces de revalorisation salariales
pour les personnels des établissements
de santé médico-sociaux ainsi des
compensations d'inflation est-ce qu'elle
a été vu de jeux par différents services
de la manière la plus juste qui soit je
voulais aussi préciser que cela vous est
présenté à cet instant puisque entre le
moment où les décisions étaient prises
et les annonces faites et les conditions
de saisine du Haut Conseil des finances
publiques les délais ne permettaient pas
il y a dans tous les arguments qui ont
été évoqués un argument qui a été évoqué
par Monsieur monsieur assril que je
cherche je crois qu'il y a des attentats
d'instants et sur lesquels je voulais
revenir puisqu'il concerne la part des
Français depuis défavorisés qui sont
malheureusement décédés à la retraite
voilà je la retraite et en fait c'est un
argument qui est souvent utilisé et qui
ne s'avère pas pertinent même si il
pointe un défi qui est de taille quand
on dit que les 5% de français les plus
pauvres que 25% des 5% de français les
plus pauvres sont décédés à l'âge de la
retraite souvent c'est présenté
aujourd'hui comme 62 ans la réalité est
plus dramatique que ça puisqu'en réalité
25% des Français les plus défavorisés
sont décédés à 60
et ce n'est pas la question d'âge qui
est importante c'est la question du
revenu je suis insolite m'a rappelé quel
était le niveau de revenus à partir
duquel on appartenait aux 5% des
Français les plus favorisés le niveau de
revenus à partir duquel ou en deçà
duquel Vito on appartient à 5 % de
Français les plus défavorisés c'est un
revenu en moyenne sur son existence qui
est égal ou inférieur à 500 euros par
mois et donc c'est un enjeu de très
grande précarité mais ça éloigne de
l'enjeu retraite parce que
malheureusement on parle là on évoque là
les Françaises et les Français qui
quasiment aucun moment de leur vie non
véritablement accès au travail en tout
cas jamais de manière durable et qui
vivent ou qui survivent avec des niveaux
de revenus qui sont égaux ou inférieurs
aux minima sociaux et malheureusement
pour eux la question de la retraite ne
se pose pas donc c'est un point que je
voulais apporter parce que souvent dans
les débats sur les retraites ce chiffre
de 25% des Français les plus favorisés
décédés à l'âge de retraite a été cité
en fait et c'est malheureux ça ne veut
pas dire qu'il n'y a rien à faire bien
soit bien dans son faux on ne parle de
gens on parle là de gens on évoque là
des personnes
qui sont malheureusement pas concernés
par ces âges de départ du fait leur très
grande précarité c'est Monsieur Ferro
merci monsieur le Président de me donner
la parole pour un rappel au règlement au
nom de l'ensemble des collègues de mon
groupe et fondé sur l'article 33 de
notre règlement tout à l'heure lorsque
notre collègue Rémi Cardon s'exprimer
dans le temps imparti déjà très court
l'un de nos collègues s'est permis de
dire je le cite il est jeune il dit des
conneries
est-ce vraiment un propos acceptable
dans notre hémicycle
est-ce la seule chose que nous aurions à
dire au plus jeune collègues de notre
assemblée
n'y a-t-il pas mieux à faire en
s'inscrivant soi-même sur article pour
donner son avis sur le projet de réforme
des retraites moi je souhaite que le
collègue qui a prononcé cette phrase
malheureuse s'excuse auprès de notre
collègue Rémy Cardon que sinon elle soit
inscrite au PV et je regrette aussi
monsieur le Président alors que le temps
de parole que nous avons est extrêmement
court que Rémi Cardon a été très
largement privé de ses 120 petites
secondes parce que vous n'avez pas dû
entendre ces propos mais ces propos et
le tumulte qui s'en est en suivi là
empêcher de bénéficier de son temps de
parole
allez
[Applaudissements]
j'imagine que c'est sur le même sur le
même sujet monsieur
le président
ce collègue c'est moi
et mes propos ont été déformés et sortis
de leur contexte
lorsque le collègue tout à l'heure c'est
exprimé
un moment il a dit vous êtes encore
vivant
et lorsque ça a réagi de ce côté-ci
notre collègue
madame la ministre Rossignol a dit mais
vous en prenez à lui parce qu'il est
jeune et moi j'ai dit mais c'est parce
qu'il est jeune qu'il dit des conneries
comme ça
alors mes chers collègues
mais mes chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
nous avons
nous avons tous nous avons tous été
jeunes moi je suis prêt à retirer mes
propos si notre collègue s'engage à ne
plus à ne plus dire des autistes de
cette sorte
[Applaudissements]
mais chers collègues je mes chers
collègues allez je vous rappelle qu'en
application de l'article 36 alinéa 10 du
règlement les interpellations de
collègues et collègues sont interdites
et il y en a eu beaucoup depuis quelques
jours je vous invite je vous invite à
respecter les interventions de chacun
des auteurs et je vous rappelle que
normalement je dis normalement on l'a
laissé faire les rappels au règlement
portant sur des mises en cause
personnelle se font à l'issue de la
séance mais là autant purger tout de
suite
merci
l'amendement 47 24 du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre si vous voulez bien
être avec nous
oui monsieur le Président
je l'ai présenté en me posant aux
amendements de suppression donc il est
défendu
avis de la commission madame la
rapporteur avis favorable merci
je passe à la encore un amendement le
299 qui le présente oui je vous en prie
merci monsieur le Président donc c'est
un article additionnel un amendement sur
l'article additionnel en vue d'assurer
un financement réaliste et adapté à la
situation des Outre-mer cet amendement
présenté par ma collègue victoire jasmin
propose de préciser les critères sur
lesquels reposent les coefficients
géographiques
[Musique]
alerte le gouvernement sur l'urgence de
recevoir le financement de ces
établissements et notamment par la
revalorisation des coefficients des
coefficients géographiques car dans tous
les départements d'outre-mer les
hôpitaux font face à des surcos liés à
l'insularité aux dépenses de personnel
offrait d'approche de transport et taxes
aux évacuations sanitaires mais
également
ce lier à la mise aux normes des
bâtiments en matière sismique et
cyclonique les coefficients
géographiques appliqués dans les
outre-mer par la Sécurité sociale au
tarif nationaux au forfait annuel et à
la notation complémentaire des
établissements de santé bien que
majorées par rapport à l'exemple ne
compensent pas les charges pesant sur
les hôpitaux merci merci avis de la
commission
à la fin des débats si le gouvernement
avait respecté le Parlement la
séparation du pouvoir les droits de
l'opposition il nous resterait pas 350
amendements aujourd'hui et je pense
qu'on serait loin d'avoir terminé
l'examen du texte qui par ailleurs et
censé pouvoir ne pouvoir être étudié que
jusqu'à demain soir parce que le
gouvernement a choisi d'utiliser
l'article de la Constitution 47-1
les temps de discussion sur les projets
sportifs de la sécurité sociale donc
même le choix de cette de cette voilà de
cette cette procédure permet d'utiliser
le 47 1 vous dites légitime et légitime
parce que vous faites une distinction
avec ce qui est légal et ce qui est
légitime si je comprends bien il a
utilisé les les armes du règlement du du
Sénat la Constitution pour vous c'est
illégitime parce que non alors d'abord
tout texte et la Constitution en
particulier on apprécie toujours la
lettre et l'esprit
un certain nombre de choses qui nous
permettent de dire que l'esprit de la
Constitution a pas été respecté et
parfois même la lettre notamment
l'utilisation de l'article 47 1 qui
restreint les débats autorise
l'utilisation du 49-3 à l'Assemblée et
autorise de pouvoir recourir aux
ordonnances est un article qui n'est pas
l'article qu'on devrait normalement
utiliser pour une réforme des retraites
donc l'utilisation que le gouvernement
fait de la Constitution est ici et bien
perverti parce que ce n'est pas l'esprit
de la Constitution d'avoir cet article
pour une réforme des retraites pas du
tout c'est pas pour ça qu'elle fait
l'article 47 1 ensuite quand j'ai dit il
est victime c'est parce que je pense que
oui il y a une différence entre ce qui
se fait ici par la majorité par
l'opposition qui est d'utiliser les
articles du règlement que nous avons à
notre disposition les leurs les nôtres
de bonne foi et certes avec des
objectifs différents ils veulent faire
adopter cette réforme absolument nous
voulons que cette réforme soit rejetée
est retirée
mais ce qui s'est passé dans la nuit du
7 au 8 pour moi va bien au-delà puisque
je considère que c'était une violation
du règlement puisque
c'est des éléments qu'on a vécu
effectivement sur la droite déclarée des
milliers d'amendements
alors qu'elle ne les avait même pas
regardé après le texte en commun
une limite c'est plus simplement utilisé
de mauvaise foi de règlement c'est le
violet que dire de ce contexte aussi de
cette mobilisation de l'intersyndicale
et qu'est-ce que ça va donner comme
image le Parlement qui vote une loi
lorsque lorsqu'il y a des centaines de
milliers de personnes et des centaines
de cortège en France contre la réforme
ah mais c'est terrible c'est un à la
fois il y a des millions de personnes
qui ont qui ont manifesté six fois il y
a un taux de rejet de la réforme qui est
massif à travers toutes les professions
tous les âges toutes les catégories
socio-professionnelles et on a un
président qui refuse de rencontrer les
syndicats en disant il faut laisser le
temps au Parlement alors qu'il a
lui-même utilisé toutes les possibilités
pour contraindre le Parlement et ça va
au delà je crois de l'injustice de la
brutalité sociale de la réforme on a un
problème vraiment démocratique de
manière dont le président réagit à la
société gouverner un pays ça peut pas se
faire contre le pays oui comment est-ce
que vous comprenez le fait que ils
disent que l'Élysée fait savoir au
syndicat que la porte de l'exécutif est
toujours ouverte et qu'il refuse de les
voilà c'est qu'il veut renvoyer vers sa
ministre et son ministre du Travail
peut-être aussi c'est il veut laisser
les ministres de premier plan sur la
réforme à la manœuvre enfin on a bien vu
que moi je comprends que l'Inter
syndicale est dit à un moment donné nous
en fait on veut voir le président de la
République parce qu'ils ont bien compris
que à la fois le Parlement ne servait à
rien parce que le gouvernement décidait
de le museler et que les ministres
n'étaient qu'au sort du président de la
République ce que je regrette dans la
Cinquième République c'est comme ça donc
évidemment que les syndicats au bout
d'un moment disent bon ben écoutez le
Parlement ne peut pas nous écouter
structurellement parce qu'on a une
droite sénatoriale qui se met au service
du gouvernement plutôt que de respecter
le rôle de sa propre assemblée les
ministres ne peuvent pas nous écouter
parce que de toute façon isobéissent au
présent de la République donc au bout
d'un moment donné ben nous on veut
parler avec le président de la
République ce qu'il refuse mais l'année
prochaine j'ai une dernière question on
va assister sans doute dans les
prochaines heures au vote de la réforme
par la droite et le centre je crois pas
me tromper en disant que c'est ce qui va
se passer à la fin de d'ici la fin du
week-end qu'est-ce qui va se passer
ensuite en CMP en commission mix
paritaire qui va chercher un accord
entre les deux chambres la droite et la
macronie sont majoritaire donc ils vont
peut-être aussi réussir à s'entendre en
commission mixparitaire qui aura lieu
mercredi est-ce que finalement on n'est
pas en train de se rendre compte que la
gauche a perdu totalement cette guerre
et pas seulement une bataille avec le
Sénat non mais la réalité politique du
pays aujourd'hui c'est que la bataille
que nous avons menée ici au Sénat à la
gauche et les écologistes et à
l'Assemblée elle est du côté de la
majorité de la population française donc
oui c'est possible possible que en CMP
il y a un accord mais ce sera un accord
qui arrivera après le fait que
l'Assemblée nationale n'aura pas voté le
texte que le scénar aura voté dans des
conditions de débat absolument dégradés
et donc la légitimité de ce vote quel
qu'il soit sera profondément affecté et
vous joindre pardon à vos collègues
socialistes qui vont peut-être avoir un
recours déposé un recours au Conseil
constitutionnel pour s'opposer pour dire
qu'il y a eu une insensiorité des débats
vous allez joindre votre signature à cet
appel vous nous l'annoncez oui vous et
de nombreux collègues écologistes
au soir le ce qui s'est passé va bien
au-delà de simplement ce qui ce qui est
acceptable dans un parlement d'utiliser
chacun nos outils etc ça va bien au-delà
ça a été une violation un abus de
pouvoir de la part de la droite
territorielle et aussi un refus au fond
du Sénat d'exister comme comme une
chambre indépendante et bien merci merci
pour cette réaction à notre micro
Mélanie Vogel nous on va retourner en
séance et on fera un point dans quelques
minutes avec notre journée se
parlementaire sur ce qui se financement
dans l'hémicycle merci se fond d'usure
professionnelle par ailleurs extrêmement
contestable on a les ponctionner 200
millions d'euros sur la branche à TMP
c'est à dire qu'on est à la fois perdant
sur la question de la pénibilité pour le
calcul des retraites et en plus
on fonctionne la broche à TMP qui aurait
besoin de beaucoup d'argent beaucoup
plus d'argent pour faire de la
prévention des maladies professionnelles
donc on est perdant sur tous les
tableaux on est perdant sur la
prévention primaire des accidents du
travail on est perdant sur leur
reconnaissance et par ailleurs à travers
ce fond d'usure professionnelle on
installe la perte pour le calcul des
montants de retraite sur les critères de
pénibilité donc on est perdant sur toute
la ligne donc ce qui nous était présenté
au début comme des grandes avancées on
découvre plus on discute de la loi plus
on s'explique plus on a le temps de
parler plus les gens découvrent que tout
ça c'est du Flon et qu'en vérité il n'y
aura que des perdants dans cette réforme
merci
je passe maintenant à 52 amendements
identiques commencés par celui de
Monsieur Ferro le 304
merci monsieur le Président après les
excellents arguments de nos trois
collections l'article 16 je suis le
premier à présenter un amendement de
suppression de cet article qui
n'enlèverait rien à personne puisque
l'objectif de dépenses de la branche
accident du travail maladie
professionnelle reste stable et même en
légère diminution je crois dans ce
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale et Pierre Laurent vient
d'exprimer très bien comment cette loi
retraite est une supercherie en matière
d'avancer social plus le temps passe
plus on voit que les avancées sociales
sont en fait des reculs est-ce que vous
appelez des avancées ça correspond au
fait que c'est moins mal que si c'était
pire et
cela
je le dis sans vouloir plaisanter sur ce
sujet alors que nous sommes un pays où
les accidents du travail reste
extrêmement nombreux ou le recul de
l'âge de la retraite aura des
conséquences importantes en matière de
maladies professionnelles je pense que
même si nous approchons de la fin de
notre débat même si vous avez voulu et
nous le répéterons sans cesse des
vitaliser la fonction parlementaire par
des procédures de débats expéditive et
bien non nous ne désespérons pas que le
gouvernement renonce à sa réforme et
surtout que des collègues y compris de
la majorité sénatoriale renonce à voter
pour une telle réforme
merci le 390 madame Ferrer
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre amendement donc proposé pour
supprimer cet article dans cette dans
cette réforme dans votre réforme vous ne
pas parler plus de pénibilité mais
d'usure professionnelle or c'est très
différent la pénibilité porte sur le
travail et sur ces conditions soit sur
une responsabilité collective l'usure
porte sur les corps des travailleurs
soit sur une responsabilité individuelle
nous n'avons pas les mêmes valeurs
vous ne renvoyez vous ne revenez pas non
plus sur les quatre critères de
pénibilité que vous avez supprimé en
2017 les critères de pénibilité qui sont
les postures pénibles les vibrations
mécaniques la manutention manuelle de
charge
l'exposition aux produits chimiques qui
sont le quotidien de très nombreux
salariés je veux à ce moment citer les
propos d'une aide à domicile qui après
avoir décrit la pénibilité liée au
nombre de risques physiques et
psychosociaux de son métier à affirmer
qu'un départ à la retraite à 64 ans
si cela devait se produire et
malheureusement
les nombreuses
manifestations les nombreuses comment on
va dire
défiler merci cortège que les Français
rejoignent chaque semaine on pourrait
dire et 90% des actifs opposés à leur
retraite à 64 ans
n'ont pas d'écho auprès de vous
peut-être que les propos de cette aide à
domicile vous feront réfléchir elle dit
une retraite à 64 ans le corps ne
pourrait pas suivre ça c'est la réalité
du quotidien pour cette femme comme pour
de très nombreuses salariés alors vous
exprimez on va dire par
sans réponse à mes prix un mépris pour
les français pour les salariés votre
projet est totalement illégitime nous
vous demandons de retirer votre réforme
merci Madame Van aigle 561
monsieur le Président oui le travail
peut t'abîmé et l'objectif de dépenses
de la branche ATMP et proposée par le
gouvernement s'avère totalement inadapté
aux besoins notamment avec le recul de
deux ans de l'âge de la retraite c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous demandons
la suppression de cet article dont nous
aurions aimé débattre et là votre
attitude à l'égard des oppositions de
cette hémicycle nous prive du travail
parlementaire qui est le nôtre vous ne
sortirez pas grandi après ce tour de
force d'ailleurs la rue gronde avec 6
manifestations historiques 90% des
actifs opposés à la retraite à 64 ans
vous répondez par le mépris les Français
s'en souviendront
merci le 63
le 660 monsieur chanterelle
merci monsieur le Président tout à
l'heure madame l'a rapporteur vous avez
parlé de la raison que ça serait la
raison qui guide votre politique ça
laisserait entendre aux françaises et
aux Français qu'une seule politique est
possible un peu à la Margaret Thatcher
comme quoi il n'y a pas d'autres
alternative que que votre effort et
votre politique ce qui est évidemment
complètement faux car ce que vous
défendez c'est un projet de société
c'est un projet de société assumé qui
est de protéger les plus privilégiés de
leur juste part à la solidarité
nationale il n'y a jamais qu'une seule
politique possible il y a toujours
plusieurs options ça s'appelle la
démocratie justement celle que vous
allez voulue bâillonner ici dans ce
Parlement puisque depuis le début
justement de ce texte nous avons fait
ici sur tous les bancs de la gauche des
propositions alternatives pour prouver
qu'une autre réforme était justement
possible
qui protège les plus privilégiés mais
justement qui permettent qu'il contribue
à leur juste niveau à la solidarité
nationale à notre système de protection
sociale au système de retraite sauf que
vous votre politique de le début ne fait
que le préserver vous avez diminué
l'impôt sur la fortune vous ne voulez
pas taxer les super profits vous ne
voulez pas qu'on puisse aussi taxer le
capital parce que le capital c'est
également renforcé au détriment des
salaires vous parlez en permanence des
travailleurs mais si vous mais vous
n'aimez pas les travailleurs parce que
si vous aimiez les travailleurs vous
feriez en sorte que leur salaire
augmente au détriment du capital parce
que ce qui augmente ces dernières années
c'est la valeur du capital ça n'est pas
le salaire des travailleurs si vous vous
souhaitez augmenter le salaire des
travailleurs augmenter déjà le revenu
minimum ça ça leur permettrait déjà de
pouvoir un peu mieux vivre comme fond
d'ailleurs certains pays en Europe qui
eux ont des politiques courageuses
d'augmentation des plus basses à l'heure
en tout cas nous vous demandons de
retirer à nouveau cette réforme
profondément injuste et brutale
le 690 madame la retour en salle des
conférences pour retrouver notre
journaliste Mathias sarez Mathias on a
vu une petite escarmouche en séance tout
à l'heure en Espagne absolument il y a
eu un petit peu de friture sur la ligne
au milieu de ces débats qui sont
globalement rondement menés il y a un
petit peu plus d'une demi-heure c'est le
socialiste Rémy Cardon Benjamin des
sénateurs vous allez voir pourquoi je le
précise qui alors qu'il défendait un
amendement de suppression de l'article
15 a été chahuté par ses camarades
la droite sanatoriale est quand même fan
de la valeur travail et qui prend en
compte bah oui non mais c'est quand même
vous êtes vous êtes quand même obsédé
par ça donc si vous voulez ça fait quand
même ça me fait quand même doucement
rigoler en réalité ah mais quand même
le cardon défendez votre amendement
ne tentez pas l'impossible allez bah
écoutez
c'est impressionnant que de
pardon enfin voilà je viens de me faire
traiter de apparemment
[Musique]
après alors après après
s'attaquer au justement aux personnes au
Seigneur vous vous attaquez aux jeunes
maintenant
c'est quand même dingue quoi
quelques dizaines de minutes plus tard à
l'issue de l'examen du bloc d'amendement
de suppression de l'article c'est son
collègue socialiste Rémi Féraud qui est
revenu sur cette incidence lors d'un
rappel aux règlements
n'y a-t-il pas mieux à faire en
s'inscrivant soi-même sur article pour
donner son avis sur le projet de réforme
des retraites moi je souhaite que le
collègue qui a prononcé cette phrase
malheureuse s'excuse auprès de notre
collègue Rémi Cardon mes propos ont été
déformés et sortis de leur contexte nous
avons tous été jeunes moi je suis prêt à
retirer mes propos si notre collègue
s'engage à ne plus à ne plus dire des
autistes de cette sorte
une intervention qui a nécessité que le
président de séance Roger karucci
rappelle au concernés que les
interpellations entre collègues bien que
nombreuses ces derniers jours étaient
interdites dans l'émission et bien merci
merci pour tous ces explications Mathias
et puisque vous êtes avec moi en direct
combien reste-t-il exactement
d'amendements à l'heure où l'on se parle
et bien au moment où l'on se parle
Quentin il reste
242 amendements à examiner très bien et
bien on va sur ça de près et on va voir
si les sénateurs vont jusqu'au vote
finale sur la réforme de retraite ce
soir ou demain c'est bien sûr à tout
l'enjeu des prochaines heures de débat
retournant l'hémicycle simplement de Ben
critique que nous que nous vous faisons
aujourd'hui mais un véritable appelle à
la réalité nous parlons d'environ mille
morts par an d'accidents du travail de
multiples de la multiplication des burn
out environ 2 millions 5 en France en
2022 ce n'est pas rien
alors que dans ce projet de loi vous
décalez l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite de deux ans que nombre de
salariés devront s'user encore plus
longtemps dans des conditions de travail
pénibles la prévention des accidents du
travail et des maladies professionnelles
doit prendre une nouvelle ampleur car
les risques vont progresser pourtant on
le sait la soude déclaration des
accidents du travail est un phénomène
massif la dernière commission de
sous-déclaration des ATMP réunies en
2021 chiffres ce coût annuel entre 1,2
et 2,1 milliard la moitié des accidents
du travail ne seraient pas reconnu et si
la commission 72% ne serait pas déclaré
et 26% des accidents avec arrêt ne le
sauraient pas donc les moyens
budgétaires révèlent l'ambition des
politiques publiques et je ne peux que
regretter que ces moyens budgétaires
soient très insuffisantes au regard de
l'enjeu
cette réforme des retraites aura des
conséquences sur les ATMP écouter les
Français retirer cette réforme injuste
merci le 800 madame de La Gontrie
sergent interroge camembert et la terre
du trou que vous êtes donc plus
arméiquement bouché qu'une bouteille de
limonade sapeur creuser un autre tout
c'est vrai approuve camembert la
simplicité du sapeur camembert que vous
avez reconnu est alors dépassé en sotise
par son supérieur le sergent bitur qui
le traite de double mulet corps du et
les reproches de ne pas avoir fait le
deuxième trou assez grand pour qu'on
puisse y mettre sa terre avec celle du
premier et bien c'est exactement ce que
le gouvernement est en train de faire
dans ce texte pourquoi nous allons
assister à partir de 2024 à un transfert
de cotisation au profit de la branche
vieillesse en provenance de la branche
ATMP hausse de 01 point des cotisations
vieillesse baisse des cotisations ATMP
et du coup les prévisions du PLFSS 2023
ne seront pas respectés puisqu'elles
vont diminuer et comme l'article 9
renchérit la nécessité de prise en
charge de nouvelles dépenses liées à la
prise en compte de la pénibilité et de
la prévention de l'usure professionnelle
voilà comment les dépenses de la branche
augmenteront plus rapidement que celle
prévue à PLFSS pour 2023 voilà pourquoi
le gouvernement se comporte ici comme le
sapeur camembert et voilà pourquoi nous
voulons la suppression de cet article
très bien
85 monsieur dur hein merci monsieur le
Président moi je n'ai pas vous parler de
trou mais de Vasse communicants si nous
voulons rejeter la confirmation de
l'objectif de dépenses de la branche
ATMP tel que proposer par le
gouvernement c'est que tout est lié dans
cette réforme parce qu'on voit bien que
ce qui vont être impactés par le report
de l'âge légal seront d'abord malade et
puis ensuite ils verseront dans la
branche ATMP alors du coup je m'en
voudrais de ne pas terminer ce débat
sans avoir cité quelques exemples très
concrets qui nous ont été envoyés par
des personnes de nos circonscriptions
Jean-Luc la question que je pose
personnellement comment arriver à l'âge
légal de la retraite même à 62 ans avec
des maladies professionnelles des je
crois que le dossier de pénibilité n'a
pas été assez valorisé voire inexistant
ou passer à l'AS dans les entreprises
dépourvus de déléguer du personnel ou
pour X raisons et les 1200 euros que le
gouvernement fait miroiter ne concernera
qu'une infime petite minorité de gens et
tous ceux qui travaillent dur font
souvent l'objet d'arrêt de travail
surtout les quinquagénaires Josette j'ai
commencé à 14 ans deux mois et la
retraite était à 65 ans après 44 ans et
demi de travail à mi-temps pour mes
enfants à 75 ans je perçois 647 euros
par mois plus de 120 euros de retraite
complémentaire c'est pas beau ça plein
d'arthrose je ne peux pas voir d'aide
trop en forme et puis cette dame qui n'a
pas signé je suis le débat pour la
réforme des retraites je suis perdu à
rien y comprendre je suis né en 66 j'ai
commencé à travailler de 82 à 84 mais
pas cotisé pour la retraite j'ai une
période de chômage et repris une
activité turque je suis aide-soignant
dans un EHPAD de nuit fonction publique
mais nous n'avons pas de compte
pénibilité j'ai 57 ans opéré du dos à 40
ans j'ai des problèmes de lombaires
discusé arthrose je continue de
travailler simplement malgré mes
douleurs récurrentes les
aides-soignantes ont notre travail dur
posture charges et puis le dernier vaste
communicant qui vous intéressera
peut-être c'est celui-là je ne vote pas
pour votre partie mais je tenais tout de
même à vous remercier d'avoir voté
contre le report de l'âge de la retraite
à 64 ans au vu des votes des sénateurs
de droite s'en est fini pour moi de
votre obstacle au RN je me rallis donc
désormais à ces gens qui n'en peuvent
plus merci infiniment d'avoir voté quand
même contre cet article 7 merci
le 965 monsieur Cardon
je vous promets je dis pas de conneries
monsieur le Président merci c'est un
moment destinateur socialiste écologiste
et républicain visa rejeter la
confirmation de l'objectif de dépenses
de la branche ATMP tel que proposé par
le gouvernement dans cet article alors
alors que des accidents au travail font
1000 morts par an que la santé mentale
des travailleurs se dégradent et que la
pénibilité demande des vraies moyens le
gouvernement souhaite maintenir ici un
budget pour ses accidents du travail et
les maladies professionnelles stables
par rapport à 2022 sans aucune ambition
nouvelle alors on est dans un PLFSS
rectificatif malheureusement alors qu'on
aurait pu
prévoir au vu du rallongement de l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite ce qui est
deux facto va augmenter les risques
d'accident du travail et les maladies
professionnelles ce qui montre également
une nouvelle fois que vous ne vous
préoccupez pas des travailleurs mais
uniquement des cadeaux fiscaux que vous
voulez couvrir avec cette réforme merci
c'est Madame Lubin pour le 1163
merci monsieur le Président
sur ce volet de la branche ATMP moi je
voudrais insister sur le fait que une
fois de plus on ne demande pas d'efforts
aux entreprises
puisque
le petit effort qu'on leur demande de se
récompenser par ailleurs
et c'est quand même un problème parce
que je me souviens lorsque nous avions
travaillé avec le rapporteur prenez pas
le Savary sur l'emploi des seniors nous
avions auditionné notamment le Medef et
je me souviens bien de la réaction du
représentant du Medef lorsque nous lui
avions demandé ce qu'il prévoyait pour
améliorer la situation au regard de
l'emploi des seniors et il nous avait
dit à l'époque il avait reconnu que
dans ma foi il n'y avait pas beaucoup
travaillé au MEDEF
et j'ai l'impression quatre ans après
que les choses ne se sont guère
améliorées leur des auditions organisées
par la commission sur ce projet de loi
de retraite nous avons entendu les
représentants du Medef dire que ils
étaient prêts à faire quelques efforts
pas beaucoup à la condition qu'on les
soulage de certaines de certaines
cotisations sociales en clair
pour que le Medef constante à demander à
ses entreprises faire de faire des
efforts pour recruter des personnes de
plus de 50 ans moi je le dis comme ça ou
pour les garder un emploi et bien il
faut qu'on penser il faut faire des
efforts il faut leur faire des des
cadeaux au niveau des cotisations de
leur cotisations sociales moi je me pose
une question
est-ce que le premier rôle d'une
entreprise n'est pas celui est-ce que
est-ce que l'entreprise n'a pas une
vocation d'organisation sociale aussi
quelque part de la société
est-ce que ce n'est pas le rôle d'une
entreprise que de se poser la question
quant à l'emploi des Français des Jeunes
comme des vieux merci
le 1297 monsieur Montauger
je suis mélangé les papiers merci
monsieur le Président chers collègues
dans la partie de notre débat consacré
aux accidents du travail à la prise en
compte des travailleurs cassés
usés par une longue et dure de labeur
souvent commencé jeune nous avons dit
combien la prévention était l'angle mort
de votre vision du travail au 21e siècle
et combien nous étions opposés à votre
prise en compte de la pénibilité dans
les droits à la retraite
l'ambition la vraie aurait été que vous
donniez une place centrale à la
prévention en rapport direct avec les
critères de pénibilité élargie à des
situations d'affection sanitaire que
vous ne voulez pas voir et prendre en
compte le concept de one Elf traduction
française santé globale comme l'a dit
évoquait Emilienne pour Mirol dans une
de ces interventions doit être
méthodiquement dans le dialogue avec les
syndicats les travailleurs et les
institutions de santé déployées dans
notre système de soins et de prise en
charge votre objectif de dépenses de la
branche accident du travail maladie
professionnelle d'intègre rien de ces
nécessités de ces urgences et c'est pour
soi et c'est pourquoi nous rejetons par
cette amendement 1297 l'article 16
merci
je tire rouge le 1458
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
cet amendement de
suppression parce que
les sommes qui sont inscrites ne
correspond aux enjeux de la branche ATMP
pas plus que les sommes pour l'article
précédent ne correspondait aux besoins
pour l'ONDAM pas plus que les 100
millions pour l'article précédent ne
correspondait aux besoins qui étaient
nécessaires
on a avec ce gouvernement un retour
particulier dans le dans le temps
vous savez que la légende urbaine veut
quand on a demandé à Bismarck l'âge
auquel il fallait fixer la retraite pour
n'avoir jamais à la verser
et bien en 1883 la Prusse a fixé l'âge
de la retraite à 70 ans sachant que bien
peu l'athénier au début du 20e siècle
vous connaissez cette phrase également
non à la retraite pour les morts c'était
le cri de la CGT devant la loi retraite
ouvrière et paysanne l'âge de départ à
la retraite était de 65 ans et
l'espérance de vie à l'époque des
Français étaient de 45 ans alors avec ce
gouvernement alors qu'il nous était
promis Retour vers le Futur encore que
Emmanuel Macron ressemble assez peu à
Marty McFly on a surtout un retour vers
le passé et les Français le comprennent
très bien retour vers le passé parce que
c'est un retour vers la régression
sociale c'est un décalage de deux ans de
l'âge de la retraite dans le mauvais
sens et Madame la rapporteur certes on
peut faire appel à la raison on peut
comprendre encore faut-il que cet appel
à la raison ne se fasse pas au détriment
de la justice sociale et c'est
exactement l'histoire de cette réforme
alors permettez-moi pour finir de
détourner un proverbe irlandais une
bonne retraite et meilleure qu'une
mauvaise résistance et bien nous nous
croyons qu'une mauvaise retraite vaut
bien une bonne résistance merci
le 1489 madame colon et Mouret
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre alors mon propos va s'inscrire
directement dans la citation irlandaise
le recul de l'âge de la retraite de 65 à
60 ans en 1983
revendications portées par l'union de la
gauche depuis les années 70 était la
réponse politique
juridique et ouvrière à la pénibilité du
travail alors cette réforme emblématique
la France se distinguait par rapport à
ses voisins européens et le sujet de la
pénibilité était désormais traités dans
notre pays alors certes depuis beaucoup
de progrès ont été réalisés en matière
de sécurité au travail le nombre de
morts dû aux accidents de travail
demeure trop élevée en France par
rapport à nos voisins ce qui démontre
que nous avons encore des progrès à
réaliser
il en est de même pour la pénibilité et
la souffrance au travail que nous
amendements posés de rectifier si nous
avions pu en débattre et que nous vous
ayons convaincu de les adopter ce dont
nous ne doutons pas beaucoup n'ont pas
la chance de travailler dans une
entreprise
ou en rivalise ou rivalisent les
ressorts de la qualité de vie au travail
qui reste totalement étrangers à des
parents entiers de notre économie et de
nos salariés ce terrain doit continuer à
être investi nous nous y étions préparés
vous nous en aviez privés puisque nous
savons que tout ce que nous proposons
est rejeté alors nous demandons la
suppression de cet article parce que les
travailleuses et les travailleurs en
France méritent beaucoup mieux que ce
que vous proposez
merci Monsieur Stanzione le 1532
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chez le crucher collègue
je vais vous parler là aussi de
les actions de travail professionnels
qui est pas abordé c'est le surcoût pour
la tmmp qui n'est pas prêt en compte
pour les affections psychiques en lien
avec le travail qui touche en premier
lieu les cadres le rapport de 2021 tente
pour la première fois d'estimer la
sous-déclaration des pathologies
psychiques liées au travail sans
toutefois intégrer le coût de celle-ci
au montant total de la sous-déclaration
de maladie professionnelle ou accident
de travail le report de l'âge de la
retraite de 62 à 64 ans va
obligatoirement augmenter les risques de
maladies professionnelles d'accidents de
travail les accidents de travail font
780 morts par an la santé mentale des
travailleurs se dégradent et la
pénibilité toujours bien présent malgré
la suppression des régimes spéciaux
pourtant le gouvernement maintient ici
un budget pour les accidents de travail
maladie professionnelle stable par
rapport à 2022 cela provient le manque
d'ambition du gouvernement dans ce
domaine nous nous y opposons tel est
l'objet de notre amendement et je
voudrais rappeler à mes chers collègues
qu'effectivement
il se passe des manifestations
historiques mais elles sont plus
historiques puisque elles se déroule en
ce moment et énormément de Français
refusent cette réforme et en fait ce qui
ce qui est la réponse c'est un espèce de
mépris de la part du gouvernement et
puis et puis de nos amis sénateurs et
j'en vois qui rigolent au milieu là et
c'est pas bien du tout donc votre projet
n'est pas légitime
et bien retirez-le et je finis avant
l'heure
pour les trois secondes que vous nous
offrez allez le 1562 madame meunier
merci monsieur le Président donc c'est
un amendement qui vise à rejeter la
confirmation l'objectif de dépenses la
page accident du travail et maladie
professionnelle telle qu'elle a été
proposée par le gouvernement dans cet
article cet objet intègre les effets en
2023 du présent projet de loi s'agissant
de financement du fond de prévention de
l'usure professionnelle notamment nous
avons déjà eu l'occasion à plusieurs
reprises soulignées lors des débats les
carences de ce fond sur la forme d'abord
il y a une glissement sémantique opéré
par l'intitulé on ne parle plus de
pénibilité mais de prévention de l'usure
et ça souligne une volonté idéologique
de minorer la pénibilité réelle que peut
représenter le travail et puis sur son
contenu se font financera uniquement les
actions des employeurs et ne sera pas
doté de ressources à la hauteur
c'est donc loin d'être une réponse au
niveau des enjeux liés à la prise en
compte de la pénibilité que fallait-il
donc faire mais réinstaurer les quatre
crinet terres de pénibilité supprimées
en 2017 qui cause 90% des maladies
professionnelles rappelons que les
seniors sont déjà aujourd'hui tout
particulièrement exposés aux accidents
de travail 58% des morts par accident de
travail en plus de 50 ans les seigneurs
ont pas ailleurs des arrêts maladie plus
longs en moyenne de 75 jours pour les
plus de 60 ans contre 18 jours pour les
moins de 18 ans c'est un phénomène qui
sera mécaniquement amené à augmenter
avec le recul de l'âge il est donc
évident que la branche accident du
travail maladie professionnelle
mériterait davantage de volontarisme de
la part du gouvernement dans le contexte
actuel de pénurie de médecins du travail
la médecine du travail a ainsi perdu
1126 professionnels entre 2010 et 2022
selon l'ordre des médecins et de
recrudescence des risques psychosociaux
encore un thème qui ne va pas du tout
retirez votre réforme merci Madame
Poumirol le 1644
elle est sortie
alors alors
madame meunier le 1771 merci monsieur le
président
le sénateur notre collègue Olivier
Hainaut nous parler d'épanouissement au
travail en exhumant une citation du 19e
siècle que je reprends le travail pense
l'appareil ronge la vie fleurie par le
travail alors le travail épanouit-il oui
mais pas uniquement il éprouve les
organismes il éprouve les corps il
éprouve la santé mentale cela a été dit
et redit et exhumé des citations pour de
ce type pour illustrer les conséquences
du travail est assez révélateur de cette
façon de penser
l'épanouissement par le travail était à
l'heure à l'époque et il est encore un
leurre est-ce
finalement le seul horizon que vous
offrez aux hommes et aux femmes de notre
pays travailler plus et plus longtemps
car aujourd'hui en 2023 le travail
continue d'user les organismes un seul
exemple dans le secteur des personnes
âgées retourner une personne alitée pour
faire une toilette à domicile ou en
EHPAD c'est fatigant au quotidien c'est
pénible et non reconnu et c'est parfois
handicapant la longue est très rarement
indemnisée cela conduit à des arrêts de
travail à des carrières hachées et à des
pensions minimes quand je vais et quand
j'étais dans les manifestations depuis
deux mois maintenant il y a une pancarte
qui m'a toujours fait tristement sourire
c'est la retraite avant l'arthrite
merci monsieur le Président canner le
oui merci Monsieur prudent mes chers
collègues après Fort Alamo Texas je
pourrais vous parler d'un village
d'Armorique bien connu de qu'on peut
appeler de direductible Gaulois mais
malheureusement je n'ai pas de potion
magique
parlementaire qui me permette finalement
d'empêcher l'adoption cette loi si j'ai
bien compris néanmoins on va essayer
quand même de supprimer l'article 16 au
travers de cet amendement 1841 la
branche accident du travail et maladie
professionnelle regroupe la prévention à
la réduction des risques professionnels
la reconnaissance des sinistres
l'indemnisation des victimes etc donc
c'est une branche très importante et
vraiment l'équilibre financier monsieur
le ministre que vous avez confirmé
zéro 12% de cotisations patronale en
plus pour la CNAV mais 0,12% de
cotisations en moins dans le cadre de
cette section
de la sécurité sociale et totalement
dommageable je veux vraiment je le
regrette on aurait pu d'ailleurs
imaginer et d'ailleurs vous l'avez
proposé que des financements sur les
cotisations soient imaginé vous avez
vraiment été dogmatique sur voilà les 12
13 14 milliards il faut les trouver en
faisant travailler les Français 2 ans de
plus c'est vraiment une une mauvaise
manœuvre pour des millions de Français
qui vont être amenés ainsi à partir de
septembre si votre loi devait prospérer
et bien on devoir commencer à réfléchir
à travailler deux ans de plus dans leur
vie nous souhaitons donc la suppression
de l'article 16 qui fixe ses objectifs
que nous considérons comme injuste voilà
donc la réalité des faits et après ces
nombreuses manifestations et bien nous
conseillerons encore que c'est le mépris
qui agite votre politique en matière
sociale vis-à-vis notamment du monde
syndical je vous remercie merci le 1929
monsieur Joly
voilà on le voit on est en train
d'accélérer le rythme dans l'hémicycle
Mathias vous êtes toujours avec nous
depuis la tribune de presse
contrairement à ce qu'espérais la gauche
sénatoriale on pourrait arriver à un
vote finale sur l'ensemble de la réforme
des retraites plus vite que prévu
n'est-ce pas oui Quentin avec plus de
3700 amendements à examiner avant le
début de ce texte sur le papier en jour
et bien la probabilité de voir le texte
allait jusqu'au bout était tout
simplement impossible mais Quentin on le
savait la droite sénatoriale avait mis
un point d'honneur à ce que le texte
soit voté ici alors petit retour en
arrière si vous me le permettez sur les
moyens mis en place pour accélérer les
débats lors de l'examen de l'article 7
Bruno Retailleau dégaine l'article 38 du
Règlement intérieur du Sénat c'est une
première un article qui clôt les débats
mais également un article qui a depuis
été largement réutilisé ce même jour
dans la nuit c'est la commission des
affaires sociales qui réécrit ce même
article 7 pour faire tomber plus de 1100
amendements alors dans la même veine il
y a eu l'article 42 alinéa 16 du
Règlement du Sénat qui a été votée en
conférence des présidents le lendemain
pour limiter les orateurs avant de
passer au vote dernier coup
d'accélérateur Quentin le retrait de
l'amendement Retailleau sur la clause du
grand-père qui dans sa chute entraîne
200 sous amendements de la gauche un
retrait lui-même contraint par
l'activation de l'article 44 3 de la
Constitution voilà exactement c'est
l'article 44 3 et qui venait du
gouvernement Mathias le gouvernement qui
a mis la main à la pâte on peut le dire
aussi pour accélérer ses débats oui un
gouvernement qui a aussi dû avoir
recours à une mesure impopulaire
l'article 44,3 de la Constitution aussi
connue aussi connue pardon sous le nom
de votre bloqué c'est un autre gain de
temps énorme ici car si les amendements
sont eux bien toujours défendus il n'y a
plus d'explication de vote quand il n'y
a plus de scrutin public tout ça qui
était bien chronophage et pas ricochet
comme on l'a vu avec l'amendement
Retailleau que je vous citais ça a
découragé certains de défendre les
amendements qui n'étaient pas retenus
par le gouvernement dans le cadre du
vote final merci Mathias pour toutes ces
explications et effectivement le nombre
d'amendements qui se réduit comme peau
de chagrin nous sommes autour de 210
amendements on reviendra vers vous
Mathias très rapidement nos estimations
que Public Sénat est en train d'essayer
de faire le plus précisément possible
mais nos estimations d'un entre 5 à 10
heures encore de débat autour de la
réforme des retraites
des salariés des services à la personne
sont des femmes un quart d'entre elles
ont plus de 55 ans donc tout le monde
aura compris que leur niveau
d'exposition au risque est plus élevé
beaucoup d'entre elles bien entendu ont
des carrières trouées et des très
faibles niveaux de ressources qui
contribue contribuera ensuite à des
faibles niveau de pension alors déjà
pour commencer pour ces femmes là de
passage de présente 2 à 64 ans est déjà
une catastrophe sanitaire mais quand
j'évoquais il y a un instant une hausse
continue d'action du travail chez les
dans les métiers de service à la
personne je vais vous donner quelques
éléments que je trouve pour ma part un
peu contre-intuitif je pense que si on
faisait un sondage tout le monde
penserait l'inverse il y a deux fois
plus d'accidents du travail dans les
services à la personne que dans le BTP
deux fois plus alors qu'on considère que
les métiers du BTP sont les plus exposés
et les arrêts de maladies chez des chez
les femmes des services à la personne
sont deux à trois fois plus longs que
les arrêts maladie chez les salariés du
BTP donc on a donc un sujet spécifique à
cet instant si on veut réellement
réorienter les politiques de prévention
ma tradition du travail alors le
ministre l'autre jour nous a parlé
beaucoup de prévention de prévention de
prendre ensemble j'ai envie de dire mais
en fait pourquoi c'est maintenant au
moment où on parle de l'allongement de
la retraite qu'on nous parle d'un fonds
de prévention des excédents de ce fonds
de prévention de l'INS uffisance des
politiques de prévention et je suis
perpète sur le fait que la réforme va
enclencher quelque chose de nouveau
merci madame poncemon je le 3198
monsieur Dantec oui merci monsieur le
Président je crois que beaucoup de
choses ont déjà été dites évidemment sur
l'aberration de de cette trajectoire
financière alors que le nombre
d'accidents du travail augmente que il y
a cette dégradation et très clairement
on sait que ce sont effectivement chez
les ouvriers et les travailleurs
modestes qu'on a cette augmentation et
que à partir du moment où mécaniquement
on va repousser l'âge de la retraite on
va augmenter le nombre d'accidents et le
nombre de morts au travail ça a été dit
avant c'est
c'est ma dernière intervention je pense
ce soir je voudrais
reprendre les propos de Laurence
Rossignol on a été quand même plusieurs
cité Albert Camus Camus ce soir je crois
effectivement ce mépris que nous avons
systématiquement soulignés dans toutes
nos interventions
est extrêmement grave
si on reprend un peu un peu de recul il
y a eu depuis que Emmanuel Macron a été
élu la première fois d'abord les gilets
jaunes déjà une révolte de notamment de
salariés modeste qu'il n'y arrivait plus
ce message n'a pas été entendu n'a pas
été suivi de changement de politique
ensuite nous avons eu la deuxième
élection présidentielle l'élection
présidentielle ou le score de l'extrême
droite dit à quel point ce pays a besoin
d'autres réponses que de manière
extrêmement je crois responsable nous
avons très majoritairement sur les bancs
de la gauche votez pour Emmanuel Macron
contre l'extrême droite en attendant une
réponse sociale à ce qui s'était exprimé
politiquement et là pour la troisième
fois
nous avons une mobilisation très forte
comme jamais dans ce pays contre une
réforme qui est profondément injuste et
une nouvelle fois vous ne l'entendez pas
vous jouez avec le feu c'est extrêmement
grave cette réforme n'est pas légitime
retirer là
merci le 4061 monsieur gay ouais merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président pas encore
j'ai déjà donné bref je pars faire 10
secondes monsieur le Président Monsieur
le ministreur
je veux répondre à l'argument que vous
avez déployé tout à l'heure sur les 25 %
des plus pauvres qui sont morts à l'âge
de 62 ans permet témoin de vous dire je
pense que vous faites une erreur vous
faites la même c'est un graphique de
libération qui a été beaucoup commenté
vous faites à mon avis la même erreur
que Patrick Cohen célèbre éditorialiste
qui a dit exactement la même chose que
vous finalement comme c'est des gens qui
ont des minima sociaux c'est pas des
travailleurs mais permettez-moi de vous
dire que nous nous connaissons que les
travailleurs il y a des travailleurs en
activité des travailleurs en formation
et des travailleurs privés d'emploi et
donc même si c'est des privés d'emploi
très longue durée ce n'est pas eux qui
ont choisi c'est le système capitaliste
qu'il est privé
et donc oui même pour celles et ceux qui
sont privés d'emploi la question de la
retraite elle aurait posé et sur les
accidents du travail plus de 600 000
chaque année les maladies
professionnelles plus de 45000 c'est les
chiffres 46000 c'est les chiffres de
2021 il y a une question monsieur le
ministre vous le savez un certain nombre
d'arguments ont été dit et donnés par
mes collègues je crois qu'il faut
travailler sur deux choses la question
évidemment la prévention on revient à ce
qu'on s'est dit hier médecine du travail
pas assez de moyens et il y a une autre
question c'est l'inspection du travail
voyez il y a aussi des accidents mortels
entre 600 et 800 par an il y en a un qui
a eu lieu cette semaine dans notre
département avec la présidente assassin
sur un chantier on a des gros chantiers
des JO P et du Grand Paris Express et
les syndicats exigent demandent avec
force beaucoup plus d'inspecteurs du
travail sur le terrain et évidemment et
je finis par vous dire que
allongé de deux ans la vie au travail
évidemment ça va produire et plus
accident du travail et plus de maladies
professionnelles je vous remercie
monsieur le Président merci
avis de la commission madame la
rapporteur général
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues nous se place
sur l'objectif de dépenses de la branche
atmpt du travail maladie professionnelle
et donc si vous l'avez bien regardé
la dépense qui est prévue et la même que
celle que nous avons votée au dernier
PLFSS donc nous pourrions nous
interroger pourquoi finalement apparaît
cette branche aujourd'hui et pour autant
on a dans les mesures qui ont été
présentées au cours de ces derniers
jours des éléments qui nous laissent à
penser qu'il y aura effectivement des
dépenses supplémentaires dans le budget
de la TMP et pourquoi c'est lorsque l'on
regarde l'annexe avec cette trajectoire
de dépenses que l'on voit effectivement
cette dépense mais pour l'année 2023 en
fait avec les arrondis et bien ça ne se
voit pas il n'y a que 52 et c'est
pourtant déjà ça millions d'euros de
plus et pourquoi d'une part parce que
nous avons l'article 9 un certain nombre
de mesures qui ont été annoncés sinon ce
fameux fond d'investissement pour la
prévention de l'usure professionnelle
donc c'est je dirais une petite montée
en charge qui va se poursuivre toutes
les années qui vont suivre puisque c'est
un milliard d'euros qui est annoncé pour
le l'ensemble de la période et puis il y
a aussi la capacité enfin le la retraite
pour incapacité permanente et là mon
collègue René Paul Savary vous a donné
notre ambition notre ambition c'est non
pas de proposer 62 ans mais de rester à
60 ans et donc en regardant les recettes
de cette branche nous avons estimé que
nous avions les capacités à prévoir
cette dépense effectivement qui est un
petit peu plus lourde que celle que
proposait par le ministre nous nous en
sommes d'ailleurs entretenus avec la
rapporteur de la branche notre collègue
Pascal grunis et qui nous a indiqué
qu'effectivement dès 2026 nous
atteindrions un niveau de
commande de moyen sur cette branche qui
serait suffisant pour absorber n'est-ce
pas monsieur le ministre cette demande
de notre commission des affaires
sociales c'est-à-dire d'aller un petit
peu plus loin et de rester à 60 ans pour
l'ensemble de ces personnes qui sont
effectivement en difficulté et
incapacité permanente merci
monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
pour la construction d'un pédophs je
voudrais simplement dire trois choses la
première dirige à Monsieur gay qui fait
un mauvais procès on peut au-delà de la
sémantique monsieur
travailleur travailleur privé d'emploi
du Grand précaire je pense qu'on peut se
retrouver tous les deux pour dire que
quel que soit la manière dont les
qualifions nous les regardons nous
pouvons avoir le même objectif du retour
à l'emploi de l'insertion et tous les
deux considérés que ce sont des gens qui
vivent dans une grande précarité parce
que avec un emploi privé d'emploi quel
que soit la manière dont on décrit quel
que soit les mots que l'on met on peut
considérer qu'à moins de 500 euros par
mois à l'échelle d'une vie on parle de
grand précaire et et nous sommes tous
deux d'accord aussi je pense pour dire
que l'enjeu c'est de les aider et
d'aider à maximum de monde à sortir de
cette situation de mots enfin si le
président d'abord sur
le financement du fond de
d'investissement pour la prévention de
l'usure professionnelle nous prévoyons
ce fond à hauteur d'un milliard d'euros
à l'échelle du quinquennat avec 100
millions cette année et la grande
puissance à hauteur de 200 à 250
millions de millions d'euros par an j'ai
entendu que c'était insuffisant
aujourd'hui la branche ATMP consacre 40
millions d'euros par an à la prévention
d'usure professionnelle et à
l'investissement dans la prévention de
l'usure professionnelle et donc c'est un
vrai changement d'échelle que nous vous
proposons en passant de 40 à 200 250
millions d'euros par an pour permettre
justement d'accompagner la négociation
et la signature d'un corps de prévention
par branche pour les métiers les plus
exposés assez trop muscle au
squelettiques madame le héros c'est
notamment inquiété de l'équilibre
budgétaire et qui est financier de la
branche ATMP pour compléter vos chiffres
madame la sénatrice en 2025 c'est la
prévision que nous avons d'excédents
estimé à 3,3 milliards d'euros c'est à
peu près 20% du total des recettes et
ces 3,3 milliards d'euros d'excédents en
2025 tiennent compte de ce que vous avez
qualifié à juste titre de ce déclaration
puisque chaque année en pdfss est
proposé un transfert de la banchâtel MP
vers la branche CNAM de mémoire à
hauteur
selon les années nous intégrons ce
transfert à hauteur d'un milliard 100
milliards de chaque année dans la
prévision et malgré ce transfert nous
restons à 3 milliards 3 en 2025 le swap
pardon pour l'anglise de taux entre la
TNT et la CNAV portent sur un peu plus
d'un milliards d'euros ce qui signifie
qu'il restera 2 milliards d'euros
d'excédents en 2025 et sur ces 2
milliards d'euros d'excès donc je pense
que nous pouvons convenir qu'il est
possible de financer de soins de 150
millions d'euros de prévention sont sans
mettre en péril du tout
l'équilibre financiers de la branche
ATMP et ça sera tout compris baisse des
taux plus sous déclaration il restera 2
milliards d'euros d'excédents 2025 200
millions d'euros ça ça passe ça reste de
la dépense publique mais mais ça passe
enfin dernier mot monsieur le Président
aussi vite que possible sur les
questions d'accident du travail
merci madame la Présidente Rossignol
qu'il a évoqué beaucoup d'autres ont
évoqué mais je pense à elle puisqu'elle
avait évoqué dans la discussion des tous
premiers articles les chiffres sont
parfois difficiles à exploiter parce que
nous ne parlons pas toujours de la même
chose il y a une stabilité du nombre
d'accidents grave et mortels et je m'en
explique en quelques mots nous sommes au
tour de 650 accidents mortels chaque
année sur le lieu de travail dans tous
les régimes auxquels il faut ajouter les
accidents de parcours les morts sur
actions de parcours et auxquels il
faudrait ajouter pour être complet les
personnes qui décèdent à la suite d'une
maladie professionnelle mais qui la
plupart du temps ne décède pas sur leur
lieu de travail parce que justement
malade mais sur le lieu de travail nous
sommes assistant
quel est la prévalence de tout cela ce
sont une augmentation 2019 je dois le
préciser parce que depuis 2019 nous
avons une jurisprudence qui intègre les
décès par malaise comme des décès avec
une préemption de cause professionnelle
c'est ce qui explique le décalage de
chiffres en 2019 et quand on regarde de
plus près qui se passe oui les plus de
50 ans sont plus nombreux
malheureusement à mourir sur le lieu de
travail essentiellement du fait des
malaises réalisé sur le lieu de travail
par contre quand on regarde les choses
hors malaise quels sont les travailleurs
les plus exposés à des accidents mortels
sur le travail ce sont les jeunes les
intérimaires les travailleurs détachés
les nouveaux embaucher les quatre ont
comme caractéristiques d'être présents
sur le lieu de travail depuis peu
longtemps et donc très certainement de
manquer de formation d'informations et
de prévention c'est là la typologie des
décès et il faudrait ajouter dans un des
comptes un peu macabre des décès
notamment dans le secteur des travaux
publics et de l'agriculture de personnes
qui travaillent de manière isolée et qui
peuvent connaître un malaise subir un
accident une chute et être seul sur leur
lieu de travail isolé de leurs collègues
et malheureusement décédés faute de soin
ou faute de secours dans le cadre du
Plan Santé au Travail numéro 4 la partie
accident du travail mortelle est grave
et est une priorité et j'aurai
l'occasion la loi travail qu'on a déjà
évoqué plusieurs reprises de proposer au
Parlement des mesures qui permettront
d'aller plus loin pour prévenir des
accidents gravés mortels parce qu'on
parle de ces 650 morts sur le travail
1000 morts au total avec les accidents
de trajet et les maladies
professionnelles mais n'oublions pas
qu'il y a 9600 personnes par an qui
connaissent en action du travail leur
laissant un taux d'incapacité supérieure
à 10% et donc des séquelles à vie en
tout cas extrêmement durable donc c'est
un vrai chantier qu'il faut pousser les
chiffres que j'ai donné sur la branche
ATMP nous permettront d'y faire face
merci Monsieur le Ministre
j'ai un amendement de douaneaux ensuite
d'actionnelle
[Musique]
avant je vais passer à l'article 17
avec prise de parole d'abord de Madame
ponce
ce type
oui merci monsieur le Président alors
nous voilà à la branche famille
au fil des débats nous avons bien
entendu la droite sénatoriale d'écrire
leur vision de la famille on va dire je
veux pas être péjoratif mais elle me
semble quand même
cette vision intangible unique éternelle
alors que pour nous c'est une
construction sociale et si elle a
quelque chose d'éternel c'est qu'elle
est en éternelle mouvement en éternel
changement
nous préférons là pour cela soulever
plutôt
le fait que la famille constitue un
champ d'observation fécond pour l'étude
des inégalités sociales les inégalités
entre les enfants sont criants rappelons
qu'en France un enfant sur cinq soit
près de 3 millions et pauvres le
président ou le directeur je ne sais
plus de la branche famille disait
d'ailleurs que c'était un scandale et
moi je pense que ce qui est un scandale
c'est que cette branche soit en excédent
c'est un peu comme la TPMP c'est pas
normal avec je peux pas vous répondre
mais c'est le ministre mais on le fera à
la loi famille sur les sur les accidents
de travail mais c'est pas normal que
avec les accidents de feu de travail
qu'on a en France et qui sont une honte
par rapport à l'Europe
avec là pour la broche famille un enfant
sur cinq qui est en situation de
pauvreté ces deux branches soient en
excédent ce qui vous permet de les
ponctionner mais elle devrait pas être
un excédent
d'ailleurs selon l'Insee les inégalités
sociales de santé apparaissent avant la
naissance et se creuse durant l'enfance
selon une étude de l'UNICEF datant de
2016 sur plusieurs critères d'inégalités
la France occupe le 28e rang sur 35 pays
de l'Union européenne ça serait bien que
quelques fois on s'occupe de regarder
les 27 qui nous précèdent et au lieu de
regarder leur site de compétitivité
l'UNICEF considère enfin dénonce un
déploiement inégal des services et des
ressources au détriment des enfants les
plus vulnérables ayant des pour
conséquences une accumulation des
difficultés pour ces derniers bref merci
Madame
merci Madame Cohen merci monsieur
le prix 17 entérine les choix décidé
lors du PLFSS 2023 pour la branche
famille avec le transfert de 2 milliards
d'euros des indemnités journalières de
la branche assurance maladie vers la
branche famille alors que les besoins
sont urgents notamment pour la création
d'un grand service public de la petite
enfance ces deux milliards d'euros vont
manquer en particulier pour les femmes
les femmes qui subissent lourdement les
conséquences sur leur vie
professionnelle de leur choix familiaux
je ne peux que regretter critiquer
fortement l'inaction du gouvernement en
matière d'égalité salariale entre les
femmes et les hommes je suis en colère
devant cette passivité des pouvoirs
publics qui consiste à accepter d'année
en année que les entreprises demeurent
dans l'illégalité à croire qu'en matière
de droit des femmes le respect de la
légalité est beaucoup moins important
que dans d'autres sujets je pense à ces
femmes qui devront travailler deux ans
de plus avec votre réforme et même
au-delà pour ne pas subir la décote qui
frappent lourdement le montant des
pensions de retraite au lieu de
rallonger la durée de travail à 43 ans
et l'âge légal à si vous aviez mis en
place les mécanismes pour garantir
l'égalité salariale notre système de
retraite serait à l'équilibre avec les
cotisations supplémentaires et les
pensions des femmes seraient bien
supérieures permettez-moi de citer Grand
Corps Malade face aux profondschisme de
nos coutumes de nos cultures dans le
grand livre des humains place au
chapitre de la rupture alors mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre rompons
avec les discriminations les inégalités
salariales professionnelles subies par
les femmes il est plus que temps en 2023
et malheureusement cette réforme va
encore les aggraver et les accentuer si
manifestations historiques 90% des
actifs opposés à la retraite à 64 ans et
votre seule réponse est le mépris mépris
envers l'opposition sénatoriale et
surtout mépris du président de la
République envers les syndicats qu'il
refuse de recevoir mépris envers les
salariés et les Français votre projet
n'est pas légitime retirez-le et il y
aura encore de grosses manifestations la
semaine prochaine et notamment le 15
mars merci
pas d'autres water sur l'article
je n'envoie point et je passe au 50
amendements de suppression monsieur
Ferro le 305
merci monsieur le Président amendement
de suppression de l'article 17 vous me
direz il n'y a rien dedans puisque le
budget de la branche famille reste
identique et il a certainement que par
une forme d'obligation légale de pure
forme mais
vous nous parlez souvent et notamment
dans la majorité sénatoriale des de la
nécessité démographique de cette réforme
des retraites et que voyons-nous comme
sur les autres sujets il n'y a aucune
mesure de politique familiale qui
accompagne véritablement cette réforme
pour justement changer l'équation de
départ et donc on entérine une situation
de manière extrêmement comptable sans
chercher aucune ressource nouvelle sans
changer les choses en prenant les
nouveaux en compte les nouveaux rapports
au travail sans non plus avoir une
politique familiale qui permette
d'améliorer l'égalité femme homme et de
donner à notre démographie
à le coup de pouce dont elle a besoin
aujourd'hui donc on voit bien que vous
mettez la charrue avant les bœufs avec
cette réforme des retraites quoi qu'on
en pense sur le fond par ailleurs c'est
ce que les Français vous disent en
demandant de la retirer c'est ce que les
organisations syndicales disent en
demandant de négocier vous nous avez dit
monsieur le ministre que vous
concerteriez une loi travail après cette
loi et forme des retraites peut-être
nous direz-vous la même chose ou l'un de
vos collègues du gouvernement sur la
famille et bien faites les choses dans
l'ordre et retirez votre réforme des
retraites merci
madame Ferrer le 391
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre sur cet article 17 proposons la
suppression nous proposons la
suppression car nous considérons que cet
amendement qui vise à confirmer
l'objectif de dépenses familles
pas cet amendement cet article
excusez-moi qui vise à confirmer
l'objectif de dépenses de la branche
famille confirme bien qu'il y a un
manque et donc confirme bien que ce
budget est insuffisant ça a été rappelé
en particulier des besoins non financés
et je pense au gros service public de la
petite enfance qui est annoncé envisagée
sur lequel un travail est engagé mais
pour lequel on ne voit pas le moindre
financement le moindrefinancement c'est
des besoins dans l'organisation de ce
grand service public mais c'est
évidemment des besoins en moyen humain
plus de de postes de travail de
meilleures conditions de travail pour
toutes celles et ceux qui accueillent
particulier ces enfants je pense
notamment à ce volet là mais je pense
aussi à toutes les femmes qui cela
étaient dit mais je pense que c'est bien
de le répéter toutes les femmes qui
seront les premières touchées par votre
réforme par votre réforme qui demande à
tous de travailler plus plus deux ans
pour tout le monde et qui demandera qui
feront que qui fera pardon que ces
femmes qui déjà vivent des situations
tout à fait
précaires difficile notamment parce
qu'elles ont des salaires elles sont
parmi celles et ceux qui ont les plus
bas salaires du notamment à l'inégalité
salariale entre les femmes et les hommes
c'est aussi les femmes qui ont en plus
grand nombre les Carnières hachées pour
plein de raisons mais vous le savez et
donc ça veut dire que leur pension à
terme seront plus faibles ou bien
qu'elles devront travailler plus et
encore plus parce que vous proposez de
reculer
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite donc
pour toutes ces raisons nous rejetons
cet amendement mais surtout nous vous
demandons de retirer votre réforme merci
voilà il est 18h37 à l'antenne de Public
Sénat nous voulions vous montrer une
image symbolique grâce à notre
réalisateur Philippe de Sony c'est
l'écran qui est affiché dans l'hémicycle
l'écran de contrôle on appelle ça un
dérouleur que les sénateurs consultent
pour suivre l'ordre et vous voyez ce
chiffre qui s'affiche sans quad 199 on
vient de passer une barre symbolique
dans l'examen de la réforme des
retraites d'ailleurs on va en parler
avec notre journaliste Mathias sarez
Mathias vous qui vous trouvez dans en
tribune de presse c'est un câble
symbolique comme je disais oui Quentin
ça y est nous nous trouvons sous la
barre des 200 amendements à examiner
alors pourquoi cela est allé si vite me
direz-vous et bien car on se trouve dans
un projet de loi de finance
rectificative de la sécurité sociale
donc il n'est pas possible de créer de
nouvelles dépenses c'est l'article 40 de
la Constitution alors il reste
simplement une seule arme au sénateur de
gauche et bien c'est de déposer flopée
d'amendement de suppression des articles
restants problèmes ces amendements ont
été signés sans exception de manière
individuelle il faut donc que le
signataire soit présent pour défendre
son amendement et malheureusement cet
après-midi est bien il y a beaucoup
d'absence sur les bancs de la gauche
notamment chez les socialistes où on
compte à la louche environ 25 absents
deuxième mécanisme qui a accéléré les
débats Quentin et bien c'est l'article
44 alinéa 3 de la Constitution ou vote
bloqué qui a été déclenché par le
gouvernement hier et c'est donc un
mécanisme qui prive les parlementaires
de votre séparé sur les articles et
d'explications de vote bref avec un peu
moins de 200 amendements restants à
examiner avec à raison de deux minutes
plus ou moins par amendement il devrait
rester à la louche environ 7 heures de
débat mais Quentin vous le savez comme
moi la politique qui est bien ce n'est
pas une science exacte exactement
Mathias la politique ce n'est pas une
science exacte merci pour cette analyse
pour en parler ici Rémi Cardon bonjour
vous êtes sénateur socialiste de la
somme si je me trompe pas voilà benjamin
du Sénat un mot sur ce que vient
d'évoquer Mathias alors c'est dû à de
nombreux facteurs il y a eu notamment
l'article 38 du Règlement il y a
l'article 44 3 de la Constitution mais
on voit ce chiffre qui a fondu comme
neige au soleil ou qui s'est réduit
comme peau de chagrin dans les dernières
heures du débat de la réforme des
retraites oui bah après ce que vous
oubliez de préciser quand même c'est que
ce sont des articles très techniques
budgétairement donc on a du mal aussi à
faire de la durée de la politique
là-dessus et donc on défend alors après
c'est pareil ces histoires très
financières en réalité tout à l'heure
vous pouvez pas déposer vous pouvez pas
créer de nouvelles dépenses donc la
seule à un moment qui vous reste
suppression on l'a expliqué à l'antenne
de public c'est ça je me doutais bien
que vous êtes très vigilant en ce moment
sur sur ce qui se passe mais en tout cas
ce qui est effectivement pas très
rassurant c'est qu'on voit on est à peu
près à 200 200 rendement en restant en
passant à la barre on descend en dessous
de la barre des deux sens si je
comprends bien donc effectivement ça
veut dire que les débats vont pas
forcément durer jusqu'à le dimanche
23h59 est-ce que vous souhaitiez c'est
ça la est-ce que vous vouliez vous non
c'était c'était de faire en sorte que à
minuit le matériel qu'à minuit dimanche
soir il y a pas eu de vote sur
l'ensemble du texte alors ça c'est des
rumeurs mais nous ce qu'on voulait
c'était juste avoir un débat c'est en
fait ils ont pris panique ils ont
enclenché alors le gouvernement a
commencé par le 47-1 monsieur Retailleau
l'article 38 et encore plus récemment
monsieur du soft l'article 44 3 donc
vous voyez que bon si vous voulez quand
quand on est on a on a peur de perdre
généralement on on essaye de changer
toutes les règles c'est ce qui s'est
passé en réalité et donc nous tout ce
qu'on a fait c'est qu'on a fait notre
job on a déposé des amendements on les a
défendus
je dirais péniblement parce qu'il y a
pas de discussion il y a même pas on a
même pas le regarde tout à l'heure j'ai
à peine eu le droit de parler parce que
mais j'étais coupé par mes collègues sur
l'antenne voilà tout à fait donc si vous
voulez un collègue qui vous a dit des
mots dit que voilà je suis jeune et je
dis des conneries en gros si je résume
mais bon bref ça c'est c'est une
parenthèse et ça en réalité c'est pas
beaucoup d'intérêt dans un débat comme
les retraites justement puisqu'on parle
on passe de sous la barre des 200
amendements qu'il reste maintenant moins
de 10 heures de d'examen de la réforme
des retraite qu'est-ce que vous retenez
vous de ces de ces 10 jours de ce
marathon autour de ce texte il y aura un
avant un après dans le niveau
d'énervement le niveau de tension qu'on
aura connu entre la droite et la gauche
sénatoriale ah oui ça c'est sûr mais en
même temps je peux comprendre aussi mes
collègues de droite puisqu'ils ont
consigne puisque monsieur retailleul
aura donné comme consigne de ne pas
parler
pour que nous on s'use à défendre des
amendements tout seul c'est-à-dire que
nous on parle à la rigueur au mieux on a
des fois on a on a un petit échange avec
monsieur le rapporteur ou alors avec
Monsieur le Ministre et ça commence
aussi et là aussi à ce à devenir de plus
en plus rare il y a de plus en plus de
juste défaves de mots défavorables basta
et puis circuler il y a rien à voir et
en réalité moi je pense qu'on a joué le
jeu jouer le jeu de d'opposants à cette
réforme on a déposé des amendements je
pense qu'on a fait même découvrir un
centre de choses à nos collègues et on a
je pense cité un centre de rapport de
chiffres d'éléments structurant dans un
débat bon voilà force cette constater
que mes collègues sont pas très
intéressés par le débat puisque ils
prennent pas la parole c'est pour ça que
d'où ma remarque avec beaucoup d'humour
je voulais vérifier si l'aile droite de
l'ICI qui était vivante parce que en
réalité il y avait personne qui qui
répond tout le monde regarde soit son
iPad ou limite ça discute avec le voisin
pendant des heures enfin je c'est si oui
je suis un peu désolé de le dire comme
ça mais c'est pas digne de la maison qui
est le Sénat on a entendu votre chef de
fil Patrick canaire dire qu'il y avait
eu une atteinte à la sincérité des
débats avec tous ces recours entre le
règlement du Sénat ou encore le recours
à une reconstitutionnelle vous allez
déposer si on comprend bien un recours
une fois que le texte sera fini d'être
d'être examiné avec vos collègues
également écologistes ou communiste au
Conseil constitutionnel effectivement il
y a eu des discussions entre les
différents groupes là-dessus Monsieur
Patrick canard a confirmé également à
une dernière réunion stratégique sur la
suite de l'avancement aujourd'hui
exactement donc on va le faire on va le
faire on va le faire parce que je pense
que ça mérite d'être alors même si on a
bien compris que à la fois le
gouvernement et pas très intéressé par
la vie du Conseil d'État ou du Conseil
constitutionnel ou de la Cour des
comptes ou de toutes ces beaux
organismes qui font quand même qui
structurent aussi le débat public mais
on va nous on va le faire on va le faire
parce que je pense que ça ça de la
clarté sur ce qui s'est passé et je
pense qu'il faut laisser aussi les voilà
des professionnels de du Conseil
consiste constitutionnel juger si oui ou
non la sincérité de de ce texte la
méthode qui est employée par la droite
ses tutoriels et le gouvernement en
grande complicité pour les clients je me
pose maintenant c'est ce qu'il va avoir
un remaniement prochainement est-ce que
Monsieur Retailleau monsieur carucci qui
ont fait le job qui ont été les phares
en soldats de ce gouvernement est-ce que
ils vont pouvoir intégrer enfin ce le
prochain gouvernement alors peut-être
après le projet de loi immigration parce
que c'est tout ça c'est des cadeaux à
droite en fait si vous voulez
franchement opposé à plusieurs mesures
du texte de la loi immigration ah comme
donc devoir trouver des oui mais sauf
que le gouvernement cherche une majorité
et donc il va devoir céder à la droite
sénatoriale c'est un peu ce qui se passe
aussi sur la réforme des retraites et
bien sûr à ça dans les prochains mois
Rémi Cardon merci pour cette réaction au
micro de public c'est là on retourne
dans les mixies que le poursuivre ses
débats et remédier le Haut Conseil de la
famille de l'enfance et de l'âge vient
de rendre deux rapports sur l'accueil
des enfants de moins de 3 ans il en
ressort que 56% des parents gardent
eux-mêmes leur bébé alors qu'ils ne sont
que 36% à souhaiter le faire faute
d'avoir obtenu une place concrète ou
chez une assistante maternelle deux
enfants sur dix sont gardés par leurs
proches familles souvent des
grands-parents qui d'ailleurs ne
pourront peut-être plus le faire car ils
devront travailler plus longtemps demain
donc là pour financer cette grande
politique publique il faudra des moyens
d'autre part cela a été dit la pauvreté
et le quotidien de nombreuses familles
l'inflation pousse de plus en plus de
familles dans la précarité alimentaire
en témoignent le recours de plus en plus
important aux associations de l'aide
alimentaire les antennes locales des
Restos du coeur de la Banque alimentaire
de mon département m'ont fait part d'un
accroissement très important des
bénéficiaires ces derniers mois
donc on le voit bien le manque
d'ambition le manque de moyens se
traduit dans cet article 17 et encore
une fois nous vous le répétons mais nous
vous le ferons jusqu'à la fin de la
soirée retirer votre réforme des
retraites injustes je merci le 886
monsieur Durand
merci monsieur le Président je soutenir
l'amendement de suppression de la
confirmation de l'objectif de défense de
la branche famille tel qu'elle est
proposée par le gouvernement de cet
article et dans cet article il y a
évidemment une partie des minima sociaux
des minima sociaux dont un certain
responsable politique du pays il y avait
dit que il nous coûtait un pognon de
dingue
je pense qu'il faut qu'on s'intéresse si
on veut comprendre la situation
politique du pays et la colère dont on
vous parle tout à l'heure depuis tout à
l'heure et le mépris dont on parle aussi
à ceux qui ne sont rien les illettrés
les Gaulois réfractaires ceux qui n'ont
pas le sens de l'effort ceux qui ne
travaillent pas pour se payer un costard
ou qui fume des clopes et qui roule au
diesel donc je voudrais dire qu'il est
en train de se réveiller quelque chose
d'extrêmement puissant dans les tréfonds
de la société française qui concerne les
petits les sans grades ceux qui passent
au regard de certains biennés pour des
beaux fous des ploucs et qui eux
opposent très concrètement le quoi qu'il
en coûte
les dividendes record versés aux
actionnaires les salaires mirobolants à
ce qu'il est impossible de faire en
matière de retraite et qui dévoile dans
l'obligation de renoncer à deux années
de retraite pour continuer à travailler
un ancien ministre du gouvernement
Macron avec écrit un ouvrage qui
s'appelait de pauvre à une époque
c'était évidemment une référence à un
film d'autant Lara il y a derrière ces
formules et ses appréhensiations bien
arrogantes et bien méprisante pour le
peuple quelque chose qui explique la
nature de la réforme que nous avons à
débattre aujourd'hui merci
un moment suivant ce sera
madame Lubin le 1164
merci
monsieur
le Président chers collègue la famille a
toujours été sur les formes qui ont
évaluées évolué avec les époques au cœur
de notre société un défendement du pacte
social qui nous lie tous sur ce point
majeur de notre vivre ensemble quelle
est la vision l'aspiration du
gouvernement autre que gestionnaire
le sujet de la prise en compte des
familles pauvres des familles
monoparentales des enfants qui
nécessitent dans une perspective
républicaine d'égalité des soutiens
adaptés ciblés en marge et en dehors de
l'école n'est pas correctement traité
dans vos politiques et ne trouvent pas
de financement dans l'objectif de
dépenses de la branche famille il faut
comme certaines associations le
proposent et je les salue elle se
reconnaîtront penser l'action publique
en direction des familles et des
individus à partir du concept de pouvoir
de vivre
de vivre la vie en famille la vie de la
famille doit être considérée en termes
de moyens d'accès aux services de base
dont la culture l'éducation dans ce
cadre du pouvoir de vivre pour chacun
dans la relation à tous rien de cette
nature dans votre objectif de dépenses
familles à l'article 17 c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous demandons sa
suppression
si Madame Conway bourré le 1490
madame Conon et Mouret
madame
le 1490
merci monsieur le Président pour votre
patience monsieur le ministre vous aviez
l'opportunité de marquer l'histoire de
notre pays en allant dans le sens des
acquis sociaux qui font la fierté de
notre pays et de donner de l'espoir une
jeunesse qui aimerait croire que les
générations précédentes comme les
générations précédentes sa vie sera
meilleure difficile à croire dans le
monde instable et fracturé dans lequel
nous vivons où les tensions et les
guerres se multiplient difficile quand
nous observons tous les jours l'impact
du dérèglement climatique difficile
enfin dans une France où nos
institutions sont aujourd'hui abîmées
vous aviez avec cette réforme la
possibilité d'envoyer un signal très
fort aux jeunes aux femmes et tous ceux
qui ont envie de s'investir dans leur
travail trouver du sens à leur métier et
une motivation ou se dépasser
quotidiennement au culte du travail
pénible supposé témoigner du sérieux du
subordonné s'oppose l'engagement de
travailleurs considérés heureux dans
leur environnement professionnel mieux
formés avec des perspectives d'évolution
de carrière qui débouchent sur la
perspective d'une dernière partie de la
vie dédiée aux siens à l'associatif à
l'humanitaire parce que la personne est
en bonne santé et surtout est capable de
vivre dignement malgré la baisse
substantielle des revenus votre réforme
ne le permet pas en tout cas pour les
pulls vulnérables malgré les espoirs
vous avez fait naître en annonçant 1200
euros comme revenu minimum que
finalement quelques petits milliers de
personnes toucheront alors qu'elles
auraient alors que cela aurait pu être
votre mesure phare
sans parler bien sûr des femmes quant
aux Français de l'étranger votre réforme
réforme les pénalistes doublement car la
mobilité qu'ils ont choisi les privera
de 43 annuités en continu et leur
carrière hachées les places de fait dans
la catégorie femme une vraie occasion
ratée et je crois que nous quitterons
toutes et tous cette hémicycle avec un
sentiment d'immense déception de regret
pour nous de n'avoir pas pu exercer
notre fonction législative correctement
et certainement des remords pour vous
d'avoir raté merci d'avoir voté un
mauvais texte de loup merci Monsieur
Stan le 1533
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre bon il s'agit là aussi de la
suppression de l'article 17
la réforme ne correspond pas aux
aspirations des familles
en nous renvoie bien sûr à une future
loi sur la famille annoncée depuis
longtemps mais qui a du mal à arriver
les inégalités flagrantes dans la
branche famille en particulier pour les
femmes pour les enfants pour les
personnes âgées etc pour tous ceux qui
sont concernés par ce sujet là
il n'y a aucune disposition pour cette
branche famille en fait on ne veut faire
que des économies
c'est le seul objectif de votre réforme
monsieur le ministre qui est en train de
discuter là oui la place de l'humain
dans ce dispositif nulle part les
familles monsieur le ministre vous dise
une chose bien précise en ce moment il y
a plein de Français qui manifestent
beaucoup sont contre la réforme des
retraites à 64 ans et votre seule
réponse ben c'est de ne pas prendre en
considération ces mouvements
comme pour l'opposition sénatoriale en
particulier et puis le président de la
République ne considère absolument pas
les syndicats qu'il refuse de recevoir
d'ailleurs vous le savez puisqu'on vous
le dit depuis toute l'après-midi mais
pris envers les salariés et bien sûr
mépris envers les Français votre projet
n'est pas légitime retirez-le et à
minima retirer
l'article 17 merci merci Madame Monier
le 1563
merci monsieur le Président donc c'est
amendement vise à rejeter la
confirmation de l'objectif de dépenses
de la branche famille tel que proposer
par le gouvernement dans cet article
pour l'année 2023 des objectifs de
dépenses de la branche famille de la
sécurité sociale sont fixées à 53 55,3
milliards d'euros comme pour la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale 2023
la régression que constitue pour les
maires de famille ce projet de réformes
a été l'un des fils rouges de nos
discussions tout au long de ces derniers
jours une régression qui n'est pas
compensée par le dispositif introduit
lors de l'examen de notre assemblée
d'ouverture de la surcotte un an avant
l'âge légal pour les assurer justifiants
de la durée d'assurance requise et
bénéficiant de trimestres validés par la
maternité ce recul au-delà d'un nouveau
coup porté à l'égalité réelle entre les
femmes et les hommes symbolise également
le manque d'ambition en matière de
politique familiale du gouvernement ce
dernier a à plusieurs reprises raboter
les de la branche famille je pense par
exemple à l'économie des 9 milliards
réalisés sur les APL il a pourtant forte
à faire dans la matière meilleure
accompagnement des familles
monoparentales c'est-à-dire dans 80% des
cas des maires en situation de
monoparentalité création d'un service
public de la petite enfance essentielle
à l'heure ou plus de 200000 places en
crèche sera nécessaire pour accueillir
nos enfants 50 et bien sûr les
difficultés supplémentaires qui seront
occasionnées par le recul de l'âge légal
de départ à la retraite aujourd'hui 23
millions d'heures de gardes
hebdomadaires sont assurés par les
grands-parents pour leur petit enfant
soit l'équivalent de 650 000 emplois à
temps plein au regard de C40 on ne peut
que désapprouver les objectifs de la
dépense de la branche familière c'est
trop insuffisant un argument de plus
pour retirer cette réforme merci le 1645
madame Pomerol
oui merci monsieur le Président nous
devons donc la suppression de cet
article puisque aucune recette nouvelle
n'est prévue dans cet article depuis le
début je dirais même depuis des années
en ce qui concerne les LR vous arguez du
problème des groupes démographiques pour
justifier de votre réforme injuste c'est
un late motive alors vous avez certes
dans ce mi quelques petites mesures de
compensation mais uniquement pour les
maires de famille comme si les femmes
n'étaient que des mères et méritait seul
le respect pourtant si vous résolviez
l'inégalité salariale entre les hommes
et les femmes il n'y aurait plus de
déficit les recettes seraient là or
aujourd'hui ce sont les femmes
essentiellement qui vont supporter les
deux tiers des économies relatives que
vous comptez faire par ce projet injuste
on aurait pu pourtant se servir avoir
une politique familiale vrai qui aurait
permis de créer un grand service public
de la petite enfance qui permettent de
résoudre les difficultés de garde que
rencontre aujourd'hui les jeunes couples
et il est temps de le mettre en place
pour que les femmes puissent enfin
choisir librement leur travail et non
pas sous la contrainte comme elles le
font le plus souvent actuellement nous
vous demandons donc de supprimer ces
articles et le 1772 madame meunier merci
monsieur le Président oui une forme pure
forme que cet article 17 obligatoire
dans un tel texte financement de la
sécurité sociale et qui concerne la
branche famille vous avez entendu mes
collègues et évoquer diverses solutions
diverses raisons
diverses réponses à cette indispensable
conciliation vie professionnelle vie
familiale vie personnelle concernant
soit les familles monoparentales soit
les jeunes parents avec des modes de
garde adaptés par un service public par
exemple
d'autres réponses concernant le congé
parental bref d'autres réponses c'était
possible mais c'était cet article est
identique enfin inchangé les ne bougent
pas et décidément c'est une réforme qui
est néfaste néfaste pour l'organisation
sociale de la société l'organisation
néfaste pour les les salariés également
néfastes pour les retraités néfastes
pour les comptes sociaux
cette loi n'est pas légitime retirer là
merci monsieur le Président canner le
merci monsieur le Président je passe
ensuite un jeu joli le 1930
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues s'agit d'un
amendement qui vise à supprimer
l'article concernant la branche famille
de la sécurité sociale en tout cas
regarde du montant de 55 milliards qui
n'arriverait pas suffisant pour répondre
aux différents enjeux que connaissent
aujourd'hui la famille la jeunesse et
tous ceux qui sont bénéficiaires des
actions menées dans ce cadre-là et pour
lesquels d'étudier des crédits sont
dédiés s'agit tout d'abord de d'une
insuffisance concernant l'offre
d'accueil à destination des jeunes
enfants c'est vrai dans tous les
territoires et particulièrement vrai sur
les territoires ruraux pour lesquels
même si les choses avancent les places
de crèche notamment reste encore
insuffisantes plus particulièrement
sujet partout insensible ces dernières
années avec l'arrivée de nouveaux
résidents qui ont décidé de
le retour à la campagne inégalité
insuffisance pour lutter contre les
inégalités également
croissante notez et vous le savez que la
part des enfants ils vont dans des
ménages ou seuil de pauvreté est en
croissance avec des familles
monoparentales généralement assumer par
les maires de famille inaccessibilité
également du RSA pour les 18-25 ans un
sujet sur lequel il faudra rapidement ce
tourner pour apporter les réponses
adaptées et éviter effectivement que des
jeunes vivent dans des conditions
difficiles inégalité également réponse
aux inégalités salariales entre les
hommes et les femmes autant d'éléments
qui conduisent à se demander la
suppression de cet amendement et qui
justifie plus encore le fait de ne pas
voter pour cette loi sur les qui
contient cette réforme des retraites et
qui est manifestement pas satisfaisante
pour les Français qui l'ont compris à
travers cette mobilisation au cours de
ces derniers jours une opposition à la
fois au gouvernement et à la majorité
sénatoriale qui s'apprête à voter cette
réforme des retraites merci merci le
2291 monsieur Tissot il est 19h sur
Public Sénat nous sommes en direct
depuis maintenant 10 jours pour suivre
l'examen de la réforme des retraites au
Sénat je voulais vous montrer une image
vous la voyez sur cette cette écran
c'est effectivement ce que les sénateurs
peuvent voir dans l'hémicycle cela
affiche ce qu'on appelle le dérouleur
c'est à dire les orateurs et qui
viennent dans la suite de la discussion
des amendements et vous le voyez en haut
on est passé à environ
160 amendements qu'il reste à examiner
d'ici à la fin de l'examen de la réforme
des retraites ce chiffre est bien il a
diminué très rapidement ces dernières
heures pour en parler on va rejoindre
notre journaliste Mathias sarez qui se
trouve en tribune de presse Mathias on
peut le dire ça c'est accéléré ces
dernières heures n'est-ce pas ça s'est
accéléré la vitesse grand V quand un
vous l'avez vu justement vous le
commentiez le moteur d'amendement étant
chute libre c'est une ambiance morose
sur les bancs d'une gauche qui a rendu
les armes à l'instant on vient de voir
le patron des socialistes Patrick Canet
refusait de défendre son amendement de
suppression de l'article 17 il reste à
présent vous l'avez dit 157 amendements
à défendre on passera ensuite à votre
solennelle cela devrait être après 21h30
et la coupure du dîner à ce moment-là on
s'attend grosso modo à une heure
d'explication de vote 7 minutes par
groupe sénatorial et c'est le président
Gérard Larcher qui devrait présider
cette séance quand un il n'y a pas
vraiment de grand doute à avoir
normalement on se dirige vers un vote
sur cette réforme des retraites ce soir
au Sénat voilà c'est l'information
qu'effectivement on peut vous donner
maintenant à priori donc il y aurait un
vote sur la réforme des retraites sur
l'ensemble du texte ce soir et non pas
demain car le chiffre du nombre
d'amendement qui reste à examiné se
réduit de minutes en minutes à vitesse
grand V comme dit mathiasarayez retour
dans l'hémistique pour écouter les
débats
d'exercer un emploi pénible les cadres
les emplois de bureau ou les professions
intellectuelles ne seront pas en reste
puisque tout le monde devra travailler
plus longtemps mais l'injustice nous le
rappelons et d'autant plus vite que
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé et
l'espérance de vie tout court n'a rien
de comparable en fonction de la
profession et exercée cela sera encore
plus marqué avec l'allongement de la
durée de cotisation et le report de
l'âge de départ à la retraite ce sont
d'ailleurs ces mêmes professions où vous
rencontrez une pénurie de main d'oeuvre
qui ne va pas s'arranger de Kito alors
je ne vais pas revenir ici à cet instant
sur des éléments chiffrés que nous avons
largement et évoqué et qui illus selon
moi une violence de classe quand même
assez inouïe la retraite pose la
question de la vie de l'humain et vont
et vous y répondez par de la
comptabilité pourtant il est bien moins
coûteux pour la planète et pour notre
santé à tous de limiter la place du
travail dans nos vies plutôt que de
poursuivre la poursuivre la fuite en
avant productiviste que vous défendez
alors l'histoire ne retiendra que nous
vous avions prévenu avec insistance et
que alors que tout le pays défilait
encore cet après-midi contre votre
réforme des retraites vous vous êtes
inventé une légitimité pour protéger une
minorité au détriment de l'intérêt
général et aujourd'hui effectivement
nous en sommes à six manifestations
historiques 90% des actifs sont toujours
opposés à la retraite à 60 4 ans face à
cela la seule votre seule réponse c'est
le mépris mépris envers l'opposition
sénatoriale et surtout mépris du
président de la République envers les
syndicats qui refusent de recevoir
mépris envers les salariés des Français
votre votre projet je l'ai dit et je le
redis et je confirme encore à cet
instant votre projet n'est pas légitime
retirez-le
madame la rapporteur général
chers collègues comme il a été très bien
dit pas de d'incidence sur cette branche
famille dans le cadre de cette loi de
réforme des retraites pour autant nous
avons les uns les autres rappelés
combien la famille le lien
intergénérationnel était primordial dans
cette réforme des retraites puisque on
veut
pérenniser les finances de cette de
cette retraite par répartition et nous
avons mentionné à différents moments ces
fameuses MDA c'est majorations de durée
d'assurance qui peuvent être
donnés au moment d'une maternité de
l'éducation d'un enfant ou pour
l'éducation d'un enfant handicapé donc
il y a un lien mais je pense qu'il y a
un lien encore plus fort quand on parle
de retraite avec la capacité pendant la
durée de travail de pouvoir confier ses
enfants et vous l'avez dit pour
certaines et pour certains ce qui est
important c'est les places de garde du
jeune enfant et j'espère que nous
resteront ce travail dans les mois
prochains il est annoncé par le ministre
des Solidarités Jean-Christophe combe
qui veut comment organiser un service
public de la petite enfance et nous
aurons j'espère l'occasion de travailler
sur par exemple les assistants de
maternelle parce qu'on sait combien les
instants de maternelle dans nos
territoires manquent aujourd'hui qu'il y
a un vieillissement de cette profession
et que il faut absolument en quelque
sorte réenchanter ce métier et donc sans
doute le valoriser de toutes les
manières et puis il y a aussi les places
de crèches en collectif et là encore
c'est un investissement important qu'il
faudra faire parce que on le voit bien à
travers les différentes conventions
d'objectifs et de moyens qui sont signés
entre entre les tailles et la CAF et
bien il y a à chaque fois un décompte
qui est défavorable et c'est un décompte
défavorable pour les familles donc nous
devons absolument confronter ces
politiques de la politique de la petite
enfance il a absolument nécessaire
d'avoir des réponses pour les familles
parce que ça permet aussi de travailler
en sérénité et surtout les territoires
et puis je voudrais rappeler que notre
collègue Olivier Hainaut va travailler
avec notre collègue Annie le Wii rousse
dans le cadre de la Mecque sur un
rapport d'informations ou d'enquête je
ne sais plus trop sur justement les
congés parentaux et sur notamment la
prestation de partage de l'éducation de
l'enfant donc là encore nous aurons des
éléments qui seront absolument
importants pour pousser cette réflexion
et réfléchir justement à l'équilibre
familial quand on a une vie
professionnelle et pour les deux parents
et parfois que pour l'un d'entre eux
mais en tout cas l'organisation de la
vie familiale autour du travail donc
rendez-vous est pris pour ces différents
travaux en tout cas je vous remercie de
vos interventions qui ont permis de
mettre aussi l'accent sur les problèmes
des familles pour
la petite enfance et et je pense que
vous serez tous motivés pour y
travailler merci donc c'est un avis
défavorable monsieur le ministre
merci à Monsieur le Président sur la
forme d'abord la vie défavorable
puisqu'il s'agit là aussi d'un article
obligatoire et en écho à ce que dit
Madame la rapporteur à l'instant deux
choses d'abord pour confirmer que mon
collègue Jean-Christophe combe aura
l'occasion de développer un certain
nombre de sujets autour de la politique
familiale cela sort de mon champ de
compétences ministérielle et donc je ne
vais pas plus loin tout en partageant ce
qu'a dit Madame le rappeur et puis par
ailleurs ce projet de loi de financement
de la rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale aura permis je crois d'avancer
sur la prise en compte de trimestre
isotique de l'assurance vieillesse des
parents foyers pour les éligibilité au
minimum de pension au dispositif de
départ anticipé carrière longue aura
permis d'intégrer les mêmes trimestres
titres de l'aide aux aidants et on sait
ça a été rappelé à plusieurs reprises
que 80 à 90% des aidants sont des aidons
aura permis d'adopter un dispositif
permettant une surcote sur un certain
nombre de trimestres mais je partage
l'idée notamment sur des questions
d'assurance vieillesse par un foyer
comme sur la question de la surcote pour
des trimestres obtenus par majoration de
durée que cela concerne les mers avant
de concerner la totalité des femmes ce
qui renvoient aux politiques d'égalité
professionnelle qu'on a qu'on a évoqué
nous aurons aussi l'occasion dans les
prochaines semaines de mettre de donner
suite à l'engagement que nous avons pris
avec la première ministre d'ouvrir un
chantier sur les droits familiaux en
général à la fois majoration trimestre
mais aussi règles des pensions de
réversion en plus de ce que nous aurons
pu faire dans ce texte mais pour revenir
aux amendements ça n'avait
merci Monsieur le Ministre article 18
madame pansemonge
merci monsieur le Président alors c'est
amendement vient corriger à la marge le
plafond des dépenses de la branche
autonomie pour 2023 cela nous donne
l'occasion de reparler quand même de
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé qui
est la Libye principale de l'allongement
de la durée du travail l'espérance de
vie en bonne santé devrait être au coeur
effectivement d'une réforme des
retraites notamment pour tenir compte
des catégories socioprofessionnelles
ça devrait d'ailleurs être un indicateur
de ce qu'on souhaite une société de
prospérité et c'est un indicateur dont
le PIB totalement aveugle je n'y reviens
pas cette espérance de vie varie selon
les revenus vous êtes vous en avez parlé
monsieur le ministre à propos des 5% les
plus pauvres cela me permet de rappeler
que pour les 30% les plus pauvres les
trois premiers décident comme on dit en
statistique et eux seuls le passage à la
retraite correspond à une amélioration
du niveau de vie ce qui n'est pas le cas
pour les classes moyennes et encore
moins pour avec classe supérieure aussi
quand même quand vous ajoutez deux ans à
tout le monde si vous voulez vous
retarder de deux ans la bascule de 30%
de la population la plus pauvre dans
leur niveau de vie qui améliore je vous
renvoie aux travaux du corps si vous en
doutez je dis ça parce que effectivement
c'est 2 ans vous voyez c'est une loi
anti pauvre
il faudrait revenir aussi souvent on
parle des femmes avec leur longue
espérance de vie j'aimerais vous
rappeler que les années d'espérance de
vie supplémentaire des femmes sont en
majeure partie des années en mauvaise
santé c'est ce que disent les chercheurs
Ulysse les Austin et Julien Blasco à 30
ans une ouvrière donc catégorie sociaux
professionnels ouvriers peut espérer
vivre 55 ans virgule 7 dans 21 avec un
capacité soit 10 ans de moins en plus
mauvaise santé qu'un cadre donc vous
voyez monsieur le ministre
non il n'y a pas de gagnant dans cette
dans cette réforme il y a que des
perdants et déjà les pauvres merci
Madame meunier
32 à 64
les débats dans l'hémicycle bonjour
merci d'être avec nous sur ce plateau
installé pour l'occasion au plus près
des débats et depuis 10 jours maintenant
on arrive dans la dernière ligne droite
voilà il reste même moins de 5 heures
puisque visiblement les amendements
tombent on voit le chiffre qui s'affiche
grâce à notre réalisateur Philippe de
Sony on voit l'écran le dérouleur de la
séance et ce chiffre qui est en train de
passer sous la barre des 150 avec en
plus des orateurs qui sont absents donc
mécaniquement peut-être qu'il reste 70
prises de parole en fait dans les
amendements voilà c'est la fin de cet
examen qu'est-ce que vous en garderez
vous alors d'une part c'est pas la fin
de l'examen puisqu'il y aura quand même
la commission mixte paritaire qui va se
réunir mercredi et nous aurons des
conclusions on en parlera à mes
déconclusions jeudi matin donc la
première lecture c'est la fin de la de
la première lecture ou ce que j'en tire
c'est que les engagements que nous
avions le prix nous les groupes de
gauche nous les avons tenus certes nous
n'arrivons pas jusque dimanche soir mais
il faut dire que la le Sénat et la
majorité sénatoriale et le gouvernement
nous ont un peu nous ont un peu
bâillonné si je puis dire les choses les
choses ainsi avec des procédures
dégainées que soient réglementaire ou
qu'elle soit constitutionnelles donc
forcément tout ça a accéléré
accélérer les débats et empêcher
l'opposition de défendre les centaines
voire les milliers d'amendement qu'elle
avait déposé quand on a posé la question
à votre collègue Mélanie Vogel elle
citait la soirée du du 7 au 8 où vous
avez vu des centaines voire même des
milliers de d'amendements de sous
amendements tombés pendant après une
réunion de la commission où vous jugez
vous estimez qu'ils n'ont pas été
examinés sur le fond c'est grave ce qui
s'est joué cette semaine oui je pense
que il faudra faire un si je peux me
permettre l'expression à un débriefing
voilà oui mais je sais pas si un audit
ça prend le temps moi je pense que il
serait
urgent que la Conférence des présidents
se réunissent et au-delà de l'heure du
jour puisse vraiment examiner les les
problématiques qui se sont posées
pendant l'examen de ce texte et c'est
emblématique ce qui s'est passé ce qui
s'est passé dans l'année dans la nuit du
du 7 au 8 est emblématique quand on a
une présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales qui qui avoue voilà
Catherine de rochechkia à vous n'avoir
pas pris connaissance de d'amendement et
de les déclarer quand même comme
irrecevable c'est assez incroyable c'est
on est là pour faire la loi faire la loi
c'est sérieux et donc je pense qu'il y a
il y a un vrai problème au delà du du
problème démocratique on peut évoquer il
y a un problème de sincérité quand même
qui a été posée on va en parler parce
que d'ailleurs on peut y aller tout de
suite cette sincérité vous allez la
remettre en cause devant le Conseil
constitutionnel vous nous dites les
socialistes les écologistes et
maintenant donc vous nous dites les
communistes vont s'associer les le
groupe de gauche pour faire un recours
au Conseil constitutionnel sur quelle
base et je pense qu'il en sera tout
autant à l'Assemblée à l'Assemblée
nationale mais sur la base de
l'insincérité pardon et nous avons bien
vu et je l'ai dit lors de ma motion que
j'avais
explicité en séance au début des travaux
il y a un certain nombre de mesures dans
cette réforme qui n'ont strictement rien
à voir un projet voilà par exemple
un projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale donc il y a plusieurs
motifs tout ça chapeauter effectivement
pour des motifs d'insincérité et de
lisibilité de la loi et je trouve que
c'est de notre responsabilité de
législateur que d'interpeller le Conseil
constitutionnel sur sur tout cela et
nous ne sommes pas le seul à le dire
puisque plusieurs grands
constitutionnalistes constatent la même
chose que nous un mot sur cette CMP
cette commission mixte paritaire ce que
vous venez de l'évoquer c'est l'étape
d'après lorsqu'il y aura eu ce vote que
l'on pense pour la soirée autour du
texte au Sénat la commission mix
paritaire cette députés cette sénateurs
qui seront réunis à partir de 9h du
matin mercredi à l'Assemblée nationale
ce sont des débats à huis clos qui ne
sont pas publiques et dont d'ailleurs on
n'a pas le retranscrit après qu'est-ce
qui peut se passer autour de cette étape
la prochaine donc autour du texte oh
vous savez cette députée cette sénateur
avec une majorité LR quand même qui se
dégage majorité LR plus c'est
qui ce qui se dégage donc on peut on
peut considérer qu'il y aurait voilà qui
sera ouvert comme on dit dans le jargon
elle sera conclusive sincèrement je
n'attends rien de cette CMP moi tout ce
que je sais c'est que même s'il y a un
accord
à la CMP et même si les conclusions
présentées le lendemain dans les deux
chambres sont adoptées je vous le dis
sincèrement la bataille n'est pas
terminée il y a d'autres outils qui sont
on est en train d'y réfléchir il y a
d'autres outils qui sont à notre
disposition et si j'ai bien lu là
je vous invite je vous invite je vous
invite à lire la déclaration de
l'intersyndicale qui s'est réunie après
la manifestation d'aujourd'hui et vous
verrez que déjà elle est bouche quelques
propositions d'initiatives et juste un
dernier mot sur cette mobilisation elle
est en 2015 des chiffres en baisse ça
vous démobilise pas vous dans la lutte
contre ce texte sincèrement aussi
attendait on s'y attendait parce que
voilà il y a quand même un état de
fatigue des des gens une question qui se
pose aussi des des interrogations sur le
vote de l'article 7 etc donc mais on
voit bien quand même enfin cet
après-midi il y avait encore des
familles avec des enfants des gens qui
n'ont pas l'habitude de manifester et de
faire grève donc non je pense que ça va
encore continuer
il est 19h17 nous sommes en direct sur
Public Sénat imaginons que des familles
comme vous dites ou même des gens
mobilisés sur sur ces manif Franck chez
elle elle allume leur télé elle voit que
le texte va être voté puisque c'est ce
que on est en train de dire dans la
soirée au Sénat qu'est-ce que vous leur
dites que la bataille n'est pas terminée
et la bataille et qu'il faut garder
espoir je pense sincèrement qu'on peut
faire flancher le gouvernement et le
président de la République sur ce sujet
et bien merci c'est sûr
merci et nous on retourne dans
l'hémicycle pour suivre les débats c'est
Corinne Ferrer qu'elle a paroles
concerné et là encore je voudrais aussi
souligner les difficultés de recrutement
pour la prise en charge des personnes
âgées qu'elles soient à domicile ou en
établissement ces difficultés sont
réelles mais comment motiver comment
donner envie comment dire à ses aides à
domicile à ses aide-soignante que tout
pourra je dirais ce métier sont deux
métiers très honorables lorsqu'il s'agit
de prendre en charge nos aînés bien
évidemment mais avec votre réforme
monsieur le ministre vous leur dites
tout autre chose vous leur dites comme à
tous et vous devrez travailler plus vous
devrez travailler deux ans de plus vous
devrez travailler jusqu'à 64 ans puisque
ce sera demain ou ce serait demain l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite alors je
vous le redis je veux je souhaite que
vous preniez enfin conscience qu'après
c'est si manifestations historiques dans
lesquelles il y avait de trop très
nombreuses femmes retenir le fait que
90% des actifs sont opposés à la
retraite à 64 ans je souhaiterais que
votre réponse ne soit plus saine du
mépris le mépris que vous avez exprimé
en comment signifier envers l'opposition
sénatoriale mais surtout le mépris du
président de la République envers les
syndicats votre projet n'est pas
légitime retirez-le merci Monsieur
Gilles et le 544
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre le cinquième risque la 5e
branche la loi grandtage globalement
votre gouvernement a abandonner le
gouvernement abandonné cette politique
majeure pour prendre en compte
l'évolution justement de notre société
ce manque de souffle ce manque
d'ambition ce manque d'anticipation en
fait est en résonance avec votre réforme
essentiellement financière ou les
paramètres sont plus importants que la
réalité sociale
autre difficulté à aborder la globalité
des étapes de la vie illustre la
faiblesse des ambitions présidentielles
à ce moment de son parcours
en ce domaine comme dans d'autres
l'absence de la négociation sociale la
faiblesse de la négociation sociale le
contournement parlementaire la volonté
permanente de légiférer en urgence
caractérise une gouvernance aux abois
soucieuse avant tout de prouver sa
capacité de réformer pour combler ses
dérives budgétaires et économique comme
la Cour des comptes et plus
particulièrement son président viennent
de le confirmer aujourd'hui ouvrant un
débat qui sans aucun doute aura sans
doute des résonances particulières dans
les semaines à venir votre réforme votre
réforme avant tout et bien c'est un
rendez-vous manqué avec les Français
c'est un rendez-vous manqué avec le
Parlement c'est un rendez-vous manqué
avec la démocratie les Français
voulaient provoquer ils s'en
souviendront retirez votre réforme elle
n'est pas légitime
merci Madame Van aigle 563
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre le manque de moyens dans les
EHPAD et dans le secteur du maintien à
domicile est considérable les besoins en
création d'emplois et en financement
sont énormes et inquiétant les
personnels sont à bout de souffle la
perte d'autonomie peut aussi être liée à
des problèmes de santé durant
l'insuffisance des mesures de prévention
des risques tout au long de la vie et
particulièrement en situation de travail
faire travailler les salariés deux ans
de plus alors que les CHSCT ont été
supprimés augmentent les risques
d'aggravation des situations difficiles
pouvant mener à la dépendance les moyens
dédiés à la branche autonomie repris
dans cet article sont ridiculement en
deçà des besoins nous en demandons la
suppression comme nous demandons au nom
des Français le retrait de votre réforme
des retraites injuste et brutal les
Français ils étaient d'ailleurs nombreux
dans la rue pour la sixième journée de
mobilisation et nous savons que 90% des
actifs sont opposés à cette réforme
cesser ce mépris envers les Français
cesser ce mépris envers les
parlementaires et demander aux
présidents Macron d'avoir le courage de
recevoir les organisations syndicales
qui demandent à le rencontrer enfin
retirez votre projet merci Monsieur
chanterelle le 662
merci monsieur le Président je vais
défendre cet amendement de suppression
de l'article 18 mais vous avez bien
compris que suite à toutes nos
interventions c'est l'ensemble du texte
que nous souhaitons supprimer bien
évidemment d'ailleurs je voulais
partager avec vous une information
importante puisque un accord vient
d'être trouvé en Espagne pour faire
davantage contribuer les hauts revenus
au régime de retraite
ça va peut-être changer tout le cours de
cet échange peut-être que vous allez
revenir sur cette réforme
alors qu'est-ce que va-t-il se passer
ils vont accroître l'assiette de
cotisation c'est à dire la part du
salaire sur laquelle les employés
cotisent en faisant augmenter le plafond
au delà duquel les salariés ne sont plus
prélevés afin de dégager des recettes
supplémentaires donc monsieur du stop
comme vous pouvez le voir en Espagne une
réforme de gauche des retraites c'est
possible mais c'est pas celle que vous
défendez la preuve que d'autres choix
politiques sont possibles et que la
raison
budgétaire dont faisait appel la
rapporteur c'est d'avoir le courage
finalement le vrai courage quand on fait
une réforme c'est pas de s'attaquer à
ceux qui en ont le moins c'est de
s'attaquer à ceux qui ont le plus
justement ça ça prend un vrai courage
parce que ça c'est difficile parce que
ce qu'on l'argent les puissants qui
financent des fois vos campagnes et qui
financent les médias ou autres ça c'est
difficile de s'attaquer à eux ça je le
reconnais le vrai courage
c'est de s'attaquer à ceux qui en ont le
plus pas à ceux qui en ont le moins et
c'est pour ça que nous vous demandons de
retirer cette réforme profondément
injuste et brutale merci le 692 madame
le héros
le vieillard sont-ils des hommes à la
manière dont notre société les traite il
est permis d'en douter c'est Simone de
Beauvoir qu'il écrivait dans son essai
La vieillesse publiée en 1970 la
parution du livre les fossoyeurs
déclenchant l'affaire hors pa en fait
une triste illustration
maltraitance institutionnels délais
d'attente faible prise en charge les
scandales se multiplient mais les moyens
alloués à l'accompagnement de nos aînés
reste insuffisants où sont les promesses
du Président Macron sur l'autonomie nous
devions avoir droit à une ambitieuse
cinquième branche et à une grande loi
sur la dépendance dans les fêtes la loi
a été abandonnée et seule quelques
mesures épars se sont frayés un chemin
dans le PLFSS la branche autonomie n'est
pas dotée des moyens suffisants pour
faire face aux immenses défis du secteur
de l'autonomie crise aiguë de
recrutement besoin de dizaines de
milliers d'embauches de hausse
drastiques du taux d'en dans les EHPAD
en 2019 le rapport Libaud estimait que
la branche autonomie nécessite un minima
6 milliards d'euros supplémentaires par
an à partir de 2024 et 9 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires par an à partir
de 2030 l'article 18 de ce projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
rectificative vient corriger à la marge
le plafond des dépenses de la branche
autonomie pour l'année 2023 une paille
au regard des besoins 240
000 recrutements en EHPAD et
amélioration du taux d'encadrement 10000
nouvelles places et revalorisation des
métiers bref des ressources qui sont
inadaptées nos anciens leur famille vous
disent et les professionnels des EHPAD
qui étaient dans la rue aujourd'hui ils
vous disent votre projet n'est pas
légitime retirez-le
et néanmoins
et il mérite autre chose que du mépris
de la part du président de la République
retirez votre projet merci Madame latrix
compta le 721 merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues c'est un monde que nous
proposons visa rejeter la rectification
de l'objectif de dépenses de la branche
autonomie cet article vient corriger à
la marge le plafond des dépenses de
cette branche pour l'année 2023 alors
que nous sommes face à un vieillissement
démographique son précédent que le
gouvernement a toujours refusé une loi
grand âge pour nous préparer
collectivement à cette évolution majeure
le budget proposé est bénin suffisant
face aux besoins réels vous voulez de
manière dogmatique et obsessionnelle
repousser l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans alors que d'autres
solutions existent nous n'avons pas
manqué depuis le début de l'examen de ce
texte de vous présenter des mesures
juste et responsables et d'autres pays
cela a été indiqué par mon collègue Yann
Chantrel en prennent le chemin vous
tentez d'imposer votre effort injuste au
terme d'un véritable passage en force on
mépris la mobilisation historique des
Françaises et des Français travailler
jusqu'à l'épuisement être malade à la
retraite voilà ce que promet votre
réforme pour un homme l'espérance de vie
et de
609,4 ans et l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé
64,4 pour une femme l'espérance de vie
et de 85,50 et en bonne santé
65,9 ans deux ans de travail en plus ça
veut dire dans beaucoup de cas pour ceux
qui ont un travail difficile une
accélération des problèmes de santé
retirer votre effort elle est injuste
merci le 802 madame de La Gontrie
défendu
merci monsieur le Président
effectivement donc un amendement donc
qui permet tout simplement suppression
par certains moments nous demandons une
suppression de l'article 18 qui fixe
l'objectif de dépenses pour la branche
autonomie d'ailleurs je me pose encore
la question et j'ai essayé de fouiller
un peu
notamment le tract au présidentiel de
Monsieur Macron il y avait des choses
sur l'autonomie figurez-vous et là je
cherche je cherche je cherche dans cette
réforme en réalité tout ce que vous
proposez c'est rajouté deux ans
supplémentaires à nos seniors donc si je
résume alors on de nous devions pardon
avoir le droit à une ambitieuse
cinquième branche et à une grande loi
sur les la dépendance
bon rien de tout ça dans les faits la
loi a été abandonnée et les seules
mesures les mesures pardon sont
totalement
totalement disparu encore une fois la
branche autonomie n'est pas dotée de
moyens suffisants pour faire face aux
immenses défis du secteur de l'automie
la crise aiguë de recrutement notamment
besoin de dizaines de milliers
d'embauche de hausse drastique du taux
d'encadrement dans les EHPAD bref le
rapport Libaud de mars 2019 estimé que
la branche autonomie nécessitait à
minima 6 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires par an à partir de 2024
et 9 milliards d'euros supplémentaires
par an à partir de 2030 pourtant les
dépenses en faveur de l'automie
progressent seulement de 2 milliards
d'euros dans ce PLFSS 2023 ce qui n'est
pas suffisant alors qu'il faudrait
240000 enfin recrutement en EHPAD et
justement une amélioration du taux
d'encadrant de 10000 places
supplémentaires et une revalidation tout
simplement des métiers du grand âge pour
une branche de l'autonomie ambitieuse
soit une enveloppe de 11 milliards
d'euros
alors puisqu'il me reste 10 secondes je
vais vous poser une question de Monsieur
le Ministre si vous avez le courage de
me répondre
les aides aux entreprises si on les
remettait au niveau de 2018 est-ce que
ça représenterait une cagnotte de 20
milliards d'euros merci Madame Lubin le
moi je voudrais juste profiter de cette
amendement pour rappeler que au tout
début aussi de la présentation de ce
projet de loi certains ministres
affirmaient que les économies réalisées
permettraient de dégager des budgets
nécessaires pour faire d'autres grandes
réformes sociales en clair on devait
faire payer aux salariés des par des
sacrifices et des réformes qui devraient
améliorer leur vie du lendemain mais
vous avez eu monsieur le ministre j'ai
eu l'occasion d'échanger rapidement avec
vous et vous m'aviez dit que ça n'était
pas votre vision des choses et je le
reconnais nous partageions cette cette
vision là parce que en fait
ce que je voudrais dire c'est que on va
demander
des sacrifices aux salariés on va
reculer l'âge de la retraite mais côté
réforme notamment
sur la dépendance côté projet de loi
dépendance côté projet de loi pour les
personnes âgées on ne voit strictement
rien venir donc je crains que d'ici la
fin du quinquennat on aille vers des
réformes qui amènent toujours du moins
mais que celles qui amène du plus et
celle que l'on doit traiter dans
l'urgence notamment celle de la
dépendance on ne les voit jamais arriver
merci Monsieur Montauger le 1299 merci
monsieur le président Richard collègue
pas plus que pour les sujets précédents
l'accident du travail maladie
professionnelle famille Honda
l'autonomie est un sujet très important
qu'il en est traité par votre
gouvernement à la hauteur des injures et
des difficultés éprouvées par beaucoup
de notre compatri de nos compatriotes en
perte d'autonomie vous avez annoncé ça
vient d'être rappelé plusieurs fois
toujours repoussé une loi sur la
dépendance et puis rien absolument rien
alors je sais que vous êtes éloigné au
ministère du Travail des des territoires
et que connaît nous beaucoup plus proche
se des territoires mais Monsieur le
Ministre allait interrogé au-delà de la
question difficile et douloureuse des
EHPAD les élus locaux en charge des CCAS
des CIAS les présidents et conseillers
communautaires de nos EPCI et les
départements les conseils départementaux
faites avec eux le point sur les besoins
de financement de leur service d'aide
accompagnement à domicile ce secteur
aussi est en train de de craquer mais
tant en question parfois la qualité de
service des usagers mais aussi les
conditions de délivrance et des services
pour les personnels intervenants donc
les conditions de travail et le rapport
le moment venu à la retraite pour eux
aucune réponse budgétaire à ces
questions
à ces questions terribles importantes
dans la branche autonomie de la sécurité
sociale que vous proposez de rectifier
ici voilà et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous demandons la suppression
de l'article 18 par cette amendement
1299 merci le 1564 madame Monnier
merci monsieur le Président donc
l'article 18 prévoit une augmentation de
100 millions d'euros des dépenses de la
branche autonomie de la sécurité sociale
alors en bonne professeur de
mathématiques je suis j'ai fait mes
petits calculs et j'ai donc pu constater
que cela représente
0,27% d'augmentation de laveloppe
globale de la branche autonomie c'est
peu c'est peu et des années lumières des
besoins réels et des moyens que nous
devrons mobiliser pour faire face au
vieillissement de la population ce n'est
pas avec ces 100 millions que nous
permettrons à chacun à chacune de vivre
le vieillissement avec sérénité et de
profiter de sa retraite en bonne santé
avec une réelle capacité d'autonomie
nous devons nous donner les moyens pour
que tout et tous puissent profiter de
ces années de repos bien mérité alors
pourquoi pourquoi avoir choisi de faire
porter cette réforme des retraites par
un projet de loi de finance de la
sécurité sociale rectificative si ce
n'était pas pour tenter de répondre
aussi à cette question de l'autonomie
des seniors qui est lié
[Musique]
oui merci monsieur le Président vous
parlez sans cesse du virage domiciliaire
oui les Français préfèrent terminer leur
vie à domicile mais pour cela il faut
une véritable politique publique mise en
place d'un service d'aide à la personne
digne ce nom or nous connaissons les
difficultés des stades des siads le
manque de personnel essentiellement
parce que c'est un personnel non reconnu
avec des salaires de misère ou est donc
passé ce projet de grande loi dépendance
cognitive du budget la cinquième branche
certes créée mais sans moyen
je ne reviendrai pas mes collègues l'ont
fait sur le scandale des EHPAD privés la
marchandisation de la dépendance de la
dépendance et déjà arrivé quelle honte
alors un vrai budget pour un vrai budget
il faut des moyens nous vous avons
proposé différentes ressources que vous
refusez car effectivement il s'agit de
taxer les burich et cela vous n'en
voulez pas votre réforme est injuste et
nous nous n'en voulons pas merci Madame
meunier le 1773 à la retour à salle des
conférences j'accueille sur René Paul
Savary bonjour bonjour on arrive à la
dernière dans la dernière ligne droite
de l'examen j'espère
que c'est indéniable c'est sa varie
restait assez peu d'amendements vous
allez donc voter ce soir vous aurez
réussi le pari de tenir 11 jours
l'examen alors qu'il y avait plusieurs
milliers d'amendements 4700 alors certes
seul 3700 était recevable mais ça
restait un nombre conséquent et vous
êtes allé vous arrivez au bout de de ce
chiffre un chiffre
pourrait qualifier ce parcours de
Marathon je dirais plutôt sur une course
d'obstacles parce que il y a eu vraiment
une volonté d'obstruction parfois de
l'opposition
un peu contrarié les débats parce que
on a eu beaucoup beaucoup d'heures de
monologues et peu d'heures de véritable
débats mais quand il y a eu ces heures
de débat c'était particulièrement
intéressant au final sur 11 jours des
moments où on est sur le fond du texte
où il y a des échanges sur la surcote
pour les femmes sur aussi la retraite
par capitalisation absolument
et d'un seul coup le débat qui vrai
voilà à cause de recours au Règlement
mais alors la faute à qui peu importe la
faute c'est pas ce qui intéresse je
pense que c'est dommage parce qu'on se
prive de débats dans des sujets
importants
regardez les sur les régimes spéciaux où
on avait des des différences d'approches
et on pouvait s'expliquer c'est ça
paraît des sujets importants et quand il
y a de la confrontation il y a du fond
il y a de la réflexion c'est pas celui
qui a raison celui 14 c'est pas blanc
c'est pas noir c'est toujours des
échanges qui permettent d'enrichir mais
enfin globalement nous avons et nous en
sommes fiers
qui a donné le volet de justice sociale
qui manquait cette réforme vous pensez
notamment à la surcotte pour les femmes
pour les femmes des mesures en ce qui
concerne la fraude sociale qui sont
significatives des avancées notamment
dans la retraite progressive dans la
capacité permanente des 60 ans aux
Français qui étaient mobilisés
aujourd'hui qui peut-être rentre chez
eux et allume Public Sénat le rapporteur
du texte ici au Sénat que vous que vous
êtes qui parle au nom de la commission
il y a dans ce texte de quoi les
rassurer et qui qui peut répondre à
leurs inquiétudes eux qui se sont
mobilisés dans la rue aujourd'hui bah
écoutez j'ai le sentiment qu'on répond à
quelques inquiétudes alors pas toutes on
a bien compris que la borne d'âge était
quand même un facteur
déclenchement voilà qui a été
difficilement accepté bien entendu nous
nous pensons que c'est indispensable
parce que il faut équilibrer notre
système de retraite il faut penser plus
tard à nos enfants qui ont besoin de du
dispositif c'est c'est la clé de la
répartition c'est pour ça que on insiste
mais on a pu adoucir je dirais et faire
en sorte que il y ait un certain nombre
d'avancées qui prennent en compte
justement si on demande un effort
collectif supplémentaire il faut bien
maintenant on en compte ce qui ont qui
sont usés et notamment quand des
facteurs de pénibilité parce que
effectivement c'est là que cette
dimension leur permettra de rendre ce
délai plus long au travail plus
acceptable la gauche dit que vous n'avez
jamais essayé de taxer le capital
notamment dans les communistes c'était
quelque chose qui était impossible même
à une part d'une cotisation sur les pour
les employeurs il est pas moyen de
trouver des sources de financement aussi
de la part des entreprises qui
finalement ne mettent pas la main à la
poche dans cette réforme écoutez on peut
toujours
mettre toujours plus d'argent quand vous
avez un système par répartition quand
vous avez moins de cotisants et de plus
en plus de retraités avec une retraite
qui dure de plus en plus longtemps c'est
plus une d'argent c'est une question
d'équilibre qui permet que le système
paraît parti sont par définition est un
système contributif que s'il y a ce
déséquilibre si vous financez par
l'impôt par la dette et bien le système
n'est plus solidaire voilà le principe
de la répartition est un principe
solidaire entre les actifs les retraités
et entre ceux qui travaillent et ceux
qui profitent de leur retraite à juste
titre
si vous le voulez bien on a vu que la
gauche vous accuse avec notamment la
présidente de la commission d'affaires
sociales d'avoir porté atteinte à la
sincérité des débats en utilisant le
règlement du Sénat en jugeant il
recevable certains de leurs amendements
de façon hâtive avec une réunion très
rapide de la commission des affaires
sociales est-ce que vous craignez un
recours devant le Conseil
constitutionnel de ces trois groupes de
gauche absolument pas
ils peuvent mettre le texte au Conseil
constitutionnel c'est bien on je suis
très intéressé par l'anime non non nous
n'avons pas rougir de ce que nous avons
fait quand vous avez 3000 amendements
qui vous sont livrés dans les 5 minutes
avant le débat il s'agit de les analyser
ou les c'est vrai qu'il faut les lire
rapidement mais ils sont tous identiques
alors vous savez ça prend pas trop de
temps ça vous inquiète pas donc non pas
du tout
débat merci René d'être venu à notre
micro on retourne dans l'hémicycle il
reste environ 20 minutes avant la
suspension pour la pose dîner
90% des actifs sont opposés à la
retraite à 64 ans et votre seule réponse
monsieur le ministre reste le mépris je
veux souligner d'ailleurs que le
Président de la République a osé quand
même dire qu'il ne répondait pas à la
demande des syndicats parce que le temps
était au Parlement le jour même où vous
avez proposé le vote bloqué et bien le
mépris c'est ça merci le 1931 monsieur
Joly
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues peut-être
rappeler les enjeux de ce qu'il y a
derrière les chiffres de cet article 18
2 millions 500 000 personnes en paire
d'autonomie aujourd'hui 4 millions en
2050 le sujet devant nous si cela
concerne les plus âgés parmi les
personnes âgées puisque 30% début de 75
ans sont concernés par ces pets
d'autonomie
6,6% aussi sont concernés sur la tranche
6075 ans donc on mesure les conséquences
que peut avoir effectivement la pro le
report de de l'âge de la retraite elle
s'ajoute à ça les disparités sociales
liées aux métiers exercés et qui ont des
conséquences sur l'usure des individus
et les disparités territoriales au
regard de la part que représente les
personnes âgées sur les sur les sur les
populations des territoires la question
est devant nous je le disais on
regardait du nombre de personnes qui
seront en perte d'autonomie dans les
années à venir le travail de réflexion
et les les
innovations à mettre en oeuvre à la fois
dans l'organisation des services en les
modalités de prise en charge de ces
personnes doivent être effectués les
pertes d'autonomie sont progressives
effectivement et nécessitent
l'adaptation effectivement de cette
prise en charge accompagnement à des
missiles alternatives
résidentielle EHPAD du futur qui va nous
falloir arriver envisager à la fois dans
une approche et d'établissements mais
également territorial d'où l'intérêt
rapidement de travailler sur dans cette
perspective à travers une l'adoption
d'une loi à grande âge il y a
véritablement une urgence à traiter de
cette question sociétale
et Monsieur Tissot le 2292 bonjour
Raymonde poncémonge merci de m'avoir
rejoint en salle des conférences pour
une intervention une interview avant la
fin et 20h qui va suspendre pour le
dîner on vous a beaucoup entendu pendant
ces 10 jours vous avez été une des
heures à tristes les plus acharnés pour
défendre vos points de vue on vous a
même donné le maillot jaune l'opposition
vous l'avez vous la décerné pour vos
efforts et cet été le meilleur point
pour la grimpe qu'est-ce que vous
retenez qu'est-ce que vous retiendrez
vous de ces 10 jours de débats puisque
ils vont se terminer bientôt on arrive
au 100 derniers amendements de l'examen
de cette réforme qu'est-ce que vous en
retenez vous ben écoutez j'en retiens
que effectivement il y a une loi qui
manque qui a traversé tous ces débats
c'est la loi travail c'est-à-dire que
vous avez là une mesure qui est
essentiellement financière qui va peser
qui est très antisocial qui va peser sur
le monde du travail
pour nous et que écologiste de plus qui
est productivisme mais je veux dire avec
une sorte de point aveugle qui est la
loi travail qui aurait dû la précéder le
gouvernement dit qu'effectivement il y
en a une puisque vous venez de le
mentionner une à une au printemps vous
dites on a mis la charrue avant les
bœufs on a fait la mesure la plus
contraignante et qui va affecter la vie
des Français sans penser à tous les
problèmes autour du rapport au travail
qui ont été soulevés pendant ces débats
c'est bien ça oui c'est ça les les tout
ce qui concerne le travail a été mis
dans les fameuses mesures d'atténuation
donc qu'on appelle de la brutalité de la
réforme avec l'index qui va certainement
sortir par le Conseil constitutionnel
parce que c'est une sorte de cavalier
et avec aussi sur la pénibilité par
exemple ce que ce fond qu'on a créé
le compte de pénibilité la pénibilité du
travail si vous voulez l'intensification
du travail il fallait il fallait en
discuter avant que vous pouvez pas
ajouter deux ans d'un travail dont vous
n'avez pas analysé la nature
comme ça c'est pas c'est quantitatif
alors que l'analyse qualitative du
travail devait devait le presser on
vient de passer à 100 102 amendements et
qui reste à examiner quand on met autant
d'efforts à s'opposer à une telle à une
telle réforme puisque la vie est déposée
des centaines d'amendements que vous
avez tous défendus pendant 10 jours
pendant ces centaines d'heures cette
centaine d'heures de débat qu'est-ce que
vous retenez entre l'investissement
personnel que ça vous a coûté dans
l'hémicycle et le rendu et la droite qui
passe cette réforme bah écoutez
effectivement il y a une grande
frustration parce qu'on nous a reproché
le nombre d'amendements mais c'est
logique par rapport à ce que je vous ai
dit il y a beaucoup d'amendements qui te
qui parlaient du travail effectivement
moi du moins j'ai bien dit que le groupe
écologiste a traversé amendements était
capable de les défendre avec pertinence
mais donc à la fin une frustration
puisque d'abord on termine par un
exercice quand même particulier qui est
ce monologue on présente un amendement
donc on est au début du droit
d'amendement on nous répondant le
rapporteur que le ministre mais ne sont
pas intégrés pour répondre après et
surtout ils sont pas intégrés au texte
puisqu'il y a le bloquer mais non
seulement ça mais c'est quand même
absolument sur le plan bien sûr qu'ils
ont le droit de faire comme ça mais sur
le plan de l'honnêteté intellectuelle je
trouve qu'il y a un vrai problème du
débat intellectuel sur un texte comment
on peut pas répondre à la réponse qui
font à notre amendement de monsieur le
rapporteur que du ministre moi je trouve
qu'il devrait se limiter à dire
favorable ou défavorable mais qui
devrait pas commenter parce que
dernièrement le ministre davantage
encore sur les ATMP si vous voulez me
répondre et moi alors j'attends la loi
travail enfin c'est vraiment pas correct
intellectuellement frustré et je trouve
mécontente quant à la méthode un dernier
mot on a eu cette journée de
mobilisation qui est effectivement un
peu en berne vous qui suit c'est une
défaite politique c'est une journée
noire sur cette réforme des retraites
pour l'opposition au texte non mais vous
savez sur la journée d'aujourd'hui
moi demande dans les rues oui mais je
trouve qu'elle a été très peu popularisé
je connais beaucoup de personnes qui ne
la connaissaient pas le 7 a beaucoup
mobilisé quoi ça veut rien dire je crois
qu'il y a aussi une journée qui sera
autour de la de la CMP mercredi oui je
pense vraiment que pour pour la droite
et pour le gouvernement ils ont fait le
plus facile à savoir avec des méthodes
de contournement procédurier faire voter
la loi mais ça s'arrêtera pas la
mobilisation je suis convaincu il ira
jusqu'au retrait de cette loi eh bien
voilà c'est sur ces mots que se termine
cette interview merci Raymond de penser
vous êtes sénatrice à écologiste du
Rhône nous on retourne dans l'hémistique
pour écouter la fin de ces débats
notre amendement de suppression et pour
compléter malgré les manifestations
historiques les 90% des actifs qui sont
opposés à la retraite à 64 ans votre
seule réponse c'est le mépris mépris
envers l'opposition sénatoriale et
surtout mépris du président de la
République envers les syndicats qu'il
refuse de recevoir mépris envers les
salariés et les Français votre projet
n'est pas légitime retirez-le merci
merci Madame la rapporteur général
le Président Monsieur
les ma chère collègues
gues la commission des affaires sociales
a émis un avis défavorable sur ses
amendements de suppression mais je
voulais revenir sur cette branche
autonomie sur laquelle vous avez posé un
certain nombre de sujets et de problèmes
c'est vrai que cette branche est
déficitaire là on est sur les dépenses
c'est des objectifs de dépenses mais
cependant je voudrais dire combien
effectivement nous sommes tous mobilisés
autour de cette branche autonomie qui
est certes pas suffisante par rapport à
une loi que nous aurions souhaité les
uns et les autres pour essayer
d'anticiper parce que maintenant je peux
plus parler d'anticipation sur le
vieillissement de la population et ça a
vraiment beaucoup de liens avec
l'ensemble des propos qu'on a tenus ici
dans cette hémicycle concernant les
retraites elle est déficitaire à moins
1,4 milliards d'euros pour l'année 2023
c'est un petit peu plus que l'année de
2022 mais je voudrais vous rappeler que
dans la loi de août 2020 nous avions
voté un point de
0,15 points de CSG qui sera versé à
partir de 2024
de la part de la cadette et donc ça
permettra la CNSA de se retrouver en
capacité financière avec 0,7 milliards
d'euros ça permettra de financer alors
on a parlé des places en EHPAD ce sera
environ 50 mille euros de places en
EHPAD 50000 places en EHPAD et puis
d'autres formes d'aide pour les
personnes qui sont à domicile je
voudrais simplement indiquer que cette
branche sera donc aussi en capacité de
prendre en charge c'est trimestres pour
les les comment les temps
vis-à-vis des
enfin en tant qu'aidant et donc
ça permettra cette financer cette
comment cette dépense supplémentaire en
tout cas
je crois que je suis arrivé au terme de
ce que je voulais vous dire donc merci
le ministre
pour vous confirmer madame la sénatrice
que pas un euro de cotisation de
financera autre chose que des retraites
lorsqu'on a un déficit de 13 milliards 5
en 2030 il faut déjà combler ce déficit
il faut financer les mesures nouvelles
et donc pas à nouveau de cotisation
vieillesse ne sert à autre chose que des
retraites par contre si collectivement
nous travaillons plus à la fois plus à
l'échelle d'une vie et plus nombreux à
travailler évidemment ça génère d'autres
cotisations ça génère d'autres recettes
en matière fiscale ou sociale qui
peuvent donner des marges pour financer
d'autres politiques mais pas à neuro de
cotisation vieillesse c'est à autre
chose que financer le système de
retraite
merci
le 3242 madame ponce ah pardon monsieur
président merci monsieur le président
49.37 ans 44 2 44 3 article 38 avec 42
62 à 64 ans déficit à 300% comme un
dogme vous aimez les chiffres on peut le
dire surtout quand il vous arrange vous
aimez les chiffres quand ils profitent
au plus riche vous aimez les chiffres
quand ils s'agit de milliards pour
quelques-uns vous aimez les chiffres
parce que tout simplement vous n'aimez
pas les gens 11 milliards 11 millions
c'est le nombre de personnes pauvres en
France la moitié sont des femmes
17% de la population vit sous le seuil
de pauvreté oui derrière ces chiffres
des gens des vies
cette réforme votre verre et forme va
agréer pardon encore plus la vie des
plus pauvres à 64 ans un tiers des plus
pauvres un tiers de ceux qui ont les
métiers les plus difficiles sont déjà
morts ils auront cotisé pourtant toute
une vie pour payer la retraite des
générations précédentes cette réforme
retire tout simplement de la vie au plus
pauvres cette réforme institutionnalise
institutionnalise l'injustice les plus
riches pourront échapper à votre effort
les pauvres non votre réforme va
précariser les plus âgées et les plus
pauvres et pénaliser les jeunes et les
femmes
c'est le nombre de manifestations
historiques dans le pays un million le
nombre de signataires aujourd'hui pour
une consultation citoyenne 90% c'est le
nombre d'actifs contre votre effort pour
une fois s'il vous plaît écoutez les
gens écouter ces gens-là et retirer
votre réforme merci Madame la rapporteur
madame la rapporteur général défavorable
monsieur le ministre défavorable mes
chers collègues il nous étions à 663
amendements au début de l'après-midi il
nous en reste 100 à faire je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
21h30 pour la suite de l'examen de ce
texte la séance est suspendue
voilà
19h55 sur antenne de Public Sénat et la
séance qui est levée pour la pause dîner
on s'oriente un verre un vote de la
réforme après cette pause dîner donc au
retour à 21h30 on va faire le bilan de
cette dixième journée d'examen de la
réforme des retraites au Sénat avec
notre journaliste Mathias ares Mathias
vous êtes avec nous depuis cet
après-midi racontez-nous cette journée
s'il vous plaît et bien écoutez ça y est
Quentin on rentre dans la dernière ligne
droite sauf retournement de situation le
texte devient devrait bien être mise au
voie ce soir et ce notamment grâce à une
délices de l'obstruction cordiale menée
par la gauche depuis le début des débats
ne soutenant plus tous ces amendements
soit tout simplement en étant absent
voire même par renoncement comme on a pu
le voir plusieurs fois une gauche qui
elle la surpourtan elle n'a pas rendu
les armes
si vous avez une victoire dans les
heures qui viennent qui est fort
probable une victoire à la perruche ou
je ne sais pas à quoi en tout cas sachez
que si nous avons résisté si nous
résistons nous continuerons à résister
contre cette réforme dont les Français
ne veulent pas ils ont encore exprimer
tout à l'heure une réforme qui est
marquée par le mépris le mépris du
président de la République vis-à-vis
notamment du monde syndical finalement
ça n'est que la réplique de son
quinquennat précédent vous n'avez pas
respecté les corps intermédiaires et
bien donc malgré votre fatigue malgré
aussi notre fatigue parce qu'on parle un
peu plus que vous vous l'avez compris
nous continuerons à être présent nous
continuerons à être présent dans cette
hémicycle pour dire non à cette réforme
il faut la retirer
par ailleurs les groupes de gauche l'ont
confirmé un autre micro un nouveau
combat s'ouvre au Conseil
constitutionnel il y a un certain nombre
de mesures dans cette réforme qui n'ont
strictement rien à voir un projet voilà
par exemple rien à voir avec un projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale donc il y a plusieurs motifs
tout ça chapeauter effectivement pour
des motifs d'insincérité et de
lisibilité de la loi et je trouve que
c'est de notre responsabilités de
législateur que d'interpeller le Conseil
constitutionnel sur surtout cela et nous
ne sommes pas le seul à le dire puisque
plusieurs grands constitutionnalistes
constatent la même chose que nous pour
ce qui est de la vie du texte ici dans
l'hémicycle après la reprise on se
dirige vers la fin de l'examen des
amendements puis nous passerons aux
explications de vote 7 minutes par
groupe pendant donc environ une grosseur
avant le vote solennelle voilà merci
Mathias pour tous ces explications et on
le comprend avec ce que vous venez de
dire tout va se jouer donc ce soir à la
reprise de la séance à 21h30 le Sénat
qui devrait adopter en tout cas voter
autour de la réforme ce soir ce sera à
vivre bien sûr comme depuis le début de
l'examen de cette réforme au Sénat en
direct sur notre antenne retour de ce
grand direct avec alexandre Poussin et
vous maintient Saez à 21h30 merci merci
à tous de nous suivre très nombreux
depuis 10 jours merci aussi aux équipes
techniques et éditoriales qui permettent
ce grand direct depuis 10 jours et
n'hésitez pas à lire les articles de la
rédaction avec les décryptages les tous
derniers sur public sénat.fr très belle
suite